Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Hast du dein Disney Plus Account gekündigt?
Aus beruflichen Gründen kann ich es nicht tun.
Das heißt, du gehst nicht ganz mit dem Zeitgeist und machst alles, was dir vor Augen in die Ohren und ins Gemüt kommt, eine staatspolitische Aufgabe, die du natürlich sofort bewältigst.
Nun, es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass Konsumentenprotest in diesem Falle, also wir reden ja über den Fall Jimmy Kimmel, etwas bewirkt haben könnte. Es gibt natürlich sehr viele, die protestiert haben, die laut geworden sind gegenüber Disney, ABC und so weiter. Aber was ja wohl auch, natürlich vom Konzern nicht bestätigt wurde, aber was Insider berichtet haben, stattgefunden hat, ist, dass Menschen ihre Disney Plus Accounts gekündigt haben. Und wir wissen, dass die Unternehmen unglaublich viel Werbegeld in die Hand nehmen, um an neue Abonnenten zu kommen, weil die Abonnenten bleiben dann lange dabei, etc. Also Abonnenten zu verlieren, ist eine sehr heikle Angelegenheit, vor allem für einen Konzern, der diese Abonnentenzahlen benötigt, um dann auch die entsprechenden Quartalsergebnisse vorstellen zu können, um zu sagen, hier, wir haben weiterhin Wachstum. Und eigentlich sah es ja auch bei Disney Plus ganz gut aus. Und jetzt aber kann natürlich das dazu führen, wenn dann sagen wir, müssen ja nur drei Prozent oder so sein, sagen wir kündigen das, dann hat das schon einen Ausstieg. Und wenn Scott Galloway beispielsweise in seinem Podcast, den sehr viele Menschen hören, darüber berichtet, dass er heute morgen 20 Minuten gebraucht hat, hat es aber endlich geschafft, sein Disney Plus Abo zu kündigen, dann hat das schon einen Nachahmereffekt. Und ich glaube, auf diesen speziellen Fall angewendet kann wirklich Konsumenten-Protest tauglich sein. Ich kann es nicht machen, weil ich nun gewisse Dinge sehen muss, sonst kann ich sie nicht mehr besprechen. Deswegen ist Disney Plus für mich da, wenn gleich ich jetzt gerade darüber nachdenke, wann habe ich zuletzt was bei Disney Plus gesehen?
Also nicht Alien Earth gesehen.
Es ist jetzt auch schon wieder drei Monate her, ja. Also wahrscheinlich hätte ich es jetzt auch mal gerade kündigen können. Dann muss ich aber vielleicht nächsten Monat wieder rein, weil dann irgendein wichtiger Film kommt dort. Aber jedenfalls, die meisten Leute sind ja nicht in der Situation, wie ich es bin. Bedeutet also, hier hat ein Konsumenten-Protest eine gewisse Wirkung gehabt?
Ich bin da skeptisch, sympathisiere aber mit diesem Gedanken. Ich habe natürlich Scott Galloys Anmerkungen dazu gehört. Es war, finde ich, Wunschdenken im Sinne von, wenn wir schon sonst nichts ausrichten können, wenigstens mit Geld einhalten, kann man noch was ausmachen. Glaube ich nicht so richtig dran, denn...
Ich glaube, es geht nur in diesem Fall. Also Scott Gallaway hat ja dann ausgeführt, dass er überlegt, ob er sein Geld weiter transferiert an europäische Banken. Und wenn das alle Konsumenten machen würden, also beziehungsweise die obersten zehn Prozent, dann hätte das eine besondere Schlagkraft auf die Wirtschaft und die Binnenkonjunktur würde schwächeln und dann würde die amerikanische Regierung in Erwägung ziehen, ihre Politik zu ändern. Das glaube ich alles nicht. Ich glaube auch gar nicht, dass sich so eine Mobilisierung da in Gang setzt. Ja, der kann deswegen mehr verschieben von der American Bank hin zur Deutschen Bank oder was weiß ich, sein Geld. Aber das wird nicht irgendeinen Auschlag haben. Ich glaube, es geht nur hier ganz konkret, wo man sagen kann, wir haben Abonnenten. Wir sehen ja Peaks nach oben, wenn die neue Star-Wars-Serie oder so kommt und dann sieht man plötzlich Kimmel, darf nicht mehr. Jetzt springen Leute innerhalb von drei Tagen ab, wie wir das sonst nie sehen. Und dann kann man plötzlich sagen, ach du je, das hat ja richtig viel Geld gekostet, dass wir jetzt diesen Skandal da losgetreten haben. Darüber hinaus bin ich niemand, der an große Konsumentenproteste glaubt und auch diese ganzen Boykottgeschichten, die da mal da und dort herbeigerufen werden, zeigen nicht besonders viele Wirkungen. Wir können ja sogar sehen, dass Sanktionen nicht besonders wirksam sind. Wir haben das ja auch geglaubt, dass es wirksamer ist. Hätten sie aber auch ja wissen können, in diesem Buch über Sanktionen von Nicholas Mulder, dass er damals zeitgleich rauskam mit Russlandskrieg gegen die Ukraine. Dort stand ja schon so als Fazit drin, er erzählt ja 100 Jahre Sanktionsgeschichte. Wir stellen fest, es gibt immer mehr Sanktionen gegen Länder, aber sie werden immer weniger wirksam. Und das scheint sich auch zu bestätigen. Ich glaube, wo es ganz konkret ist, wo Leute sagen, ich deaboniere dich jetzt hier, ich deaboniere Disney Plus, weil ihr so und so verfahren seid mit Jimmy Kimmel, da kann es eine Wirkung haben. Darüber hinaus, glaube ich, ist das, wie du sagst, Wunschdenken.
Also ich glaube, um diesen kurzen Exkurs auch von gleich wieder zuzumachen, die Russlandsanktionen wirken viel mehr, als wir glauben. Wir können sie natürlich nach unseren Gesichtspunkten verrechnen, aber die schlagen da schon richtig rein. Nur ist die staatliche Repression noch krasser in Russland und die haben natürlich China im Hintergrund. Und wir sind natürlich jetzt gerade dran gewöhnt, dass wir immer direkt erfahren, wenn was passiert, weil Donald Trump direkt darüber twittert oder wie auch immer. Truth. Nur in China passiert ja genauso viel, nur erfahren wir es da nicht. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass deswegen da weniger passiert. Und ich glaube, die Allianz zwischen Russland und China ist stark genug, um einfach europäische Sanktionen und amerikanische Halbherzigkeit auszubleiben.
Also das meine ich damit nicht mit wirksam. Also natürlich hat das eine starke Wirkung auf die russische Volkswirtschaft, wenn jetzt plötzlich Europa da sagt, ne, wir machen keinen Handel mehr. Das auf jeden Fall nur wirksam im Sinne von, deshalb wird Putin den Krieg schneller beenden oder wird dastehen und sagen, ich muss mich vor meiner Bevölkerung verantworten, ich kann nicht mehr, wir hören jetzt auf damit. Das war ja gedacht bei diesen Sanktionspaketen, die man da alle aufgelegt hat, die auch zum Teil ja sehr halbherzig waren. Man hat ja dann erst mal in Schritt 17 das getan, was eigentlich der erste Schritt hätte sein sollen. Das war schon ein bisschen obskur.
Na ja, man hat es im Schritt 18 geplant.
Jedenfalls ist es dann so, dass genau sich diese neuen Wege ergeben. Und das ist eine Erkenntnis auch von Nicolas Mulder, dass in dem Sinne die Sanktionen nicht mehr wirksam sind, dass man einfach sagen kann, ich erpresse dich jetzt damit und dann wirst du entsprechend gehorsam sein, sondern du findest einfach einen neuen Weg dann für deine Wirtschaft. Und das zeigt, wie wenig dann Sanktionen wirken in dieser Hinsicht.
Okay, und jetzt würde ich die große Klammer noch mal schließen, indem ich, ich höre schon wieder Kritiker, die dir und mir zuhören und mir dann unterstellen, ich sehe die Tragweite von ökonomischem Handeln auch des Einzelnen nicht, auch wenn man es erst aufsummieren muss, also wenn viele ihr Disney Plus kündigen und so. Wir werden nämlich das Thema heute durchschleifen, denn es steckt in Charlie Kirk ganz massiv drin, wenn wir dem großen politischen Vordenker Amerikas glauben, Tucker Carlson, ist das, was jetzt gerade passiert, der allerletzte Versuch, noch Gesellschaft zu gestalten und um die ökonomischen Fragestellungen drumherum zu kommen. Also der nächste Revolutionsversuch, wir sehen es ja schon ein bisschen bei Mamdani, der einfach sagt, ich treibe die Supermärkte selbst als Bürgermeister, geht dann in diese Richtung, weil alle anderen, und wir gehen heute sehr auf diesen religiösen Weg, den die Amerikaner nochmal einschlagen ein, weil die dann ausgetrampelt sind als Weg. Und in der Hinsicht, ja, ich bin sehr überzeugt von der Wirkmächtigkeit ökonomischer Diskurse, insbesondere wenn dann endlich mal, durchaus affirmativ gemeint, jeder Einzelne, wenn auch nicht daran teilnimmt, zumindest darüber weiß, welche Handlungsmöglichkeiten er hat und welche Tragweite, aber bei diesem Kimmelding sehe ich es noch nicht. Sondern da würde ich sagen, da war sehr viel wichtiger, wie Scott Galloway über Bob Iger in seinem Podcast gesprochen hat.
Das wahrscheinlich auch.
Ich nehme mich wirklich fünf Minuten lang als, okay, es gibt Tyrannen und das sehen wir auch, aber dann gibt es diejenigen, die das alles unterstützen und einfach voraus eilend mitdenken, mitmachen. Und in dieser Situation, da will ich Bob Iger nicht sehen.
Es war ja auch Ökonomie. Also es war ja nicht, dass irgendjemand von Disney oder den Untergruppen da sagte, das ist uns jetzt moralisch irgendwie schwierig.
Bob Iger würde ich da noch mal ein bisschen einklammern in dieses Geschichtsbilddenken.
Bob Iger ist ja der, der sehr stark diese ganzen Diversity-Geschichten bei Disney beschleunigt und gestärkt hat.
Die lögen ja auch mit einer gewissen moralischen Überzeugung.
Ja, aber das zeigt ja dann ist er ja eher nicht auf der republikanischen Seite an sich. Ich würde eher sagen, dass das, was jetzt gerade da passiert ist mit Jimmy Kimmel, ist ja einfach die Frage, wird man dann die Fusionen, die man vorhat? Ja, also es gibt ja einfach Fusionspläne, die müssen von der US-Regierung oder von den Behörden abgesegnet werden und bringt man diese in Gefahr? Das heißt also bringt man die künftigen Millionen Milliarden Geschäfte in Gefahr oder kann man sich da ein gut Freund machen, indem man Kimmel entlässt, weil die Trump-Administration den unterhinsicht leiden kann? Das war ja die Rechnung, die da aufgemacht wurde. Und da hat man aber dann, glaube ich, ein bisschen die Rechnung ohne den Verbraucher gemacht und ohne die Öffentlichkeit, die dann doch bei solchen Galionsfiguren plötzlich in anderer Weise aufschreckt. Also es war ja dann doch auch von konservativer Seite, eine Kritik daran zu vernehmen. Bedeutet also, wenn man diese Schlachtrösser da plötzlich so freisetzt, dann hat man tatsächlich diese große Gefahr, dass die Öffentlichkeit sauer wird. Denn zugleich finden ja diese ganzen Angriffe gegen Free Speech in den USA weiter statt, ohne irgendwelche großen Proteste. Das heißt, man hat jetzt quasi wieder so einen liberalen Frieden hergestellt, aber der große Free Speech-Kampf oder Kampf gegen Free Speech, der findet ja nach wie vor statt an Universitäten und sonst wo.
Da sollten wir uns eh nicht ablenken lassen. Das, was wir jetzt besprochen haben, ist Fernsehgeschäft. Es ist eh die Frage, warum interessiert das noch jemanden? Wichtiger ist ja, dass die drei reichsten Männer der Welt jetzt die größten Netzwerke der Welt besitzen, also Mark Zuckerberg, Alison und Elon Musk. Aber darauf kommen wir später zu sprechen. Du willst mit Gaza beginnen?
Ja, kurz mit eigentlich nur einer Abbildung der deutschen Debatten. Wir hören jetzt erst hier ein kurzes Interview im RBB. Die haben von den Gaza-Protesten in Berlin berichtet. Hören wir Michael Barenboim. Er ist nicht nur der Sohn von Daniel Barenboim, dem berühmten Irrigenten, sondern er ist ein Geiger, der sich zugleich aber auch politisch laufend einmischt. Und er wird hier interviewt und sagt Folgendes.
Deutschland ist verpflichtet, Genozid zu verhindern und zu bestrafen, so wie alle anderen 153 Staaten, die die Genozid-Konvention unterschrieben haben. Und dafür stehen wir hier. Wir wollen, dass Deutschland aufhört, Genozid zu unterstützen.
Nun ist der Begriff des Genozids höchst umstritten, Kritiker sagen, das ist Wasser auf die Mühlen von Antisemiten.
Das halte ich für eine verrückte Behauptung, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Fast alle Menschenrechtsorganisationen, fast alle Experten sind sich mittlerweile einig, dass Genozid an Palästinenser in den Gaza verübt wird von Israel. Das kann man nicht mehr ernst nehmen.
Der Öffentlich-Rechtliche Rundfunk mit seinem Begriff Fetisch, sage ich mal. Die Tagesschau spricht ja nicht von Palästina, sondern sie sagt immer Palästinenserstaat. Und da sitzen natürlich alle vorm Fernseher und fragen sich ein bisschen, was soll der Quatsch? Also ich finde es ein bisschen witzig.
Ja, es ist ja ganz interessant, wenn man es jetzt vergleicht. Mir geht es jetzt eigentlich darum, denn natürlich sind Gerichte es am Ende, die etwas klären und sagen, so ist es gewesen. Aber mir geht es darum, wie diese deutschen Debatten da verfolgt werden. Denn tatsächlich ist es ja so, dass man sich ansehen kann. Es gibt ein Netzwerk juristischer Fakultäten, Boston, Cornell, Yale darunter, die also Mai 24 gesagt haben, dass diese Handlungen in Gaza von Israel-Völkermord-Konventionen verletzen. Dann gibt es European Center for Constitution and Human Rights. Da gibt es eine Analyse, die kommt zu dem Schluss, dass da ein Genozid an Palästinenser verübt wird. Dann gibt es Bezalem und Ärzte für Menschenrechte Israel, die sagen in ihrem Bericht Ähnliches. Dann gibt es noch die Unabhängige Untersuchungskommission des UN-Menschenrechtsrats. Da heißt es, eine UN-Menschenrechtsrat eingesetzte Kommission kam in einer juristischen Analyse zu dem Schluss, dass Israel ein Genozid im Gazastreifen begehe. Und dann gibt es noch Amnesty International. Und jetzt sind das alles Expertenberichte, die im Nachhinein dann bei Gerichten bediegt die Entscheidung, was ist jetzt da vorgefallen. Die Sache ist ja nur, auch wenn ich was im Nachhinein sagen kann erst, kann ich ja trotzdem sagen, ich muss also jetzt präventiv vorgehen, bin aber dann verwundert über die deutsche Debatte, die ja dann so aussieht, dass zum Beispiel Katrin Eigendorf zugeschaltet ist beim ZDF und auch darauf angesprochen wird, was ist denn nun jetzt da in Israel und eigentlich auf ein anderes Thema gerne zu sprechen kommen möchte, bei dem ich wirklich sagen muss, also dann müssen wir sagen, reden wir über Doppelstandards.
Der Begriff Völkermord ist ja ein juristisch definierter Begriff, über den letztendlich Gerichte entscheiden müssen. Also es wird hoffentlich irgendwann ein Verfahren geben gegen die Verantwortlichen, wo festgestellt werden muss, handelt es sich hier um Völkermord. Aber wenn es um die Politik der israelischen Regierung geht, habe ich das Gefühl, ist dieser Begriff Völkermord ja nicht erst jetzt, sondern schon kurz nach Beginn des Krieges in Gaza immer wieder in aller Munde. Ist das wirklich das, was so wichtig ist, zu diskutieren jetzt? Ist es nicht irgendwo auch sehr auf Israel fixiert? Es gibt viele Kriege, in denen viel eindeutiger Völkermord begangen wird. Also der Krieg z.B. Russlands gegen die Ukraine ist für mich ein viel, viel eindeutiger Völkermord, ein erklärter Völkermord. Ich höre nicht, dass da dieser Begriff permanent in Munde geführt wird.
Ganz eigenartig. Also das, was in der Ukraine geschieht, also der Angriffskrieg, Russlands gegen die Ukraine, wird folgendermaßen eingeschätzt. Also da gibt es den Internationalen Strafgerichtshof in Den Haag. Und der hat ja Ermittlungen aufgenommen wegen Kriegsverbrechen, Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit und möglicherweise Völkermord. Und da befasst man sich aber jetzt mit der strafrechtlichen Verantwortlichkeit, der individuellen strafrechtlichen Verantwortlichkeit. Und hat auch Haftbefehle gegen hochrangige russische Persönlichkeiten erlassen. Aber es geht um mutmaßliche Kriegsverbrechen. Es geht nicht dabei um Völkermord. Es ist ganz interessant. Es ist also da nicht diese Eindeutigkeit, die Kathrine Eigendorf hier behauptet. Auch internationale Experten und Organisationen verwenden zwar die ganze Zeit den Begriff Kriegsverbrechen, Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit, also zum Beispiel auch mit Blick auf Butcher. Allerdings ist man viel zurückhaltender bei dem Begriff Völkermord als im Bezug auf Israel. Ich bin kein Jurist, kann das nicht beurteilen, bin kein Völkerrechter, um das genau einzuschätzen, finde aber erstaunlich, dass Kathrine Eigendorfer sagt, da sei das ganz eindeutig für sie. Und ja, wir hatten diesen deutschen Diskurs, dass bei Butcher gleich am ersten Tag, als das herauskam, sich alle einig waren, hier wird gerade Völkermord verübt. Und dass man aber jetzt im Punkt Israel, man sagt, ja da warten wir mal bis irgendwann Gerichtsprozesse was geklärt haben. Also das sind doch sehr merkwürdige Doppelstandards, möchte ich behaupten.
Genau, denn zum einen ist ja Gefahr im Vollzug. Ich würde auch sagen, wenn jetzt Kathrine Eigendorfer auch angefangen hätte mit, ich finde das immer so komisch, dass man beim Thema Israel ja schon war, ist bei dem, was man sieht aus Gaza, möchte man gerne zumindest, mehr hat man ja nicht in Begriffen, die härtest mögliche Formulierungen finden. Und da scheint ja das Wort Genozid sehr aufgeladen zu sein, bei den Leuten, die israelische Regierungen verteidigen. Von daher möchte man denen das gerne unterschieben. Nur man kann eben auch so damit umgehen, wir hören hier ein kurzes Snippet, mal ohne Kontext. Die Namen werden genannt aus der Deutschlandfunk-Tageszusammenfassung.
Herr Waldmann, begeht Israel in Gaza gerade einen Völkermord?
Herr Reze, das ist nicht das erste Mal bei dem Nordkonflikt, wo wir über Begrifflichkeiten sprechen. Das, was in Gaza-Streifen passiert, ist unerträglich und uns aufhören. Wir haben jetzt keine Zeit, darüber zu debattieren, ist das ein Völkermord oder nicht. Es wird später der Fall sein, es ist auch wichtig, dass man das verhandelt vor internationalen Gerichtshöfen. Jetzt muss dieser Krieg zum ersten Mal gestoppt werden. Der muss aufhören. Die humanitäre Lage muss unverzüglich radikal verbessert werden. Die Geiseln müssen befreit werden. Dann wird man die Zeit haben, darüber zu debattieren, ist es ein Völkermord oder nicht.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist genau die richtige Antwort, die man darauf geben muss. Gefahr im Vollzug ist wahrscheinlich auch die richtige Begrifflichkeit, um zu sagen, da muss eingegriffen werden, beziehungsweise muss nicht nur halbherzig irgendeine Waffentieferung gestoppt werden, sondern ganz massiv gesagt werden, dass das nicht gehen kann und dass die Unterstützung generell gestoppt wird.
Ja, und wenn man auf dieser Begriffsebene ist, finde ich, Christian Siebers macht das gerade sehr gut. Den sehe ich auch häufiger auf Instagram, wo er so eigene Videos macht. Macht ja Jake Tapper auch gerade und so. Alle funken über Instagram. Aber hier hören wir mal so richtige Moderationen, nur in kurzen Auszügen aus dem Heute-Journal.
Gaza brennt, meldet der israelische Verteidigungsminister heute. Aus seiner Sicht ist das eine Erfolgsnachricht.
So, da kommt jetzt das Wort Genozid nicht vor, aber es ist begrifflich trotzdem mal auf den Punkt gebracht. Ein anderes Beispiel.
Es wird sich auszahlen, sagt der Finanzminister des Staates Israel auf einer Konferenz in Tel Aviv. Er spricht von einer Goldgrube für Immobilienentwickler. Er meint den Gaza-Streifen.
Ja, also da würde einem dann der Begriff ethnische Säuberung vielleicht einfallen.
Ich würde jetzt auch gar nicht mehr so sehr, also ich finde der Begriff des Genozids hat jetzt in seiner Debatte seine Aufgabe erledigt. So, da können jetzt alle noch so ein bisschen, sondern hier kann man jetzt ruhig einsteigen und einfach tagtäglich das Konkrete nennen, etwasartig erzählen, was da eigentlich passiert.
Das Konkrete nennen. Bleiben wir noch mal ganz kurz bei diesen Doppelstandards, die mich tatsächlich stören, weil sie ja so unredlich sind und ich auch mich sehr darüber aufrege, wenn so das Denken an einer Stelle ausgeschaltet wird und an der anderen Stelle aber bitte weitergehen soll. Und nun hatten wir ja diesen Fall, dass Lahav Shani, der Dirigent, mitsamt dem Münchner Philharmonieorchester ausgeladen wurde beim Flanders Festival Gent, weil man von Shani erwartete, dass er sich bitte ganz eindeutig gegen die israelische Regierung und ihr Vorgehen in Gaza positionieren soll. Nun, ich bin ja bekanntermaßen gegen solche Boykott-Geschichten und war ja auch bei Anna Netrebko gewesen und würde auch zu Lahav Shani gehen. Aber bist du auch gegen Bekenntnisse?
Leg ein Bekenntnis ab.
Ich erwarte nicht von Künstlern, dass sie Bekenntnisse ablegen. Ich nämlich auch nicht. Michael Barenbäum sieht das ja anders. Er sagt nein, also er sagt dann ja bei Völkermord, das ist eine rote Linie, da muss man sich bekennen. Und ich würde sagen, nein, wir können jetzt nicht von allen laufend irgendwas abverlangen. Es ist übrigens interessant, man hat bei Anna Netrebko auch denlichen Bekenntnis abverlangen wollen. Ihr Mann aus Aserbaidschan oder ihr damaliger Mann aus Aserbaidschan, da hat man nicht von dem irgendein Bekenntnis gefordert oder so. Da würde ich sagen, da könnte man genauso kritisch mal nachfragen. Und wenn wir jetzt über alles reden, wo irgendjemand wie beteiligt ist, dann müssen wir laufend Bekenntnisse einholen und sonst was tun. Ja, also ich würde mir zum Beispiel auch komisch vorkommen, wenn ich jetzt eingeladen werde im Aussand und müsste erstmal ein Bekenntnis ablegen, dass ich sage, ich bin nicht einverstanden damit, wie Deutschland gerade Israel mit Waffen unterstützt oder mit der West-Sahara umgeht. Also das finde ich deswegen grundsätzlich falsch. Bedeutet aber, dann kann man auch diese ganzen anderen Geschichten nicht machen, dass man sagt, also, ne, Trepko soll nicht aufregen und Georgiev muss unbedingt entlassen werden, denn der darf auf keinen Fall weiterspielen. Der macht ja alle, der macht ja nur Putin-Propaganda oder so. Lahav Shani ist ja ausgeladen worden, nicht, wie das gesagt wurde, weil er Jude ist, sondern die Sache war, man wollte eine Distanzierung von ihm deshalb haben, weil er ja zugleich Leiter des Israel Philharmonic Orchestra ist, also eine doch wichtige musikanische Institution in Israel. Und deswegen hat man das Abflang. Wie gesagt, ich unterstütze das nicht, dass man das so tut, bin generell dafür, dass alle auch teilnehmen dürfen, überall und hasse das auch, wenn irgendwelche Konzerte jetzt gestört werden von irgendwelchen Aktivisten, welcher Art auch immer. Finde es aber wahnsinnig unredlich, wie dann Igor Lewitt zugeschaltet in den Tagesthemen, genau darauf angesprochen, gefragt wird, wie ist es denn, dass Gergiev nicht mehr dirigieren darf in Deutschland. Zugleich aber kritisiert er, dass Lahav Shani dort ausgeladen wurde in Ghent. Und wir hören uns jetzt mal diese merkwürdige Begründung an.
Nun löst Lahav Shani im kommenden Jahr ja ausgerechnet den bisherigen Chefdirigenten der Münchner Philharmoniker ab, den Russen Valeri Gergiev, der gefeuert wurde, wegen seiner großen Putin-Nähe und weil er sich nicht vom russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine distanzieren wollte. Aus Ihrer Sicht, wie unterscheiden sich die beiden Fälle?
Die einzig sinnvolle Antwort wäre jetzt, man ist gegen solche Beukotte, lasst die Künstler Künstler sein und wenn sie dann diese Nähe dazu haben, gut, dann ist das nochmal ein Problem, das kann man ja im Diskurs lösen, aber das kann man nicht über, oder man kann es im Diskurs verhandeln, aber man kann es nicht über Beukotte machen. Es kommt aber eine sehr komische Antwort.
Herr Zambaroni, Menschen, die solche Vergleiche anstellen, kann ich Folgendes sagen, da möchte ich Folgendes sagen. Ein Künstler zu vergleichen, nämlich Valery Gergiev, der seit Jahren, wenn nicht Jahrzehnten, offen für alle sichtbar, aus Überzeugung, transparent, ein Unterstützer, ein Kollaborateur, ein Profiteur ist, von den Machenschaften des russischen imperialistischen Diktators. Diesen, dessen Land, ein anderes Land, ein freies Land, nämlich die Ukraine, einseitig in einem kriegerischen Akt überfallen hat, schon 2014 überfallen hat. Diesen Künstler zu vergleichen mit Lahav Shani, einem Dirigenten, mit seinem deutschen Orchester, nämlich den Münchner Philharmoniker, der in diese Situation reingerutscht ist, einzig und allein, weil er ein Israeli ist, weil er ein israelischer Jude ist. Diese Situation miteinander zu vergleichen, ist wirklich in meinen Augen ein intellektueller Offenbarungseid, der ehrlich gesagt weder Aufmerksamkeit, noch Plattform, noch jede Form von ernst zu nehmendem Diskurs verdient.
Okay, sehr gut. Klassischer Hegemon-Diskurs. Wir haben das im Salon behandelt. Genau, ist ja so ein Gezerre. Der eine traut sich schon, die Frage nicht richtig zu stellen. Also es gibt ja Leute, die und so, reden ja nicht von sich. Und so, dass er dann nochmal sagen kann, diesen Leuten sollte man dann das und das sagen. Und ich würde immer noch eine Bande spielen, und dann ist es Literatur. Da kannst du uns den Salon wieder vorstellen.
Also das ist ja auch, also was mir so widerstrebt ist, dieses permanent tautologische Argumentieren, das stattfindet. Man sagt, da ist es anders, weil es da anders ist. Ja, Kathrin Eigentorf sagt, da ist es Völkermord, weil es da Völkermord ist. Da müssen wir mal noch gucken, ob die Gerichte was klären. Hier ist es völlig anders, weil es völlig anders ist. Aber da ist es wieder so. Also das ist ja einfach eine unredliche Diskussion. Und man kommt dann nur raus, indem man sagt, wir können nicht jetzt laufend Bekenntnisse herauskitzeln aus Leuten. Wir haben das schon auch bei der Antisemitismus-Resolution gehabt. Wir haben das bei vielen anderen Fällen. Wenn wir da jetzt anfangen und die ganze Zeit sagen, aber steht ihr dann auch dazu, ich habe ja hier mal vor einigen Monaten erzählt, dass ich mit einem Musiker gesprochen habe, der ziemlich renommiert ist, der sich fragt, darf er in Israel jetzt auftreten? Also dort Konzerte spielen oder er fragt sich, ist das vertretbar bzw. bekommt er dann hier von einigen Seiten so starke Repressionen, dass er damit seine Karriere kaputtmacht? Und dann habe ich ihm gesagt, das kann ich dir nicht beantworten, was strategisch richtig ist. Ich kann dir nur antworten, was an sich richtig ist. Natürlich kannst du in Israel Konzerte spielen. Ich würde mir jetzt von Netanyahu nicht nur Orden umhängen lassen, aber das sollte man generell ja haben, eine gewisse Distanz zu staatlicher Macht als Künstler. Aber sonst, warum soll man nicht Menschen in Tel Aviv auf Freude mit der Musik machen können? Sobald man aber da anfängt und sagt, der nicht und da nicht und Albano ist irgendwie zu russenfreundlich, weil er da gesungen hat und dort. Also ich verstehe das nicht, wie man da so weit gehen kann. Obwohl bei Albano würde ich noch eingrenzen, also das ist dieser italienische Pop-Sänger, der ist ja tatsächlich bei so einem offiziellen Russland-Kongress aufgetreten hat da gesungen. Das muss man nicht tun. Also man kann auch normal irgendwo Konzerte geben oder so vor Russen, aber man kann dann nicht auf so einer offiziellen Veranstaltung, die Putin organisiert auftreten. Da sehe ich tatsächlich jetzt gerade ein großes Problem und würde ich auch niemanden zu raten.
Ich würde es ein bisschen anders sehen, denn das ist ja auch ein bisschen ausweichend, wenn auch korrekt, zu sagen, wir halten uns in Äquidistanz zu allen Mächtigen und sagen, wir sind die Künstler. Nur, ich würde sagen, die große Alternative, die es immer gibt zu all diesen Fragen, und wir kommen gleich auf eine, wo man sich wirklich langsam fragt, sollten wir nicht einfach gar nicht mehr miteinander diskutieren. Wenn jemand eine politische Frage hat zum Thema Bürgergeld, einfach Gemini fragen. Gemini hat einen Zugang zu allen Zahlen, die alle Politiker verwenden. Einfach Datenbank abfragen, sich eine Antwort geben lassen, fertig. Warum irgendwen fragen und sich eine Meinung abholen? So, wir haben eine Wissensgrundlage. Und da wir das ja nicht können oder nicht wollen, wie auch immer, sind wir in einem politischen Diskurs, bei dem ab und zu die Frage aufkommt, darf ich noch in Israel spielen oder was auch immer? Meine Antwort wäre dann, ich würde nicht in Israel spielen, weil jede Nähe zu Netanyahu ist leider blöd. Und da er dort regiert, aber wo kommen wir dann da hin? Ja, das kann ich dir sagen. Wir kommen dann da hin.
Wie gesagt, der Musiker machte auch eine Tournee durch die USA und dann hat dem das auch keiner übergenommen, weil da Trump jetzt gerade regiert. Das sind die Doppelstandards, die nicht gehen.
Soll ich in Amerika spielen? Ich wurde für eine Tour angefragt, zehn Termine, würde ich sagen. Nö, also ich an deiner Stelle, es ist nicht meine Entscheidung, deswegen kann ich das ökonomische ausklammern, würde sagen, mit großem Traum und Trara. Nein, in Trump-Land spiele ich nicht. Denn ich fahre, klar, Eqidistanz zu allen, also dass man, dass alle jetzt einfach nur nach Abstand zueinander halten. Also der Künstler geht nicht in die beschmutzte Politik, der Politiker hält sich aus der Wirtschaft draußen und so weiter. Halte ich für falsch, denn idealtypisch ist schon dieses Modell von jemand wie Barack Obama regiert und jemand wie was auch immer, nehmen wir jetzt mal The Boss, lässt sich Norden von ihm umhängen. Und alle haben gute Laune bei so einem Termin, weil das einfach vernünftige Leute sind. Ja, finde ich auch nicht gut, mag ich nicht.
Aber Obama ist auch für schreckliche Thronmorde verantwortlich.
Ja natürlich, Obama ist halt ein amerikanischer Präsident.
Ja genau und deswegen würde ich mir generell weder von einem amerikanischen noch von einem deutschen Präsident als Künstler einen Orden umhängen lassen. Ich würde sagen, generell sollte man es so halten wie Thomas Bernhardt, der brauchte eine Zeit lang Geld und dann hat er sich Staatspreise verleihen lassen, dann hat er irgendwann Geld und hat gesagt, nein ab sofort will ich mit diesem Staat nichts mehr zu tun haben. Er hat also das eine Zeit lang mit ausgenutzt. Man kann natürlich noch rigoroser sein und sagen, grundsätzlich mache ich das nicht, finde ich an sich noch besser. Aber ich finde generell diese Nähe gut und nur weil Obama so nett und freundlich war, der aber zugleich auch ganz schlimme Sachen gemacht hat, finde ich sollte man als Künstler und gerade wenn man da aus Rock'n'Roll kommt, wo man eigentlich so anti-establishment sein will, eine Distanz zu haben. Und dass das immer mehr verloren geht, sehe ich ja. Und jeder YouTuber stolz ist, wenn er den Bundespräsidenten interviewen kann, finde ich alles grauenhaft. Und da ist ja auch Igor Lewitt so ein Beispiel dafür, der dann auch immer mit der Bundesregierung kungelt. Das finde ich alles überhaupt nicht gut und finde auch, dass Künstler sich davon fernhalten sollten. Wenn sie das nicht tun, Gott, dann machen sie das nicht. Sie können ja trotzdem gute Musiker sein. Also ich sage ganz klar, ich würde auch zum Konzert von Lahav Shani morgen gehen, wenn sich die Gelegenheit bietet. Aber ich finde, wenn wir jetzt anfangen und sagen, die sollen da nicht und da nicht und dort nicht auftreten, das ist gar nicht aushaltbar. Also das ist gar nicht machbar. Mein Gegenangebot ist hier gefolgt. Ich sage dir ein Beispiel. Ich bin im November auf einer Shizhek-Tagung in Prag. Kann man auf der Homepage gucken, vielleicht sind ja manche in der Gegend, können dir auch vorbeikommen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie da jetzt gerade regiert wird. Weiß ich nicht. Könnte ja eine rechte Regierung jetzt gerade sein.
Das hat niemand von dir verlangt, dass du das wissen musst und ich auch nicht. Niemand. Also nicht jetzt Leute in irgendeine Ecke drängen, wo sie wieder Bekenntnis ablegen müssen, wie jetzt muss ich bei Tschechen nachdenken. Nein, ich will ja gar nicht über Tschechen nachdenken, sondern entweder halten wir eine Equidistanz durch und dann sage ich, warum stellst du mir gerade eine politische Frage zu irgendwas? Frag doch Gemini.
Ja.
Das ist wie, Mama, wie viele Eier kommen in diesen Kuchenteig? Frag doch Google. So.
So. Nur, wir sind ja Wesen, die kommunizieren. Wir haben ja bei Rutger Breschmann gelesen, die menschliche Intelligenz kommt aus der Kommunikationsfähigkeit, aus der Synchronisation miteinander und so weiter. Ansonsten wären wir ja einfach die, wie hießen sie, Dingstabums, Neandertaler und wir wären ausgestorben. 20 Prozent mehr Muskeln und Gehirn, aber ausgestorben. Was bedeutet, ich möchte bitte nur an Diskursen teilnehmen, in denen Menschen auf einfachste politische Fragen einfach eine Antwort geben können, wie zum Beispiel. Welchen amerikanischen Präsidenten wünscht du dir lieber aktuell im Amt? Jemanden wie Donald Trump oder jemanden wie Obama? Ich will dann keine, ich halte mich lieber raus, will ich da nicht hören. Ich will auch nicht auf die Frage, wer im deutschen Bundestag gefällt dir besser in der Sitzungsleitung, Bärbel Bas oder Julia Klöckler? Jemanden haben, der mir dann sagt, oh nee, also da halte ich mich gerne raus, da will ich meine Finger jetzt nicht beschmutzen und so weiter. Das hat nichts zu tun mit, in Tschechien regiert irgendwer und ich will da meine Reise hin machen. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Tschechien. Ich werde mich da auch nicht einlesen, sondern ich würde dann einfach nach Krakau fahren und fertig ist.
Krakau ist in Polen.
Genau, so weit ist es schon. Ich würde selbst nach Krakau fahren, wenn ich gar nicht weiß, dass es in Polen ist.
Also meine Tagung ist in Prag jedenfalls.
Aber es gibt so ein paar Sachen und ich finde, wenn die Losung lautet, all eyes on Gaza, dann gilt das für alle. Dann darf nicht irgendwer dastehen und sagen, ach so, jetzt gerade sind wir beim Thema Musik und da halte ich Äquidistanz, da ist mir das egal und so weiter. Nein, alle mischen sich jetzt bitte ein in die großen Themen.
Ja, also man kann sich ja gerne einmischen. Nein, was ich nur gesagt habe, ist, dass ich es nicht richtig finde, dass man Künstlern ist verübelt, wenn sie irgendwo in Ländern auftreten. Was ich Künstlern verübeln würde, ist, wenn sie sich dann mit irgendwelchen autoritären Herrschern zum Beispiel gemein machen. Das finde ich auch nicht gut. Aber die Frage ist dann trotzdem, kann ich jemanden, der Putin gut finde, trotzdem noch ein Konzert mehr anhören? Das ist eine Frage, die will ich individuell für mich beantworten, aber die will ich nicht allgemein beantwortet bekommen, indem man sagt, darf da nicht mehr, soll da nicht mehr und das. Weil wenn ich das mir mal ansehe, also du brauchst nur mal dir die Künstler ansehen, hier aus lauterwestlichen Galerien, von wem die gekauft werden und wo die so privat, wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit Galeristen auslässt, wo die auftreten, mit wem die sich, mit irgendwelchen Scheichs, die die frauenverachtendste Politik überhaupt und so weiter betreiben, wo diese feministischen Künstlerinnen zuteil alle dorthin reisen, weil sie da zehn Millionen bekommen. Also die Kunst, da klebt fast nur Blut dran an der Gegenwartskunst. Und dann macht man jetzt, statuiert man solche Exempel und sagt, ja jetzt können wir uns irgendwie reinhalten. Da sag ich, nee, das ist alles völlig miteinander gedrängt von Macht. Und wenn wir eben von Filmen gesprochen haben, der Sohn von Larry Ellison, der jetzt die ganze Filmindustrie umkrempeln will, diese Republikanernähe der Familie Ellison und all das, ja gut, dann kann ich mir fast keinen Film mehr aus Amerika bald in den deutschen Kinos mehr ansehen. Also das ist dann ist meine Alternative Hollywood oder Til Schweiger. Das ist auch nicht eine Dichotomie, in die ich kommen will. Also wir kommen mit diesen rigorosen Fantasien nicht weiter. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, alle sollten erst mal überall auftreten können. Und ich bin generell gegen solche Boykotte, weil man, weil man ab ganz schnell in diese Doppelstandards kommt und dann sagt ach so, da guckt ihr jetzt genau hin, aber dort nicht. Und um das zu entgehen, sollte man es einfach nicht tun.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich sage nur zu dem Punkt.
Wir hoffen, dass du jetzt eine Einladung bekommst, also ich hoffe es zumindest sehr, aus den USA, dass du dort über Demografie in Deutschland sprichst.
Gar keinen Fall, einfach nicht in Amerika.
Und dass man dir noch so, sagen wir, 5000 Dollar zahlt. Ich bin gespannt, ob du hinfährst.
Ausgewählte Städte natürlich nur. Ich fahre jetzt nicht nach, was weiß ich, Austin.
Ausgewählte Städte, aber siehst du, du würdest ja dann doch in das von Donald Trump beherrschte Land fahren.
Also, das von Donald Trump beherrschte Land, das sich immer dadurch auszeichnet, dass der amerikanische Präsident irgendwo an der West-Ostküste sitzt und nicht mal einen Innenminister hat. Da gibt es natürlich Regionen in Kalifornien, wo wir wissen, jedes Wahlamt ist von einem Demokraten besetzt, oder in Seattle.
Ich weiß das, ja. Aber genau mit diesem Punkt kann ich ja zum Beispiel auch sagen, ich trete in Israel auf, weil nicht alle Menschen in Israel wie die Netanyahu-Regierungen sind.
Ich wollte das ja niemandem ausreden. Ich will nur sagen, auch als Künstler, finde ich, steht man in einer gewissen Verantwortung, es schon zu sehen, wer da regiert.
Und dann kann man durchaus trotzdem da hinfahren und sagen, es wäre schön, ich bin immer skeptisch, wenn Künstler sich politisch äußern, dann wollen sie meistens die Werbpflicht einführen und sonst was tun.
Jetzt sind wir wieder bei dem Thema, wie bei der Wahlpflicht, Wahlrecht für Kinder, dass so nämlich, nee, Künstler lieber nicht melden, politisch, weil ihr könntet ja die falsche Meinung haben.
Nee.
Und dann will ich sagen, nein, lasse ich ihre Meinung haben.
Ich habe hier den Eindruck, dass Künstler oftmals sehr große Opportunisten sind. Das ist auch systemisch bedingt, wegen Preispolitik und so weiter. Und ich kenne Leute, die natürlich eine Meinung haben, bei der sie sagen, die kann ich nicht sagen, dann bekomme ich keinen einzigen Literaturpreis mehr oder sonst irgendetwas. Und deshalb schweige ich lieber dazu. Also das ist auch eine Sache, in der man ist. Und deswegen gibt es ja auch 17 verschiedene Pennenclubs, um sich irgendwie zu positionieren. Ich bin froh, dass ich nicht da mitmachen muss. Meinungsfreiheit, wir diskutieren hier immer häufiger jetzt, ist sie bedroht?
Dein Lieblingsthema?
Na ja, deins doch auch.
Ich bin natürlich, wenn es drauf ankommt, wie hieß nochmal Notfall, Free Speech?
Okay.
Vielleicht bist du ja auch schon von der Angst getrieben. Wer weiß.
Immer.
Jedenfalls wollen wir im Salon dieses Thema ganz groß nochmal aufbereiten. Wir haben ja schon im Sommersalon über die Meinungsfreiheit, wie sie bedroht ist, aus der Perspektive von Taylor Lawrence gesprochen, die ich sehr dann unterstützt habe in ihrer Perspektive. Du hast dich angestachelt gefühlt zur permanenten Volte gegen mich und Taylor Lawrence. Aber wir werden sehen, vielleicht kommen wir auch noch mal in eine ganz andere Richtung, nämlich durch das Buch, das wir im Salon lesen wollen. Es heißt Angst, Stillstand, warum die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet von Richard David Precht. Er nimmt sich jetzt diesem Thema an. Dieses Buch erscheint Mitte Oktober und dann erscheint auch der neue Salon. Wir werden es also dann sofort veröffentlichen und diskutieren. Und ich denke, es wird eine gute Anknüpfung sein an die Diskurse, die wir jetzt schon hatten. Beziehungsweise ja auch, wenn man blickt auf das, was jetzt gerade alles von Jimmy Kimmel bis Kirk diskutiert wird.
Ja, Angststillstand, da muss ich immer an diese Ziegen denken, die sich erschrecken und aus Angst einfach frozen umfallen, die nicht mal mehr stehen können, schweige denn sich bewegen.
Ja, naja, es sind ja jetzt doch einige schon umgefallen in den USA. Das kann man doch deutlich sehen, wer da so alles mitmischt. Und wir können natürlich auch die deutschen Diskurse kritisch beobachten. Jedenfalls, dieses Buch diskutieren wir dann ausführlich im Salon, reden also über die Meinungsfreiheit. Und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr den Salon abonniert. Das geht, wenn man Apple-Kunde ist, ganz einfach.
Also wenn man Apple-Kunde ist, geht super einfach, wenn man eh schon in der Podcast-App hört, die ja auf dem iPhone vorinstalliert ist. Man bekommt dann aber einen Podcast, der keine Kapitelmarken hat, weil Apple so denkt, ne, wenn man den manuell hochlädt, was man machen muss, damit er hinter der Paywall erscheint, gibt es keine Kapitelmarken. Ich weiß nicht, warum. Das Textfeld für den Begleittext ist sehr beschränkt. Ich kriege die ganzen Show Notes da gar nicht unter, sondern kann nur noch sozusagen die Kapitel einmal nennen. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum Apple da so hinterher ist. Es wird auch immer erst einen halben Tag später veröffentlicht, weil Apple so lange braucht mit Prozessieren. Von daher, ja, man kann ihn bei Apple buchen. Also bei Apple kriegt man sicher den Salon, aber ich kann jetzt nur sagen, die Präferenz ist dann schon steady irgendwie. Man kann auch den Steady Feed, den man von uns bekommt, in der Apple Podcast App abonnieren, dann fällt einem gar nicht mehr auf, dass es gar nicht bei Apple direkt gebucht wurde.
Ich bin ja inzwischen auch Apple-Kunde und kann nachvollziehen, dass man sagt, aber es ist nur ein Klick und das ist sehr praktisch. Ich muss mich mit nichts weiterem mehr beschäftigen. Ja, also über Apple ist das möglich. Wer bei Patreon angemeldet ist, kann das auch schon tun. Wir präferieren allerdings Steady. Da sind wir von Anfang an und auch nach wie vor sehr froh mit dieser Plattform. Dort, aber auch sonst, kann man natürlich dann die Live-Salons, die wir jetzt schon angesprochen haben, gerade auch den vom Sommer, überall hören. Also das ist jetzt nicht nur bei Steady, aber Steady bietet dann noch mal den Vorteil mit den Klippmarken, mit den Kapitelmarken.
Man kann überall den Podcast hören. Es ist ein Audiopodcast.
Man muss nicht vor einem Desktop sitzen.
Genau, das sowieso nicht. Bei Steady könnt ihr den Podcast so hören, wie wir wollen, dass ihr ihn hört, nämlich im Podcast-Player eurer Wahl. Und zwar genau dann, wenn euer Podcast-Player als Podcatcher auf dem Telefon, wie auch immer, euch einfach sagt, neuer Salon ist da, Ding-Dong, und dann drückt man einfach auf Play. Wenn man auf Play drückt...
Podcast-Podcatcher eurer Wahl bedeutet aber für die meisten Menschen Spotify.
Man kann ihn bei Spotify hören, man kann ihn in der Apple Podcast App hören, bei Overcast, bei Atenac, was auch immer es alles gibt. So, nur wenn man dann diesen Podcast hört bei Steady, dann kriegt man auch noch das Episodenbild angezeigt, man kriegt den kompletten Begleittext, wo alle Kapitel nochmal kurz textlich zusammengefasst sind. Man kriegt jede Literaturangabe aus dem Salon verlinkt zum Verlag oder Herausgeber, wie auch immer, plus Kapitelmarken, die einem im Player noch zeigen, die reden jetzt noch drei Minuten über das und dann kommt das nächste und so. Und das macht schon einen Unterschied im Vergleich zu Apple. Ich weiß nicht genau, woran das liegt, weil Apple eigentlich Vorreiter, jeder weiß noch, wie Steve Jobs auf der Bühne stand und gesagt hat, iPod, wir machen hier Podcast, es ist wie Broadcast, aber halt im iPod und so. Und jetzt haben sie es schludern, die da so. Also ich rufe auch Apple auf, jetzt gegen Spotify mal wieder ein bisschen anzustinken. Ich verstehe das nicht.
Der Podcast ist überall zu hören. Das ist die wichtigste Botschaft und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr dem Podcast abonniert. Wir wollen aber jetzt über Charlie Kirk insofern reden, als wir merken, das religiöse kommt zurück. Aber was mir auch aufgefallen ist, ist durch das Attentat auf Charlie Kirk so ein eigenes Genre entstanden, kurzzeitig bei Instagram, YouTube und sonst wo. Nämlich Menschen sagen nochmal Selbstverständliches und versuchen nochmal zu verdeutlichen, wie gut sie selbst sind, wie wichtig ihnen die Menschlichkeit ist. Und ich will ein Beispiel liefern. Also man sagt nochmal, man sollte keine Menschen abknallen. Genau.
Und dann auch nicht essen.
Und ganz richtig. Wir hören jetzt mal ein typisches Beispiel dafür. Comedian oder was weiß ich, was der Moderator, Bastian Bielendorfer.
Komm, wir nennen ihn ganz dispektierlich Podcaster.
Ich kann mit vielen Dingen, die dieser Mann gesagt hat, nicht übereinstimmen. Viele Dinge, die der von sich gegeben hat, fand ich absolut schrecklich. Aber wenn wir anfangen in unserer Gesellschaft so zu verrohnen, dass wir im Internet befeiern, wenn jemand, der dann auch noch zwei kleine Kinder oder eine Ehefrau hat, auf grausame Art...
Wurde auch immer dazu gesagt, noch so als sei nicht der Tod eines Menschen an sich schon ausreichend. Man muss immer noch hinzufügen, hat noch Kinder. Also ich habe keine Kinder, aber ich glaube es wäre jetzt trotzdem blöd, wenn man mich jetzt erschießen würde.
Ja, man hinterlässt typischerweise bei einem Todesfall. Das ist ja der soziale Komponente in diesem Menschsein.
Ja, man ist nicht ganz allein auf der Welt....
aus dem Leben gerissen wird, dann verrohnen wir als Menschen, als Menschheit im Gesamten. Alles ist nur noch links gegen rechts, dumm gegen klug, Impfgegner gegen Impfbefürworter. Es gibt nur noch Fights auf der ganzen Welt von Menschen, die unterschiedlicher Meinung sind. Unterschiedliche Meinungen gibt es, seit es die Menschheit gibt. Und irgendwie hat man das Gefühl, dass in den letzten paar Jahren durch Social Media und durch andere Einflüsse, dass es überhaupt keinen Konsens mehr gibt. Es gibt überhaupt keine Möglichkeit mehr, dass Menschen irgendwie sich auf irgendwas einigen. Es geht nur noch darum, sich zu bekämpfen und am Ende zu vernichten. Und ich kann das nicht beklatschen, wenn jemand stirbt, weil er eine andere Meinung vertreten hat. Und ich finde es erschreckend, dass...
Es wird so getan, als wäre das so ein Riesenphänomen, dass alle nur noch applaudieren, wenn jemand stirbt.
So viele Linke, so viele, die vielleicht mehr auf meinem Meinungs-Spektrum sind, als Charlie Kirk, es war jetzt auf einmal keine moralischen Grenzen mehr kennen und sagen, ja, das ist aber gut, dass der jetzt weg ist. Das kann nicht gut sein. Und wir sollten uns, unsere Menschlichkeit, unsere Verantwortung als Menschen nicht davon rauben lassen, dass wir das vorgelebt bekommen von Figuren wie Putin, von Trump, aber auch von Menschen der linken Seite, die offensichtlich keinen moralischen Pompas mehr haben. Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr es seht, aber Katastrophen.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, lieber Bastian. Wenn man nochmal das Selbstverständliche so deutlich sagen muss, halte ich das für verdächtig. Ich hätte gedacht, das wäre der Konsens, dass wir uns ja nicht gegenseitig erschießen und so. Aber gut, dass du es nochmal sagst, dass auch für dich geht, dieser Konsens.
Ja, ich war dann doch ein bisschen überrascht, denn mein Gedächtnis ist gut und ich erinnerte mich an einen Tweet, den ich auch wieder gefunden habe von Bastian Bielendorfer. Und zwar war das eine Weile nachdem Putin in die Ukraine einmarschiert ist, da war einmal mehr Sarah Wagenknecht in einer Talkshow. Und Bastian Bielendorfer twitterte folgendes. Sarah Wagenknecht ist einfach nur die leere Hülle eines seelisch und menschlich komplett verdorbenen Zellhaufens. Man sollte sie nicht in Talkshows einladen, sondern therapieren. Widerlich. Ich würde da auch nochmal darüber nachdenken, was die Abwertung von menschlichen Leben so anbelangt. Und würde auch hier sagen, über was reden wir, wenn da einfach so gesagt wird, die Linken feiern das. Es gab, ich will die Namen jetzt auch nicht nochmal hier alle erwähnen, ein paar aus der Comedy-Richtung, die sich hervorgewagt haben und haben irgendein Witzchen gemacht zum Tod von Charlie Kirk. Das kann man geschmacklos finden. Das ist aber ein anderer Modus, wenn das im Bereich der Comedy passiert, als wenn ich aus einer wirklich politischen Perspektive heraus sage, ich freue mich darüber, dass Menschen getötet werden, die nicht meiner Meinung sind oder die rassistisch sind oder sonst etwas. Erst mal sind wir da im Modus der Comedy. Ich würde sagen, dass wir da auch eine gewisse Hypersensibilisierung bekommen haben, dass man also immer wartet, macht die Gegenseite jetzt gerade was, was man skandalisieren kann, nämlich das findet statt. Ich erinnere an die Comedian Joan Rivers, die ich hier hin und wieder mal erwähnt habe. Die war nun eine, die immer politisch unkorrekt unterwegs war, die zum Beispiel sich wagte zu sagen nach dem furchtbaren Tsunami, na ja, aber wenigstens ist das Land jetzt mal sauber. Also das kann man natürlich auch geschmacklos finden. Und genauso war es ja auch gedacht. Nur es ist dann in der Sphäre der Comedy und wurde damals aber nicht in der Weise skandalisiert, dass man sagte, da sieht man es wieder. Und sie ist wahrscheinlich auch Republikanernah oder sonst was. Sie hat auch viele Witze über den 11. September gemacht. Sie hat gesagt, ja, es war wirklich eine schlimme Zeit. Aber die Witwen, die haben ja 5 Millionen bekommen. Na ja, so 5 Millionen. Jetzt stell dich mal vor, da würde einer klingen und sagt, ich habe doch überlebt. Also so Witze hat sie, hat sie am laufenden Band gerissen. Und natürlich ist sie da auch mit angeeckt. Aber jetzt hat man da gleich auch so eine Hyper-Politisierung draus. Und jeder muss noch mal so ein Bekenntnisvideo aufnehmen, in dem er sagt, nee, abknallen ist nicht so richtig. Es ist ein eigenes Genre jedenfalls, das wir, glaube ich, noch häufiger erleben werden.
Ja, ich glaube, wir können die Selbstverständlichkeit hier einmal aussprechen. Menschen erschießen, das ist das große Thema, weshalb wir uns eh immer wundern, Amerika zuwenden und uns fragen, heute schon wieder 100 Kinder, die sich selber erschossen haben, weil einfach eine Waffe ungesichert im Wohnzimmer rum lag.
Ja.
So, und das wird wirklich im dreistelligen Bereich täglich gemessen.
Auch die Suizidrate ist ja zum Beispiel sehr viel höher. In einem Land, weil die Möglichkeiten vorhanden sind. Also die Leute kaufen eine Waffe, um sich zu verteidigen. Richten sie aber häufiger gegen sich selbst als gegen andere.
Und es ist nun mal, klar, ich als Scott Galloway Fan und so, aber diese kleine kleine Botschaft oder dieser kleine Hinweis zu sagen, nee, offenbar gab es nicht eine riesige Milieu-Mobilisierung und einen demokratischen Prozess, um zu sagen, erstens, wir haben entschieden, Charlie Kirk muss sterben. Und zweitens, du wirst diese Aufgabe übernehmen, aber wir stehen alle hinter dir. Sondern nein, typischerweise finden diese Attentate, die ja nun, was soll man sagen, früher hätte man, als sich die Attentäter immer noch selber erschossen haben, hat man von so einem erweiterten Suizid gesprochen. Sie haben eigentlich mit ihrem eigenen Leben abgeschlossen. Und wollten dann noch mal irgendwas anrichten und so. Gerade bei diesen Schulmassakern. Jetzt flüchten die Täter immer und werden dann aber nicht etwa gefasst, sondern die Familie sagt einfach, sorry, aber wir bringen dich jetzt zur Polizei. So auch in diesem Fall. Das sind junge, unter 25-jährige Männer, die einfach vor dem Internet vereinsamen. Und das ist auch ein Muster, das ganz deutlich nach vorne steht. Und wenn man von einer Milieu, also wenn man überhaupt jetzt so von dem Milieu sprechen will, dann ist das dieses Milieu, der untereinander sich unbekannten, vielleicht gerade so mit, was auch immer, sich für Signale setzt, wenn man jetzt in einem Discord-Chat rumhängt oder bei Reddit oder so den ganzen Tag. Man hat ja wohl so eine Ahnung, dass da auf der anderen Seite noch andere Menschen sind, die da Up- und Downvoting machen oder wie auch immer. Aber das sind Leute, die vereinsamen vor ihrem Bildschirm.
Und jetzt kann man sagen, das sind nicht guerilla-Kämpfer, die schon seit Jahren sozialisiert sind in irgendeinem revolutionären Kampf. Das ist nicht wie in One Battle After Another. Dort gibt es ja jetzt in dem neuen Film von Paul Thomas Anderson eine radikale Gruppe, die gegen Eis kämpft, die dann loszieht. Aber hier ist die Einzelradikalisierung, die stattfindet im Stillen.
Genau. Und hinter diese Wahrheit, die nun mal offensichtlich ist, wir kennen ja die Täter, kommt man nicht zurück. Egal, welche politische Meinung man hat und egal, welchen Wunsch man daraus ableitet. Nämlich, dass es da doch Milieu gibt und wie auch immer. Und das hat natürlich alles große soziale Folgen, die wir mal nachgehen. Und ich will noch mal diese kleine Dichotomie, die Binarität erklären. Entweder reden wir gar nicht miteinander oder wir gehen all in. Also dann hat einfach jeder zu allem immer eine Meinung und dann versucht man einfach, damit klarzukommen. Es scheint ja so in diese Richtung zu gehen. Ich versuche jetzt dazwischen so lang zu lavieren, indem wir unterschiedlichste Einflug schneisen. Also ich will jetzt nicht meine Meinung vorstellen, sondern wir hören jetzt Ishu Ma Mangaulch. Später hören wir den All-In-Podcast. Da podcasten ja vier Leute aus konservativer Richtung zusammen. Drei davon sind Milliardärer, einer ist Angestellter von Donald Trump und so weiter und so fort. Also da geht es ja richtig zur Sache.
Ja schön, ja.
Und wir beginnen bei diesem Memorial für Charlie Kirk. Denn die Legende sagt und diesmal ist es auch, wir können jetzt nicht nur Times Clips spielen, weil ich finde, es haben jetzt alle falsch gemacht. Also das ist natürlich auch ein toller Anwurf jetzt hier in diesem Podcast zu sagen.
Alle haben es falsch gemacht.
Es haben leider alle falsch gemacht, weswegen wir es jetzt mal richtig machen müssen.
Ich bin gespannt. Aber... Kommen wir auch auf Esra Klein zu sprechen?
Ja, natürlich.
Gut.
Du hast mich ja im Salon schon provoziert. Du wirst dich wundern, wie wir das gleich aufgreifen. Es gab eine drei bis vier Stunden lange Veranstaltung in Windeseile organisiert. Riesiges Stadion. Ästhetisch einfach perfekt. So wie man das halt so macht, wenn man Trump ist. Man kommt aus diesem Fernsehzeitalter. Man weiß, wie das Fernsehen funktioniert. Man verbindet das mit Politik. Man sieht so, die Politik wie bisher funktioniert nicht mehr. Also macht man sie jetzt anders. Ah, wir nehmen die Einladung an. Jetzt spielt auch Jesus Christus hier eine große Rolle. So. Sowohl die deutschen Journalisten als auch sogar die New York Times, das habe ich gar nicht verstanden, haben so diesen Tenor gebracht. Okay, es ging zwei Stunden lang um Charlie Kirk. Und man hat so an ihn gedacht und er war ein religiöser Mensch. Also spielte das so eine Rolle. Es war so eine Art Messe für ihn. Und dann kam aber aus Reihe eins die Politiker nach vorne, die Regierungsmitglieder. Und die haben dann natürlich da ein Wahlkampfding draus gemacht. Oder wie auch immer. Steht ja gar keine Wahl an. Aber so Mobilisierungs...
Hat ja sogar über die Zölle gesprochen.
Genau. Also es ging ja drunter drüber am Ende. Ich möchte gern sagen, nein, diese ersten zwei Stunden, wo es ja angeblich nur um die Person Charlie Kirk und Family in Faith ging, das ist die eigentliche politische Veranstaltung gewesen. Und da muss man natürlich sagen, Politik ist eben das, was alle betrifft. Und nicht nur das, was Politiker machen. Als Publikum wird ja typischerweise immer ausgeblendet. Ich würde jetzt sagen, nee, wir müssen uns jetzt genau angucken. Wir beginnen bei einem Clip, wo wir jemanden haben. Es wurden ja rein weise Wegbegleiter, was auch immer. Das wird auch immer unterschätzt. Turning Point USA. Also wenn deine Lebensaufgabe ist, zu einem Unicampus zu gehen, um da Prove Me Wrong Veranstaltung zu machen, stehen wir Europäer, haben ein bisschen komisch daneben und wundern uns, wieso, ist doch irgendwie Quatsch. Also warum setzt er sich dahin auf den Stuhl, hat es ein komisches Zelt, da steht da so ein Mikro. Es gibt gar keine Vortragssituation, sondern es ist direkt Q&A, aber sofort aufgeladen auch, weil alle wissen, dass es Charlie Kirk. Man muss einfach wissen, hinter diesen, es ist ja keine Partei, sondern es ist eine, was weiß auch immer, es ist ein Privatmann, ja. Aber der hat einfach 100 Millionen Dollar dafür gekriegt. Und natürlich ist man dann motiviert, diesen Quatsch zu machen. Und ich würde mal sagen, wenn man sich Charlie Kirk Videos so anguckt, so richtig Spaß hat eben das auch nicht gemacht.
Jetzt zieht es halt professionell durch, wie ein Schlagersänger jeden Tag im Möbelhaus.
Der legt jedes Mal das Mikro ab. Ach, lass mal was trinken und so. Ach, nächste Frage. Oh, okay, okay. Also das ist ja hier mein These, jetzt wieder sprich mir. Dann hört er sich das an und dann greift er so zum Mikro. Ja, blablabla. Also ich finde nicht, dass das nach macht Spaß aussieht.
Nee.
Sondern so wie bei vielen, die wir gerade in Amerika sehen, die politische Geschäfte führen, Pete Hexeth, JD Vans, wo man sich echt fragen muss, Elon Musk und so. Macht's Spaß gerade, was ihr macht? Ja und die Antwort ist offensichtlich nicht. Die Kräfte sind andere. Und die Kräfte bei Charlie Kirk waren einfach 100 Millionen Dollar. Der hat ja ein riesen Apparat gehabt, der ihm da ein Stuhl hinstellt. Wir fragen uns immer, wenn das öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk-Ding ein Stream macht zu irgendwas, müssen da 18 Leute arbeiten? Kann man es nicht zu zweit so machen wie bei uns? Nee, und dort ist es genauso. Da stellt sich jemand einen Stuhl hin mit so einem komischen Partyzelt auf dem Unicampus. Müssen da 50 Leute für arbeiten? Eigentlich ja nicht. Also, es sind schon andere Kräfte am Berg. Gut, die Kräfte, die da am Berg sind...
Das ist ja jetzt nicht nur ein Sonderphänomen gewesen, sondern generell gibt es das und dort kann man enorm viel Geld damit verdienen. Wir haben ja auch schon mal erwähnt, Milo Yiannopoulos, der damals als der gay Influencer von Donald Trump dort auftrat, der übrigens jetzt mit dem Tod von Charlie Kirk verkündet hat, dass er zurückkommen will. Und dann habe ich ihn mal gegoogelt und mir das angesehen. Milo Yiannopoulos sieht jetzt ein bisschen aus wie der Tiger King. Und er ist auch jetzt gar nicht mehr schwul, sondern er hat sich einer Konversionstherapie unterzogen. Angeblich ist er jetzt also geheilt, in Anführungszeichen, und ist jetzt also auch christlich geworden. Das heißt, er kann sich also schön auch anschließen an diese neue christliche Form des rechten Denkens.
Genau, das muss man auch deutschen Journalisten immer wieder erklären. Ich höre immer diese Sachen und frage mich dann Leute, kriegt ihr gar nichts mit der? Wir haben ja Ben Shapiro zum Beispiel im letzten Salon Eclipse gehört. Es gibt diese Laura Loomis, es gibt Charlie Kirk, es gab Charlie Kirk. Diese Leute hassen sich aufs Blut und die wünschen sich auch jeden Morgen gegenseitig den Tod. Was Loomis da zuletzt, es gibt eine Dokumentation darüber, für Tweets gelöscht hat über Charlie Kirk, weil sie einfach wusste, ok, das Ziel ist erreicht, aber jetzt muss er alle löschen. Also man muss sich das so verstellen, da gibt es nicht eine Verlangst, die einfach Kumbayah mäßig und so weiter, wir gehen jetzt hier, wir tragen Trump ins Amt, sondern es ist dieser Management-Stil von Trump, jeden Posten doppelt besetzen und die müssen das in dem Krieg miteinander klären. So ist auch dieses Vorfeld organisiert. Die hassen sich alle bis aufs Blut. Und wenn der eine tot ist, sagt der andere, ich komme aus dem Exil zurück, wie Friedrich Merz.
Also Milo Janoklis wurde ja damals von der rechten Seite geschlachtet. Der hatte ja Aussagen gemacht zum Thema Pädophilie, wo er dann so sagte, na ja, mit 13 und so weiter, wo man dann sagte, ist der jetzt da völlig durchgedreht? Und dagegen haben ja die rechten, dann also die rechten Aktivisten, die Milo immer gehasst haben, haben dann so gegen ihn mobil gemacht, dass er nirgends mehr was machen konnte. Auch bei Breitbart musste er kündigen und so weiter. Das heißt, ja, man muss sich das so vorstellen. Das ist ein Haifischbecken. Da sind ja irgendwie alle ganz freundlich miteinander.
Das ist ein Haifischbecken. So, das mal alles sozusagen vor der Klammer. Jetzt gucken wir hier rein. Also wir nehmen jetzt mal einen beliebigen Clip, wo einfach Family and Faith eine große Rolle spielt. Und das wollen wir dann politisieren und auf die fundamentale Ideologie dessen, was da gerade passiert, so insgesamt, von dem auch die ganzen Leute, die da gerade regieren, hoffen, dass mit Trumps Tod so was weiter ausgebeutet werden kann und das auf Dauer gestellt werden kann. Denn wir wissen ja, die sozio-logisch interessante Frage ist nicht, wer war der Kaiser so und so, sondern wie kann man die soziale Ordnung, wie wir sie gerade vorfinden, stabilisieren, auf Dauer stellen? Dass man eben nicht, ah ja, mit Trump ist es tot und dann ist alles wieder vorbei, das wollen die ja nicht. Also, ein Wegbegleiter von Charlie Kirk steht mit seiner Frau arm in arm am Rednerpult in diesem riesigen Stadion.
True freedom is not found in doing whatever we want, but pursuing Christ in doing what is right.
Kannst du auf deiner Liste schon mal abhaken, Was er alles nicht gemacht hat.
True joy. Charlie led by example. It's not only seen in the incredible wife, Erica Kirk, his two beautiful children, the legacy he built, his values, his love of God and true joy he found in his savior Jesus Christ, but in countless people, especially young people like Elizabeth and I, Die sehr liebsten sind die Früchte von Charleys Beispiel der Glaubenheit. Charlie, es war der Ehren meines Lebens, dich zu servieren, als du Jesus servierst. Und jetzt werden wir alle, wenn du bist, als wir Jesus servieren. Vielen Dank, ich liebe dich, Charlie. Ich kann mich nicht mehr erwarten, dich wiederzusehen. God bless Erika Kirk, CEO and Chair of Turning Point USA. The Kirk Family and God bless America.
So, die Leute, die in Charlie Kirk schon etwas gesehen haben, als er diesen Föllefanz da gemacht hat, überall mit seinem Prove Me Wrong und so weiter, haben hier natürlich wieder etwas gesehen, weshalb die Veranstaltung so groß organisiert wurde. Das passiert ja nicht aus Versehen. Da gibt es also einen gewissen religiösen, christlichen Fundamentalismus, den man ausbeuten kann und von dem wir wissen, der hat sich in Europa so im fünften Jahrhundert vielleicht durchgesetzt, nach Rom und so weiter. Und dann war der einfach 1000 Jahre da, bis mal irgendwer kam und meinte, ne, das mit diesem Ablasshandel und der ganze Graben und überhaupt muss das alles auf Obskurität sein, kann man das nicht in deutscher Sprache machen und bla, bla, bla, ja. So, und das kann man natürlich wieder installieren wollen. Und dass die irre drauf sind, ist ja klar. Also das wissen wir ja schon, ja. Also die Leute um Trump, die sind wirklich irre drauf.
Trump selbst, ja, um das ein bisschen auseinanderzuhalten, ist ja nicht sonderlich religiös.
Der ist ein Idiot. Das wissen wir von Michael Wolf. Der hat keine Ahnung von nichts.
Er wird wahrscheinlich auch dann sagen, ich bin so erfolgreich, weil Gott das wollte. Vielleicht kann er sich das noch abbringen. Aber genau, Gott hat ihn verschont. Aber er ist nicht jemand, der an sich besonders religiös ist, was wir jetzt erleben bei diesen verschiedenen christlichen Strömungen, ist ja, dass sie dann in diesen Momenten, oder auch wenn es um diese großen nationalen Projekte, Trump an die Macht zu bringen oder so, häufig zusammenarbeiten, was ungewöhnlich ist. Also auch sogar in der Ehe Kirk. Also Kirk gehört ja so einer evangelikalen Strömung an, während ja seine Ehefrau katholisch ist. Also eigentlich stehen die sich sehr weit ideologisch auseinander, wenn man das ernst nimmt. Also ich kenne zum Beispiel Leute aus meiner Schulzeit, die so frei evangelisch unterwegs waren. Für die war also die Institution Kirche im Sinne von die evangelische Kirche Deutschlands oder die katholische Kirche Deutschlands wirklich ein rotes Tuch. Hier erleben wir aber jetzt so ein Potpourri aus verschiedenen christlichen Strömungen, die sich zusammentun, weil sie sagen, wir haben ein gemeinsames Ziel. Das ist also, dass Christliche weitertragen, viele Kinder, auch wenn man sie sich nicht leisten kann, wie hier gesagt wird, auf die Welt zu bringen, mehr als du dir leisten kannst. Und das ist selbstredend dann sehr stark gerichtet gegen den Islam. Wir kommen heute noch auf Großbritannien zu sprechen, da werden wir das dann auch nochmal wieder sehen. Und das ist, finde ich, eine absolut neue Dimension, die mit dem Religiösen hier reinkommt. Oder sagen wir eine nicht neu, sondern es ist eine Renaissance des Religiösen. Wenn wir uns mal an Samuel P. Huntington erinnern, der hat ja nicht nur dieses Buch geschrieben, Kampf der Kulturen, sondern ja auch dieses Buch geschrieben, Who Are We? Und dort fragte er ja, was zeichnen denn eigentlich die Amerikaner oder den Westen aus? Und dann wollte er ja eigentlich mit diesem Buch auch klarmachen, werdet Christlich, ihr müsst ein christliches Selbstverständnis haben, um euch absetzen zu können von den Islamisten. Wenn ihr nur Konsum und American Way of Life habt, dann ist das zu wenig. Ihr braucht ein Glaubensfundament. Und das hat man auch bei dem Historiker Niall Ferguson, der geht auch in die so eine Richtung rein. Der hat immer gesagt, das Christentum, wenn das, das muss aufrechterhalten werden. Und das hat sich jetzt viel stärker noch als bei Huntington angedacht, radikalisiert, dass man also sagt, gut, wir brauchen jetzt diese christliche Identität, um der anderen Identität, gegen die wir schon lange etwas haben, nämlich die muslimische Identität, etwas entgegensetzen zu können. Und deshalb schaffen die das überhaupt, sich auch in dieser Weise zu verbinden. Denn normalerweise sind die zwar alle christlich und glauben an Jesus Christus und den einen Gott und so weiter. Aber eigentlich müssten die sich spinnefeind sein, müsste es mindestens so sein wie in den 60er Jahren in der Bundesrepublik, als es wirklich heikel war, wenn ein Katholik eine Protestantin heiraten wollte.
Das haben wir ja, also diese, sag ich mal, irischen Probleme, die ja bis zum Brexit und dann haben alle wieder Angst, dass es wieder aufblüht. Haben wir in Amerika nie, weil die Kirchen da immer sozusagen enge Bande zum Publikum halten mussten, durch diese Direktfinanzierung. Also es ist einfach jede Kirche zu einem Musicaltheater geworden und sonntags ist halt Halligalli. Und am Ende muss man auch ehrlich sagen, den Leuten ist so ein bisschen egal. Hauptsache es steht Jesus Christus drüber.
Naja, das war ja auch...
Und warum sollte sie es auch interessieren? Also das ist ja irgendwas für Kleriker, so ein hier evangelisch hier, katholisch da, blablabla.
Die einen machen mit und die anderen ohne Weihwasser, aber das war eigentlich egal dann.
Also für die Leute, die nur sonntags in die Kirche gehen und den Rest der Kirche zu Hause privat organisieren, da ist das ja alles egal. Wir machen das jetzt so, kalt schnäuzig, wie wir sind. Wir wissen, Peter Thiel hat den Antichristen auch schon vorgestellt. Warum? Um die Monopolisierung der Weltpolitik hinter einer Idee, wie Klimawandel, irgendwas mit KI oder was, zu verhindern. Möglichst viele Länder, damit die wirtschaftlichen Monopole unter sich bleiben können. Hier ist es dasselbe. Family and Faith sind nicht einfach ja, das hat man besprochen, bevor es um die Politik ging, sondern Nate Silva, der ja auch schon ein bisschen abgedreht ist, hat im Juni einen Text veröffentlicht zum Thema Konservative sind schon bei 30.000 Dollar im Jahr auf einem Zufriedenheitslevel wie progressive erst erst bei 100.000 Dollar sind. Das heißt, wenn man auf Family and Faith geht, kann man sich politisch ganz schön viel ökonomische Einbuße erlauben durch, was weiß ich, für einen Crypto-Creed und so oder ich hätte gerne die Zölle in meiner Hand, ja, weil die Leute dann so ja ok in der Küche keine Politik, ja hier koche ich Essen für die Kinder und so weiter. Also wir haben das auch schon mal behandelt.
Sag nochmal gerade die Zahl, weil das wirklich erstaunlich ist.
Also es ist so eine Grafik, wo die Balken so aufgeschlüsselt sind, von welchen bis welchen Gehaltsspannen man Zufriedenheitslevel hat und danach wissen wir ja, spielt es keine Rolle mehr. Und der Punkt der Konservativen, also der Zufriedenheitspunkt in der Grafik bei 30.000 Dollar Jahreseinkommen deckt sich mit den 100.000 Dollar für Progressive.
Dann sind die erst froh.
Genau.
Sagen wir mal.
Dann sind die auf demselben, die brauchen dreimal mehr Geld, diese Progressiven, um auf dasselbe Zufriedenheitslevel zu kommen. Also für junge Frauen und junge Männer gilt das, früh heiraten, wirklich verliebt sein und dann den Kopf voll haben mit, hoffentlich geht es den Kindern gut. Dann blendet man so ein bisschen die Welt aus. Insbesondere, wenn man auf dem Land lebt, wo wenig Angebote sind, um auch mittwochs abends noch mal irgendwo einen Whisky sauer zu trinken. Klingt jetzt ein bisschen despektierlich und so, aber Studienlage ist Studienlage und offenbar lässt sich daraus politisches Programm ableiten.
Ja, man kann es ja sehr gut verstehen, denn wenn nicht dieser religiöse Halt vorhanden ist, der dort ja in ganz hohem Maße propagiert wird, dann muss man sich ja einen Ersatz suchen, also den Halt schaffen und das ist ja relativ teuer. Also das heißt, man muss ja versuchen, sich dann z.B. beruflich einen Halt zu geben, im Lebensstil einen Halt geben. Man muss versuchen, einen Lifestyle auszuprägen, eine Identität, die individualistisch ist. Individualistisch meint, also nicht nach Serie bedeutet, also mehr ausgeben, weil es nicht seriengefertigt ist. Also das ist ja dann ein Leben nach Maß, das man haben möchte. Und wir wissen, Maßanzüge sind teurer als von der Stange. Und was hier angeboten wird, ist, wir haben hier schon mal alle Schablonen da. Ihr könnt euch da einfügen. Ihr braucht doch gar nicht viel Geld. Ihr müsst nur sehen, dass ihr dann mehr Kinder, als ihr euch eigentlich leisten könnt, auf die Welt bringt. Ihr müsst häufig beten. Und ihr könnt euch dann unsere Videos angucken oder kommt zu unseren großen Events. Und das ist wirklich nicht despektivisch gemeint, sondern ich glaube, das ist so ganz klar, weshalb ja auch so eine große Frustration vorhanden ist. Denn wenn das andere nicht da ist, was ist denn eigentlich? Ich hatte gerade mit Ole diesen Roman Rabbit Run von John Abdeich besprochen. Das ist ja Anfang der 60er Jahre. Und der erzählt ja von einem Mann, der eigentlich so ein Star in der Highschool ist, was Basketball anbelangt, dann aber in so ein normales Leben muss, mit seiner Frau nicht glücklich ist. Dann bekommt sie jetzt das zweite Kind und er haut ab. Und dann ist eigentlich den halben Roman lang ein episkopalischer Pastor hinter ihm her, um ihm zu sagen, Familie ist wichtig und der Weg zu Gott und so was. Aber der kann das nur aus so einer allgemeinen Verantwortung für Familie noch mal sagen, ich kehre zurück. Aber diese religiöse Dimension, die ist einfach nicht da. Und davon erzählt Abdeich und erzählen ja so viele Romane in der zweiten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts in den USA, aber auch in Deutschland. Und jetzt ist aber plötzlich das religiöse zurückgekehrt, hat man also, auch weil der ökonomische Status immer schlechter wurde, weil die Aufstiegsversprechen auch nicht mehr so funktionieren, ja eigentlich dann als Anker wieder die Religion, weil man sagt gut, also beruflich wird es wahrscheinlich nicht so bergauf gehen, aber ich kann mich trotzdem nach oben richten, nämlich zu Gott.
Ja, wir hatten ja mal ganz kurz damals bei der Papstwahl diese Erweckungslösungs, was auch immer, südamerikanischen, die sagen Gott ist nie verschwunden, das religiöse, sonst wurde reformuliert. Plötzlich hat man so ganz weltliche Wünsche gehabt, wie auch immer. Und wir hatten einen anderen Salortext. Wir können das als Salornachröhn, deswegen hier nur ungefähr. Am glücklichsten sind die Menschen, die ihre Lebensaufgaben aus dem sozialen Umfeld, das sie unmittelbar erleben, ableiten. Also sorge dich um die Eltern, die die Nachbarn sind, kümmere dich noch um die anderen Nachbarn, die Kinder, wie auch immer. Wenn du aber, ja und alles darüber hinaus ist sozusagen so weit hinter dem Horizont. Irgendwo ist ein Gott, der gibt dir eine Aufgabe, aber erledigen musst du die an deinem Mann, an deinen Kindern und so weiter. Also es wird alles abgeleitet. Während du, wenn du in diese moderne Richtung gehst, dann wird deine Lebensaufgabe abgeleitet von irgendeinem Fitness-Influencer, der dir ein Programm bei YouTube vorsagt. Zudem hast du gar keinen Kontakt, der wird dir nie Bestätigung geben, wie auch immer. Deine beruflichen Sachen hängen davon ab, dass dieser Chef, der einmal im Jahr aus London angeflogen kommt und so, also auch ist alles viel zu weit weg. Und das kann man natürlich ausbeuten, indem man diese Art von elementarer Lebenszufriedenheit, die nun mal in uns einprogrammiert ist, einfach wieder weckt. Und das erfolgreiche Programm ist das religiöse. Also finde das hier statt. Jetzt brauchen wir natürlich jemanden, der uns diese Shijekse Idiotie, nämlich das eigene Leben, nur sozusagen im Umfeld, am allgemeinen Vibe, an religiöser Vorgabe abzuleiten, der uns das erklärt. Und ich hab's jetzt mit Absicht Shijekses Idiotie genannt, weil er sich ja selber in dem Buch, wir haben ja den Ausschnitt gelesen im letzten Salon, weniger als nichts, das unterstellt. Und wir brauchen hier jemanden, der uns das, uns da Clips gibt. Und wir haben so jemanden, nämlich mit Ijoma Mangold. Wir haben schon mal festgestellt, dass Ijoma Mangold, also Zeit-Vötau-Redakteur und die sogenannte Gegenwart, Podcaster, Bitcoiner, genau, dass er in der Lage ist, mit so einem externen Vibe zu gehen. Also irgendwer erklärt ihm im Internet, das mit Bitcoin ist voll super für dich und so. Und er geht voll drauf ein. Bitcoin kann man nicht sehen, nicht fühlen, nicht schmecken und nichts. Und um Ruhigstöpfchen erzählt dir die ganze Zeit, das ist ein Nullsummspiel und du gehst eher als Verlierer raus. Aber solange der Vibe stimmt, geht auch Mangold mit. Also brauchen wir ja Mangold. Und er hatte im September jetzt einen Podcastausflug in die Schweiz.
Da war ich auch. Ich war auch auf dem Festival am einen Tag vorher.
Ah ja, also wir hören dieses Podcastfestival.
Das wurde dort von der protestantischen Kirche organisiert.
Ja, sehr gut, sehr passend.
Der reformierten Kirchen.
Genau, also die Zeit labelt den Podcast. Welchen Weltuntergang hätten Sie denn gerne? Frage. Die sogenannte Gegenwart denkt über die apokalyptischen Naherwartungen nach und versucht zu deeskalieren. Was er nur heißt. Kluge Leute versuchen uns was zu erklären. Wir hören jetzt diesen Ausschnitt. Es ist zentral geht es. Also wir hören fast nur Clips aus einem achtminütigen Monolog von Ejumamangal zum Thema Wie war das denn jetzt mit? Warum gibt es da einen Antichristen? Warum ist er nicht da und so weiter und so fort? Wir versuchen das jetzt in unsere Fragestellung hier zu reformulieren. Denn wenn man diese Veranstaltung länger da gesehen hat, ich habe sie auch nicht ganz gesehen, aber in großen Ausschnitten, es hatte sehr viel von Anfang und Ende. Und man wusste nicht so genau, ist Kirks Tod jetzt ein Anfang oder ein Ende? Es ging sehr viel um die anderen. Um wenn wir den anderen den falschen Umgang haben, ist alles vorbei und so weiter. Also man hatte diese ganz großen religiösen der Weltuntergangen.
Aber Kirk lebte ja zu dem Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme noch.
Der Podcast.
Das weiß ich ziemlich genau.
Ja, genau, aber er wurde am 15. September veröffentlicht danach. Aber das ist alles egal. Die reden ja nicht über Kirk. Nur deswegen ist es ja für uns jetzt, es ist sozusagen noch unvergiftet von diesem Einschlag, den es da gab. Also lassen wir uns das jetzt von Ijoma Mangold erklären, was es mit diesem religiösen Denken, das nun wirklich fundamental ist für die Trump-Regierung sowieso und deren Handlanger, die da die Geschäfte führen, aber insbesondere jetzt durch solche Veranstaltungen, wie sie da organisiert wurden, mit entsprechenden Zielsetzungen. Also Mangolds Worte. Was braucht man? Und das, klar, steckt da hier schon im Titel drin des Podcasts. Eine Weltuntergangserzählung. Irgendwas muss abgewendet werden.
In der Tat, alle Lager neigen dazu, gerne so Letzterzählungen im Umlauf zu bringen.
So, wir brauchen alle Letzterzählungen, denn wir brauchen eine Untergangsstimmung. Wir wollen natürlich immer reformulieren. Ja, nichts lenkt dich besser von Irgendwer hat deine ökonomischen Probleme verursacht, ab als eine Letzterzählung, die dich in deine Schicksalsfrage reindrängt. Und dann am besten wird der Antwort, liebe deine Frau und kümmere dich um deine Kinder. Halt die Klappe. So, wir haben also eine Ausgangslage von ganz frühen Christen. Und das erkennen wir dann gleich in dieser Veranstaltung da wieder, die für Charlie Kirk veranstaltet wurde. Das Ende ist nah, aber wir leiden nicht darunter, sondern wir versuchen, das Beste daraus zu machen.
Das Ende ist nah, ist ja kein Schreckensspruch gewesen, sondern eine totale herrliche Aussicht auf das vor der Tür stehende Paradies. Das muss man eigentlich nur noch beten.
Ja, es gibt ja zum Beispiel eine Bach-Kantate, die da heißt, ich freue mich auf meinen Tod.
Genau.
Die Freude auf den Tod, weil es im Jenseitsjahr umso besser weitergeht, wie bei Gladiator, also so vorchristliche Sachen, was wir im Leben tun, Echoes in Eternity und so. Also diese Idee von, ja, es sieht schlimm aus, der Weltuntergang ist kurz bevor, die Linken erschießen uns jetzt sogar schon, aber für die, die hier Opfer werden, ihr werdet, da steht ja der Gladiator so da, also falls ihr euch wundert, weil ihr die Augen aufschlagt, die Sonne scheint und ihr lauft durch die grünen Wiesen, ihr seid tot und alle lachen. Also man kann da noch das Beste draus ableiten. Was man jetzt aber braucht, ist eine hoffnungsstiftende Idee in diesem Weltuntergangsszenario.
Sie glauben, an was glauben Sie ja? An die Wiederkehr des Gekreuzigten, dass Jesus Christus wie an Ostern gewissermaßen im großen Stil wieder zurückkehrt und dann ist das Ende aller Tage erreicht?
So, also der große Wunsch der Wiederkehr, der des Wiedersehens, dass es war zwar blöd, aber nicht umsonst diesen Hoffnungsstiftenden Gedanken. Jetzt hören wir mal, wie die Ideen in diesem Memorial da eingebaut haben. Also wir hören namenlose Weggefährten und andere Funktionäre aus Kirchen und was auch immer für Organisationen, die dort auf der Bühne stehen und versuchen, aus dem Ende des Lebens von Charlie Kirk so eine Alpha Omega, so einen Bogenschlag zu machen. Also die dachten, sie töten Charlie Kirk und damit sehen wir das Böse, dachte es tut uns etwas Böses an, aber Gott hat gesagt, nein, das ist keine Beerdigung, das ist eine Revival, was wir hier feiern. Es ist eine Erweckung von was auch immer. Charlie Kirk ist tot, aber so ging es die ganze Zeit.
Wenn man sagt im Christentum, dass Jesus Christus am dritten Tage auferstanden ist von den Toten, dann ist der Tod nicht etwas, vor dem man sich zum Beispiel fürchten muss.
Gott hat einen Plan für dich, auch wenn du ihn noch nicht verstehst, aber vertraue auf das Leben danach.
Charlie's death was not just a murder. The true word for what Charlie did is sacrifice.
Also Charlie Kirk ist das Opfer für uns. Er wurde für uns geopfert, kennen wir doch irgendwo her.
You see the difference between murder and sacrifice.
Und das soll man auch nicht anders sehen können, denn Gott befindet ja darüber.
Ja, aber das ist ja eine Rede, die könnte man ja so bei jedem Soldatenbegräbnis halten.
Ja, wird ja auch.
Also das ist ja genau diese Idee.
Das Tod war nicht umsonst, der ist für uns gestorben.
Das ist ja das, was jetzt gerade abverlangt wird, man muss bereit sein Opfer zu bringen und Opfer meint also nicht das Victim, sein also einfach nur Spielball der Kräfte, passiv, sondern das Sacrifice meint natürlich, dass man damit eigentlich sich verewigt und auch den Gedanken verewigt, man ist gestorben für Gott, für die Demokratie, für die Meinungsfreiheit, was auch immer oder jetzt neuerdings für LGBTQ-Rechte vorkonwerhaft. Und das ist so eine Redeweise, die nie verschwunden ist und die bei unseren ganzen Mitte-liberaldemokraten absolut vorhanden ist, sobald es um den Staat geht. Wenn man das mit Religion bei denen knüpft, dann sind die so ein bisschen irritiert, aber in Wahrheit haben die das nur ein bisschen ins Säkulare geholt, aus der Religion aber entlehnt.
Die formulieren ja einfach nur in originalistischer Sprache aus, was andere modernen Säkular eben auch reformulieren. Und sind damit ein bisschen näher dran.
Also lieber Tod als Rot ist ja früher die Formulierung gewesen im Kalten Krieg. Wir haben das jetzt heute wieder, wenn Friedrich Merz zum Thema Frieden angesprochen wird und sagt, ja Frieden gibt es auf dem Friedhof. Also das ist das ist für ihn nicht nicht erstrebenswert. Ja, wenn gesagt wird, man muss bereit sein, das zu tun, was zählt und man muss auch bereit sein, sich zu opfern für einen höheren Wert oder für die Familie oder so, dann meint das immer genau dieses Denken von Charlie Kirk. Also ich glaube ja, dass wir, das ist natürlich skurril. Ich habe mir das Memorial ja auch dann so in Auszügen angesehen. Aber im Prinzip sind wir viel näher an Schloss Bellevue und Anneville, als wir das wahrhaben.
Genau. Es ist nur eine Frage der Formulierung. Und hier können die natürlich aus den Vollen schöpfen, denn der Tyrannenmord, der dann auch in göttlichem Auftrag gerechtfertigt werden kann, liegt ja hier nicht vor, sondern es wurde ja ein Märtyrer geboren. Und als Märtyrer ist man auch begrifflich sozusagen fast stellvertreter Jesu.
Charlie's assassin thought that he could steal and silence his voice by putting a bullet in his neck. In the words of Soren Kierkegaard, the tyrant dies and his rule is over, the martyr dies and his rule has just begun.
Juckmann, da wird noch Soren Kierkegaard zitiiert.
Genau, genau. Kommen alle vor, ja? So, jetzt, das sind sozusagen die Vorredner für Erika Kirk. Und Erika Kirk hat natürlich jetzt die Aufgabe, sie übernimmt ja jetzt diesen 100 Millionen Laden Turning Point USA, bei dem ja die Aufgabenstellung völlig klar ist, Gefolgschaft herzustellen. Sie leitet jetzt die weltliche Aufgabe für die Anwesenden daraus ab.
Aber vor allem hat Gott's Gnade und Gott's Liebe in den letzten zehn Tagen zu mir gezeigt, nach Charlie's Erkundigung, haben wir keine Gewalt gesehen. Wir haben keine Reaktion gesehen. Wir haben keine Revolution gesehen. Vielmehr haben wir gesehen, was mein Mann immer betrachtet hat, was er in diesem Land sehen würde. Wir haben Revival gesehen.
So, also, die Leute sind erweckt. Sie ist erfreut zu sehen, dass Leute das erste Mal die Bibel öffnen, wieder in die Kirche gehen und so weiter. Das ist jetzt das Programm. Und jetzt ist da natürlich die Idee dahinter, wenn ich die Bibel öffne und in die Kirche gehe, sehe ich dort Charlie Kirk. Also im Sinne von Alfa Omega, der Gekreuzigte, der wieder präsent wird mir gegenüber. Nur das Problem ist, im Christentum, Jesus kam ja gar nicht so richtig wieder. Also, the Christ ist ja immer abstrakt und abstinent geblieben.
Das ist die Parosie. Die Parosie ist die Wiederkehr des Herrn. Und das Christentum hat von der ersten Stunde an das Problem der ausbleibenden Parosie, weil Jesus Christus nicht zurückkehrt.
So, Jesus kommt ja gar nicht zurück. Was ist jetzt, wenn die Leute sich Vorstellungen und Wünsche machen, politisch abgeleitet aus Charlie Kirk? Das muss ja was bedeuten. Und da stellt man fest, ich bin jetzt drei Jahre in die Kirche gegangen und das Essen ist immer noch teuer und so richtig läuft es in der Familie auch nicht, was auch immer. Also, was macht man dann, wenn die Erlösung nicht kommt? Tja, man musste sich Gedanken machen. Mal sehen, wir hören jetzt Mangold zum Thema die frühen Kirchenmanager. Das müssen sich natürlich die Trump-Leutenden auch.
Also müssen sich die entsprechenden frühen Manager dieses Kirchentums Gedanken darüber machen, wie sie ihre Gemeinden, die teilweise nicht mehr arbeiten gehen, die nur noch beten, weil sie sagen, es lohnt sich gar nicht mehr zu arbeiten, weil Jesus Christus kommt ja eh gleich zurück und dann ist das Himmel reichen da. Und jetzt kommt aber die Parosie verzögert sich und dazu braucht man eine Erklärung, dass man die Leute bei der Stange halten kann.
Ja, also ich will jetzt nochmal nicht, dass jemand denkt, weil ich jetzt hier Mangold Clips spiele, der Ijoma Mangold nimmt das ganz ernst. Also der hat ein echtes Interesse, genau so zu verstehen, wie Peter Thiel und so darüber denken, wenn die sowas sagen. Also verzieht er das so voll nach. Ich höre diesen Podcast, ich sehe die Veranstaltungen und ich finde es einfach absurd und amüsant.
Ich dachte, dass er jetzt einfach nur erklärend die Modelle.
Ja, das ist sehr erklärend, aber wir wissen ja, wie das bei...
Aber die Faszination ist dann doch ein bisschen zu groß.
Die Faszination kommt auch sehr über Lars Weißbrod. Der ja immer, und das gibt es auch bei HJ. Schumacher im Podcast, Männer, die feststellen, dass sie auch andere Männer nachdenken. Also, dass die anderen gar nicht non-playable Charakters sind, sondern auch durchaus Main-Character. Zum Beispiel, weil sie eine Milliarde haben oder mal eine Idee, die man nicht sofort verwirft. Diese von, ach, diese anderen Männer sind ja echt so dumm und so, ja. Und wir alle haben unsere Lieblingsmänner, denen wir so im Gedanken folgen. Nur für Ijoma Mangold ist eben Peter Thiel so ein Typ. Und zwar, und das ist das Idiotische, nicht, weil Ijoma Mangold, das war, vielleicht findet er es selbst interessant, ja, aber er sieht, dass andere Leute interessant finden, was Peter Thiel da sagt. Also, dieses Mimetische da drin ist halt sehr scharf. Weshalb er sich, ohne drüber lustig zu machen, dass Peter Thiel den folgenden Gedanken ja ausbeutet für sich, uns ihn einfach darbietet. Denn wir haben jetzt festgestellt, okay, wir brauchen so eine, die Welt ist scheiße und wir müssen es aber akzeptieren lernen. Also haben wir eine Hoffnungserlösungssicht. Nur diese Perspektive wird niemals wahr, weil die Erlösung kommt einfach nicht. Warum? Sie wird verhindert. Wer verhindert sie? Der Antichrist. Weil er auch nicht kommt. Also ja, ganz verdreht. Wir lösen das gleich. Also eigentlich eine Kindergeschichte für eine Seite der vier. Aber wir lassen uns jetzt von Ijoma Mangold die Erlösung zur Erlösung. Wo bleibt sie?
Die biblische Vorstellung des Weltuntergangs ist, dass dem Untergang zuvor der Antichrist kommt. Das greift später dann Luther auf. Wenn Luther sagt, der Papst in Rom, das ist der eigentliche Antichrist. Aber der Antichrist ist zwar eine Emanation des Bösen, aber dann weiß man, wenn der Antichrist kommt, dann kann er nach Jesus Christus zurückkehren, weil er den Antichristen besiegt. Das heißt, in heilsgeschichtlicher Vorstellung ist der Antichrist geradezu eine notwendige Voraussetzung.
Ja, also wenn ich jetzt eingeladen wäre, mit dir am Zürichsee über sowas zu reden, was denkt Donald Trump und Peter Thiel, würde ich sagen, das ist ein bisschen wie bei Marvel. Wir alle wollen Iron Man sehen. Das Problem ist nur, wenn wir Iron Man in voller Pracht in Minute 50 Films zeigen, geht der Film nur fünf Minuten. Also muss erst eine Aufgabe formuliert werden für Iron Man, weil ohne Aufgabe kein Glänzen. Er muss erst entführt werden in einer Höhle mittellos, wo er sich irgendwas zusammenschlawinert in Begeiver-Manier, damit er dann nach 90 Minuten, das wissen wir eigentlich auch vorher, aber wir wollen es trotzdem sehen, wie er leidet, ja, er braucht einen Gegenpol, einen Antichrist.
Ja, Phänos oder so.
Wie auch immer. Ja, 1000 Namen, 4000 Marvel-Helden finden natürlich alle ihren Antichristen jeweils. Man braucht so einen Antichristen. Das Problem ist nur, der Antichrist kommt ja auch nicht. Also nicht nur kommt Jesus nicht zurück, sondern der Antichrist kommt ja auch nicht. Wie wollen wir jetzt unseren Film machen? Also muss das weitererzählt werden. Ich habe mir so ein bisschen gedacht, es ist auch wie beim Warten auf Godot. Wir haben dieses Stück von Samuel Beckett, das wir in der Schule gespielt haben in Auszügen, was ich herausstelle, als ist einfach super langweilig. Die sitzen halt da und gehen einen Dialog durch.
Nein, so kann man das nun wirklich nicht sagen. Also das ist nicht ein Stück, das spannungsvoll sein will im Sinne von, da sollte was passieren, sondern genau das ist es ja, dass Beckett uns eine Welt zeigt, in der genau das nicht mehr eintrifft. Also Godot kann ja zum Beispiel für Gott stehen.
Davon gehen wir jetzt mal aus, dass wir dafür stehen.
Und der muss nicht nur, aber kann auch. Das trifft nicht ein. Es ist auch ein Stück, das nach der Shoah entsteht, also auch damit natürlich zu tun hat, also mit der Abwesenheit Gottes dort. Und gerade darin, wie diese Lehre, das ewig gewahrt in Pfandelfürth und das ja nicht das einzige Stück, in dem das so ein Thema ist bei Beckett, sondern das wiederholt sich, ist ja wiederkehrend bei Beckett, auch in Variation dann. Genau daraus entsteht ja das Spannungsreiche, das zu erleben als Theaterstück. Wenn ich natürlich in dem Modus da sitze und sage, ja, aber wann passiert dann mal was? Dann geht das nicht auf.
Ich will das jetzt einbetten in diese christliche Geschichte, wie wir sie heute nachträglich erzählen. Ich würde ja sagen, es ist sehr viel interessanter. Sehe ich das reale Leben, soweit wir es wissen, als soziologisches Phänomen orientiert am Christentum oder irgendeiner Idee. Es könnte aber Mitra sein, in Frankfurt oder was auch immer. Nur wir haben, sagen wir mal, 2000 Jahre später, Shoa blende ich jetzt mal aus, warten auf Godot, der Gott. Eine Situation, in der wir ein Bühnenstück sehen, in dem im Dialog, ohne dass viel rumgelaufen wird, erklärt wird uns als Zuschauer implizit, Gott kommt gar nicht. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, kam Gott nicht, weil er keine Aufgabe sah, zu kommen, wovon sollte er die erlösen? Es ist ja gar keine bedrohliche Situation da, im Sinne von die Erlösung muss schon wirklich von etwas erlösen. Also die Problemstellung, da ist ein Antikreis und der wütet im Marble, und dann gibt es immer zeitreisende Aliens oder wer auch immer, so und am Ende kommt der Christ und besiegt dann alle. Und ich finde es sehr witzig, dass in Warten auf Godot auch eine Pointe ist, christlich abgeleitet. Gott kommt nicht, weil er erlöst dich nicht von Langeweile. Das musst du schon selber machen, so in diesem Stile. Jetzt sind wir aber hier, wo wir das alles ganz ernst nehmen und deswegen brauchen wir eine dritte Figur, den Katechon, der Aufhalter.
Und eine dieser Erklärungen gibt Paulus, ich weiß gar nicht, wo er da war, bei den Korinthern, glaube ich. Da führt er den sehr enigmatischen, dunklen Begriff des Katechon ein. Katechon übersetzt sich als der Aufhalter, der letzte Aufhalter.
So, ab jetzt wird es politisch, denn wir müssen uns jetzt fragen, ok, Christ, Antichrist, das hört man so ein bisschen, das sind irgendwie christliche Begriffe.
Wer hält wen gerade auf?
Katechon, genau. Haben wir es nicht grundsätzlich so mit Hämmern zu tun, die uns immer hemmen wollen die ganze Zeit? Obwohl auf der Bühne immer an Sonntagsreden so das große Enable und Empowerment stattfindet. Und ich würde jetzt sagen, den Leuten einzureden, ne, du musst nicht in Labor forschen für eine Milliarde Euro irgendwas und hier und da und in die Schule. Nein, krieg einfach drei Kinder und fertig. Deine Lebensaufgabe ist erledigt. Das ist ja auch so ein gewisser Hämmer. Ja, Katechon, wie auch immer. Wir lassen uns das von Mangert noch ein bisschen erklären.
Wenn der Antichrist derjenige ist, der das Böse und das Chaos bringt, dann kann man ihn aufhalten durch ein weltliches, das Regime, das das Schlimmste verhindert, das wahrlich nicht das Himmelsreich ist.
So, wenn wir wollen, dass die Menschen christlich leben, dann sollten sie das machen. Und dann stellt aber die Trump-Regierung fest, ja, dem stehen ja so weltliche Zwänge im Wege. Historisch gesehen, theologisch leitet Mangold das jetzt so ab.
Jetzt kommt aber der Antichrist nicht. Warum, sagt Paulus? Ja, weil das römische Reich der Katechon ist.
So, das römische Reich hat also den Leuten gesagt, ich weiß, ihr wartet auf die große Erlösung und die wird bestimmt auch irgendwann kommen, aber wir haben auch kleine Alltagsprobleme und die lösen wir jetzt mal mit Bürokratie. Und dann haben die Leute festgestellt, ja, das macht Sinn. Also wenn hier Wasser fließt und morgens alle gemeinsam zur Arbeit gehen, dann kriegt man auch richtig was gewobt. Vielleicht brauchen wir gar nicht die Erlösung. Vielleicht reicht es einfach völlig, so ein bisschen mit Bürokratie machen und so. Und jetzt sind wir in der Moderne, also in unserer Moderne. Die Trump-Regierung steht ja auch da und sagt, ja, hier sind noch ganz schön viele weltliche Beschränkungen, die uns so im Wege stehen, so eine Art römisches Reich. Das muss ja erst mal abgebaut werden. Wir haben das im Gespräch von Israel Klein mit dem israelischen Soziologen gehört, der oder was auch immer, der immer die konservativen Dinger da organisierte, genau. Der auch meinte, nee, du musst zuerst, das ist das, was sie denken, was sie glauben, was sie tun, die Empathie völlig zerstören, damit du wieder eine Homogenität herstellen kannst. Und ja, es muss nicht gleich Holocaust sein, aber so ein paar Lager, wo so Leute eingesperrt werden, wäre schon gut, damit du danach wieder auf Empathie in der Gesellschaft aufbauen musst. Also es muss erst ein weltlicher Abriss stattfinden, damit danach wieder ein Aufbau stattfinden kann. So, es muss also eine...
Na, wir hatten das ja auch in den Diskussionen. Wir hatten da mal aus dem Allesgesagt-Podcast was gespielt, wo auch gesagt wurde, dass jetzt immer mehr in Politikreisen, in Journalismuskeisen so eine Idee davon da ist, vielleicht braucht es noch mal einen großen Krieg. Also auch das funktioniert ja nach dieser Idee, dass da auch noch mal so eine Reinigung dann dadurch stattfindet und dass man wieder besser starten kann, gesünder starten kann. Genau.
Ich will nur kurz, ich habe es schon ein paar Mal genannt von Stefan Kühl, diese neue Soziologie zur Staatsorganisation im Dritten Reich und danach. Denn da wird auch der staatliche Katechon, um es jetzt mal so zu reformulieren, dargestellt, verglichen mit, okay, wir haben das eine Mal so charismatische Führung abgeleitet von Adolf Hitler, dem großen Führer. Werden so kleine, die sind ihm direkt unterstellt und wenn der einen Zuruf macht, dann machen die das schon. Und dann hat man darauf reagiert und gesagt, nach dem Krieg, okay, niemand macht hier mehr irgendwas mit selber Kopf einschalten, sondern es wird alles hardcore durchbürokratisiert. Einzelne Stellenausschreibungen, Stefan Kühlspor-Arnte, bis zu 60, 20 Seiten, DIN-A4-Stellenbeschreibung. Was darfst du, was darfst du nicht? Und danach hält man sich. Also keiner macht hier mehr diesen, muss man auch sagen, etwas Sakral und von der Kirche gestützten Föllefanz mit, der wird schon richten, der ist sozusagen gesandt. So, jetzt sitzen ja in dieser Memorial-Veranstaltung auch die Trumpianer vorne direkt mit drin. Wir hören in Ausschnitten, wie sie angesprochen werden.
Das ist das, was Charlie uns wissen wollte, über sein Glauben in Jesus Christ. Die Macht von Christes Blut und die Macht von Martyrschaft spricht über Charlie. Der Apostel Paul würde die Bücher des Romans schreiben. Und ich möchte nur mit diesem enden. In Romans 13 spricht der Apostel Paul über eine göttliche Regierung, institutiert von unserem Herr und Seher. Und was beschreibt er? Der Apostel Paul beschreibt, wie Gott die Rulier der Nationen erstaunt. In der Publikation jetzt gibt es Rulier unserer Land.
Er könnte auch sagen, alle Avengers sind da.
Genau, genau, die Avengers sind da. Sie werden für euch dieses weltliche zivilisatorische Projekt amerikanische Bundesregierung aus dem Weg räumen, damit endlich der Antichrist Raum greifen kann mit seiner Chaos und Wut, damit uns dann endlich Gott wieder erlöst und Jesus Christus schickt.
Ja, ja.
So ist das hier alles angelegt.
Dann kommt Charlie Kirk wieder und macht das dann alles.
Genau, dann kommt Charlie Kirk wieder und räumt dann richtig auf und establisht dann dieses, und er ja hier schon, wir können ja jetzt schon mal die Gegenwerte-Regierungen, die wir haben, dass sie sich nicht mehr dagegen wehrt, einfach göttlich abgesandt, ja, so ein Gottesgnadentum einrichten oder so.
Und das ist aber diese neue Dimension, die jetzt reingekommen ist. Natürlich haben sich alle Präsidenten immer auf Gott berufen. Und es gibt ja die kuriosesten Äußerungen dann bei Ronald Reagan, der bei irgendwelchen Staatstreffen dann sagte, jetzt beten wir erst einmal und dann mussten mal alle auf die Knie gehen. Bis hin zu den Gründerveltern der USA, die auch Engel gesehen haben, die ihnen nochmal erzählt haben, was in die Verfassung reingehört. Wir haben das bei Bruno Marquez, glaube ich, damals History Has Begun, das Buch, das ich auch nochmal sehr empfehlen will in dem Zusammenhang. Wir haben das damals im Salon besprochen. Da kamen dann lauter solche Geschichten auch noch vor. Also diese Religiosität mit gleichzeitiger Fiktionalisierung der Realität. Und was aber jetzt hier nochmal besonders deutlich wird, ist, dass wir tatsächlich so einen Machtblock haben von christlichen Fundamentalisten, die sich verbinden mit der Regierung und jetzt aus diesem Eifer heraus sagen, unsere Politik plötzlich ist eine, die von Gott geleitet ist. Das heißt, sie kann auch nicht mehr falsch sein, weil Gott ja keine Fehler macht.
Genau. Und selbst wenn alle leiden, das ist halt das Neue. Es gelten nicht mehr die allgemeinen Kriterien im Sinne von Arbeitslosigkeit ist niedrig, Steuern sind niedrig, uns geht es allen gut und jeder kann studieren, was er will, das ist gut, sondern jetzt gilt, wenn wir alle leiden, heißt das, wir sind auf dem richtigen Weg, der Antichrist kommt, bald werden wir erlöst, weil ohne Antichrist keine christliche Erlösung.
Deswegen ist es vielleicht dann gar nicht so dumm von Trump, auch wenn es vielleicht zufällig aus ihm so rausplappert, wenn er nochmal auf die Zölle eingeht, bei dem Memorial für Charlie Kirk, weil das etwas ist, worunter jetzt gerade die amerikanischen Konsumenten leiden. Aber wir wissen, Leiden gehört dazu als guter Christ, genauso wie er ja auch schon sagte, in einigen Interviews zuvor, lange bevor das Attentat war, brauchen Kinder wirklich so viele Puppen, brauchen kleine Mädchen 30 Puppen zu Hause, reichen nicht auch zwei. Also bedeutet das nicht, dass wir uns christlich bescheiden. Und das ist ja eine Aussage, die hört man von D-Crow-Anhängern vielleicht. Ja, brauchen wir wirklich 30 Puppen. Aber jeder Präsident vorher, ob demokratisch oder republikanisch, hätte gesagt, Leute kauft, kauft, kauft, kauft.
Das war immer das amerikanische Programm.
Das ist hier unsere Wirtschaft.
Absurd, dass wir das jetzt so in Szenewechsel hier haben. Wir werden wirklich Vorzeichen umgedreht. Alle werden ausgerichtet, orientiert an dem Guten und dem Bösen.
Und was sagt der Apostel Paul in den Romans über eine göttliche Führung? Er sagt, dass Rulier die Schwierigkeiten haben, für die Schutzung von guten Männern und für den Schaden von bösen Männern.
Also Terror, solange es gegen die Böse Seite ist, absolut gerechtfertigt. So ein Ausschnitt eines aktiven Politikers Pete Hexseth, oh gewöhn nachher noch Stephen Miller, aber hier mal Pete Hexseth, der jetzt seine Lehren daraus ableitet.
This is not a political war. It's not even a cultural war. It's a spiritual war. Faith and family first. There is a God and as Charlie would say, it is not us. We're sinners saved only by grace in need of the gospel. You see, we always did need less government. But what Charlie understood and infused into his movement is, we also needed a lot more God. Charlie had big plans, but God had even bigger plans.
Also, früher hätte ich gesagt, diese Rede hat er unmöglich selber geschrieben. Ist ja klar, er hat Redenschreiber und so. Diesmal denke ich mir, das ist wirklich Chet Chibbittee. Also das sind die einfachsten Logiken. Government, God, er hatte große Pläne für sich, aber God hatte größere Pläne und so. Das ist wirklich Chibbittee 3.5 irgendwie. Ohne größere Raffinesse. So, wir haben also jetzt Folgendes established, bevor wir wieder Ejoma Mangold nimmt, der das alles ganz ernst nimmt. Also ich würde auf der Bühne sitzen und sagen, ja, sie müssen das wirklich verstehen. Es ist absurd, aber die wollen die Erlösung. Also brauchen sie einen Erlöser. Der Erlöser braucht dabei eine Aufgabe. Also braucht der Erlöser vorher einen Zerstörer. Klammer auf, Antichrist, klammer zu, nenne ich das in dieser komischen Kultsekte da. Nur der Zerstörer kommt nicht, weil der Aufhalter da ist. Der Aufhalter ist unser weltliches. Wir kriegen es eigentlich ganz gut hin. Wir brauchen die Erlösung gar nicht. Das glauben Leute immer.
Lass mich da mal einhaken. Ich finde das ganz erstaunlich, denn jetzt ist ja Mangold, so wie er es vorträgt, nicht ein Anhänger dieser Lehren, sondern er beschreibt sie.
Doch, der ist Anhänger.
Nein, nein, ich will es differenzieren. Er ist, glaube ich, nicht Anhänger dieser Lehren. Dafür beschreibt er es ja anders. Aber ich glaube, und das ist dann vergleichbar mit dem Bitcoin-Buch und das will ich jetzt aber gar nicht auf Mangold Münzen, sondern ist generell, glaube ich, ein Phänomen, dass man sagt, sobald da irgendwie so ein Gebäude ist, ein Denkgebäude, das verschiedene Stockwerke hat, Geheimtüren, die zu öffnen sind.
Dass wir sagen, wie es obskur ist. Das fasziniert ihn, weil er gerne in eine Gruselbahn geht.
Dann kann man da ganz einsteigen. Dann kann man sich in die Welt verlieren. Im Prinzip ist es so, wie wir das bei ganz vielen Fankulturen haben.
Rabbit halls nennen wir das.
Wir haben das auch bei der Manga-Kultur, dass man sagt, ja, ich muss also diese 157 Comics lesen und dann die 80 Serien dazu gucken und dann die Karten tauschen, die es dazu gibt. Dann bin ich Teil des Ganzen. Genau. In dieser Weise, glaube ich, wird jetzt auch die Religion für viele so interessant, weil man plötzlich so Begrifflichkeiten hat, mit denen man sich auseinandersetzen kann. Denn der Rest ist ja sonst in der Konsumwelt gewesen. Gut, man kann sich darüber unterhalten, welche Kaffeemaschine ist die beste. Kauft man eine Rolex oder eine Breitling? Welches Parfum soll es sein? Ja, solche Verbrauchertipps konnte man sich holen. Man konnte vielleicht auch noch eine Exklusivität erlangen, dass man bei MS auf die Liste gesetzt wird und angerufen wird, wenn es die Handtaschen gibt oder sowas. Aber jetzt kommen wir eigentlich an so einen Punkt, an dem man sagen kann, wir bieten hier so ein Weltgebäude rein, komm mal hier rein, trete über die Schwelle. Und wenn du tritt über die Schwelle und wenn du das gemacht hast, dann kann ich dir ganz viele Räume zeigen und dann gibt es noch ein Stachwerk und noch ein weiteres und noch ein weiteres. Und damit funktioniert, glaube ich, das heute so gut im Fan-Kultur-YouTube-Zeit, Alter, weil man einfach was hat, mit dem man sich sehr tief beschäftigen kann. Es ist dann zwar immer auch wieder runterzubrechen auf was ganz Einfaches, pflanze dich fort, glaube an Gott, aber es ist dann auch noch mal die Möglichkeit, sich näher da so reinzufuchsen. Und das geht eben einher mit der Sache Bitcoin. Also eigentlich könnte man ja sagen, ach, ich will ein bisschen spekulieren, ich kauf mal Bitcoin oder kauf ETPs, die Bitcoin vertreten. Und das ist ja eine Sache, das hat man ja in zehn Minuten für sich geklärt, ob man das machen will oder nicht. Aber der Bitcoin und die anderen Kryptowährungen bieten natürlich auch noch an, dass du ein ganzes Weltgebäude bekommst, wenn du nur bereit bist einzutreten. Und das ist etwas, was wir jetzt in der Internetkultur vielfach finden konnten. Also wir hatten ja auch zum Beispiel diese ganz starke atheistisch-neurobiologische Strömung, so Dawkins und Aldi. Die haben ja auch nicht einfach nur einen Atheismus angeboten, sondern die haben ja auch wiederum eine Kirche gebaut für ihren Atheismus, sodass man sich jeden Tag wieder mit neuen Dingen auseinandersetzen konnte, um Atheist zu sein oder zu werden.
Das was du sagst ist genau richtig und im Grunde ging es zum Beispiel jetzt in ganz konkret diesem Fall, ja. Wenn ein Attentäter unter 25 Jahre ist, von dem wir wissen, viele Freunde hat er nicht, aber der hat sich die Zeit genommen, irgendwelche Memes auf die Munition zu schreiben, dann weiß man, der steckt in genau solchen idiosynkratischen Rabbit-Holes drin, wo alles, wenn man nur lang genug drüber nachdenkt, noch einen Sinn ergibt. Und da im Internet immer das Puzzleteil hinzugefügt usw. Nur eigentlich sollte man als Erweckter daneben stehen und sagen, ich erkenne das Phänomen. Ich kann jetzt nicht jedes einzelne Problem nachvollziehen, was da gelöst wurde, weil das ist ja Sinn dieser idiosynkratischen Rabbit-Hole, dass das die Leute eben nicht können. Mit den Eltern so, ich habe dein Bild im Fernsehen gesehen, bist du der Attentäter? Ja, so ungefähr. So läuft das ja ab. Also nicht mal die Eltern verstehen das. Wie sollen wir das 1000 Kilometer entfernt verstehen, weil ein Journalist, der gerade eben gelernt hat, wer Charlie Kirk ist, uns das erklärt. Das ist absolut. Nur, man muss sich darüber lustig machen. Man kann es auf gar keinen Fall so ernst nehmen, wie Ijo Mangold das hier ernst nimmt. Und uns einfach, weil das jetzt Thema ist, erzähle ich ihnen jetzt, also es gibt einen Erlöser und dann gibt es einen Zerstörer. Und der Erlöser kommt nicht, weil der Zerstörer nicht da ist, weil der Zerstörer vom Katishon aufgehalten wird. Und den Katishon, also das weltliche Regime, kann man aber aus der Welt räumen, indem man sozusagen einen Weg breiter nochmal installiert als vierte Vorstellung, also Vorstellung, damit dass dann diese Kaskade endlich mal losgetreten wird. Und dieser Wegbereiter, der also den Katishon, das weltliche Regime, die Bürokratie, den Staat aus dem Weg räumt, ist Donald Trump. Und wir haben es ja eben schon angesprochen. Es kommen dann diese Zölle, ja die internationale Ordnung, wir zerstören mal die Universitäten und so weiter und so fort. Also alles, was diesen Katishon ausgemacht hat, weshalb Amerika der Hegemon der Welt wurde, wird da jetzt fundamental attackiert, um diesen Weg frei zu machen. Und das einfach nur, damit die eine Bevölkerung haben, die sie so ein bisschen steuern können. Dem sie nämlich einfach auf den organisierten Klerus zugreifen und sagen, predigt heute mal das und das, weil dann wissen wir morgen denken die so und so.
Ja.
Das hat tausend Jahre funktioniert.
Das ist das alte Motto. Halt du sie dumm, ich halte sie arm.
Genau. Ganz genau, genau, genau. Wo kommt das her?
So sagte man, das war die Aufgabe der Kirchen in Deutschland.
Ich halte sie dumm, halt du sie arm. Also das ist die Logik. Nur, anstatt sich jetzt darüber lustig zu machen, macht Ijoma Mangold jetzt auf der Bühne pointierte Ableitungen daraus. Wir hören nur mal eine, weil sie mich sofort getriggert hat.
Die apokalyptische Erzählung der Bevölkerungsexplosion ist mittlerweile ersetzt durch die apokalyptische Erzählung, dass wir sterben aus und dass diese Welt wirtschaftlich nicht durchhalten wird. Denn nur Ökonomien oder Volkswirtschaften, die auch demografisch wachsen, sind überhaupt Stichwort Rentenkassen und so weiter in der Lage, eine Gesellschaft zu erlernen.
Wir sind immer zu wenig oder zu viel.
Genau, wir sind immer zu wenig oder zu viel.
Stimmt und er löst es sogar selber ein bisschen auf, aber ohne die Schlussfolgerung daraus zu ziehen.
Das Problem mit der Apokalyptik scheint mir zu sein, dass wir immer das, was gerade Trend ist, extra polieren und egal, was gerade Trend ist, wenn man kann alles extra polieren und dann landet man in einer Extremität, die nicht mehr gesund ist. Der Witz ist nur, die Welt entwickelt sich nie entlang irgendeiner Extrapolation, sondern sie ist viel kontingenter und viel dynamischer und es passieren zwar ständig schlimme Dinge, das will ich überhaupt nicht in Abrede stellen, aber in der Regel nicht die schlimmen Dinge, vor denen wir uns gerade noch gefürchtet haben.
So, ich finde hier, ja, das ist sozusagen der Schienbeitritt gegenüber Wissenschaft und so weiter, Bildung, denn...
Bei Demografie gibt es nicht so eine hohe Kontingenz. Also es gibt natürlich das Entstehen von Verhütungsmitteln wie der Pille, die dann dafür sorgen, dass man plötzlich in ganz anderer Weise das Kinderkriegen kontrollieren kann für sich individuell. Aber sonst ist ja Demografie relativ berechenbar. Was ich aber schon zustimmen würde, ist, dass es diese Trends gibt, dass Aktuelles genommen wird und man dann extrapoliert. Und ich bin nämlich interessanterweise... Lass mich nur sagen, in meinem Gespräch in Zürich bin ich nämlich auch auf dieses Überbevölkerungsding eingegangen. Wir haben nämlich über Apokalypse und Film gesprochen und dann gab es in den 70ern, selbstredend, die Filme, die uns erzählten, die Überbevölkerung wird das große Problem sein.
Alles richtig.
Silent Green.
Das Problem ist nicht, dass das alles richtig ist, denn es ist alles richtig. Wir hatten damals Angst vor Überbevölkerung und jetzt haben wir ja Eden Marx, der Krog einprogrammiert. Das größte Problem der Welt ist Zero Planet, wie das eine Buch heißt. Das Problem hier ist, niemand, niemand, niemals macht eine Wissenschaft und sagt, in zehn Jahren geht die Welt unter, die Apokalypse ist da, weil das und das, sondern der wissenschaftliche Beitrag in der politischen Diskussion ist immer, und das kann man gerade in der Klimasache richtig nachvollziehen, wenn wir so weitermachen, dann passiert das, also sollten wir etwas anderes machen. Ja. Und das Problem ist, dann Politiker leiten nicht ganz daraus ab, was man anders machen könnte, sondern versuchen so, naja, können wir nicht noch ein bisschen weitermachen und was auch immer, ja. Aber kein Wissenschaftler sagt auch, ich verschließe die Augen vor dem einfachsten Phänomen überhaupt, nämlich, dass wir natürlich anders entscheiden können, also die Extrapolation nicht aufgeht. Ja, es hier nochmal so ernsthaft reinzubauen im Sinne von, also ich möchte jetzt heute den Wissenschaftlern nochmal sagen, ihr habt ja immer so vorausberechnet. Ja, genau. Im Ansinnen des, wir könnten, wir sollten es jetzt mal anders machen.
Es gibt ja dieses sehr gute Buch, mir fällt gerade der Titel nicht ein, das erklärt, wie die Klimawissenschaftler seit Ende der 70er Jahre im Prinzip nur richtige Voraussagen machten und die Politik auch unterrichtet hatten. Und dennoch ist es nicht dazu gekommen. Und es ging da nie darum zu sagen, die Apokalypse ist da und es ging auch nicht darum zu sagen, sie kommt bestimmt, sondern sie könnte kommen, wenn.
Das ist eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung. Und zur Demografie, dieses Club of Rome Ding und so, das erschien, als selbst in Deutschland noch die Geburtenrate über zwei war. Und die ganze Welt wirklich explodierte. Also wenn man von 1945 bis 71 die Zahlen weiter nimmt, kann man durchaus mal durchrechnen, da sind wir jetzt locker hier, keine Ahnung, wo wir sind. Also mindestens noch mal das Doppelte drauf. Nur weil die ganze westliche Welt und inzwischen die Hälfte der Welt eben unter diesem Niveau liegt, nur das hat man 71 nicht sehen können. Aber deswegen kann man doch nicht sagen, warum haben die so eine apokalyptische Warnung ausgesprochen? Na ja, weil es das Zahlenmaterial war. Also man könnte dann auch nicht sagen, die Atombombe explodiert mit deren Geschwindigkeit, aber noch ist die Druckwelle ja nicht da. Also müssen wir noch nicht Bescheid sagen. Das Experiment macht ja Trump gerade. Also das Wetter kommt, aber wir beobachten es einfach nicht mehr. Also das macht ja gar keinen Sinn. Jetzt zum Finale aus diesem ersten Teil.
Ich glaube, die Clap-o-Form-Leute, um das auch noch zu sagen, hätten schon extrapolieren können, dass also mit zum Beispiel steigendem Wohlstand das Kinderreichtum abnimmt.
Das Phänomen hat man damals noch nicht gesehen, weil es es damals noch nicht gab. Das Phänomen gab es vor den 70ern noch nicht. Wir haben in den 70ern eine ganz große Zäsur. Wir haben zum einen eine Containerschifffahrt, also das nicht mehr so einzeln gedenkt, sondern dass wir plötzlich eine Verhundertfachung, Verteusenfachung von Weltmarkt haben, wodurch so ein ökonomischer Aufschwung kam. Und es gibt kein Land auf der Welt, das vor den 70ern, also du hast einzelne Beispiele im Sinne von die aristokratische Familie, die sich mal...
Diesen Knick gab es ja schon.
Nein, die Pille kam 71, 72. Das war dann der Pillenknick. Okay. In den 60ern, 68 kam die Containerschifffahrt 70, 71, 72, die Pille. Und selbst die musste sich erst mal durchsetzen. Also zu dem Zeitpunkt dieser Club of Rome Sache war es völlig legitim zu sagen, also wenn wir die letzten 20 Jahre nehmen und das weiterziehen, dann ist hier Apokalypse angesagt. Dass es dann rapide schnell anders ging, aber das wurde ja auch immer eingepreist in die Diskussion. Es hat ja keiner 1980 die Augen verschlossen und gesagt, nee, also für mich geht es weiterhin 1950 bis 1970. Wie er das jetzt unterstellte. Gut, wir hören jetzt zwei Clips aus diesem Podcast noch, in denen auch Lars Weißbrot ein bisschen zu hören ist, denn warum das Ganze? Also zum einen, warum das Ganze als politisches Programm religiös angeheitet ist in Amerika, das haben wir geklärt. Aber warum diesen Diskurs, warum die Apokalypse, was fasziniert uns so am Weltuntergang? Warum betonen wir alle gerade, dass es voll scheiße um die Welt steht und wir auch eine echt schlechte Stimmung haben und so? Weil wir gerne Schuld zurechnen wollen, weil wir gerne schadenfrohe sein wollen, weil wir gerne jemanden sagen wollen und so weiter. Wir hören das hier mal aus den Worten mündern der beiden.
Es gibt auch eine gewisse Lust da dran, ein lustvolles Erwarten der Apokalypse. Es ist nicht so klar negativ, dass Apokalypse ein Bild wie man es im ersten Moment erwarten würde.
So und Mangold beschreibt es noch mal ganz gut.
Wir hoffen natürlich alle auf dieses Strafgericht und wenn dafür die Welt untergeht, aber dann werden die, die es immer zu wild getrieben haben, die werden dann den Preis zahlen und dann wird der ewige Richter, der dann zwischen Himmel und Hölle entscheidet, ja eben diese harten Urteile sprechen. Die Apokalypse ist immer eine Quittung für Fehlverhalten und wir sind alle Rechthaber, deswegen verbinden wir mit der Apokalypse dieses befriedigend Gefühl. Seht ihr, dazu haben wir es nun gebracht.
So, also ganz ohne Erlösung. So eine Weltuntergangsstimmung finden wir auf jeden Fall attraktiv. Sei es nur, da haben wir was zu reden, aber vor allem haben wir Schuld zuzuweisen. Wir können noch mal sagen, schade, dass wir jetzt alle sterben müssen, aber ich hatte immer recht. Ja, so ungefähr. Und jetzt hören wir mal, wollen wir vor allem auf den Ton freilachten, Steven Miller. Steven Miller ist jetzt wirklich eine besondere Rolle, weil er ist alles in einem. Er ist im Grunde so eine Art Charlie Kirk, der die ganze Zeit diese Debatten-Dinger gemacht hat. Er ist so ein religiöser Anpeitscher. Er ist aber auch Vizestabschef im Weißen Haus und im Wahlkampf ideologischer Vorkämpfer gewesen. Er ist im Grunde alles. Und ich finde, was man vor allem heraus hören kann, ist bei ihm diese Lust daran, Leuten zu sagen, die Welt geht unter und ihr seid schuld. Und dann geht er lieber mit unter, als sich diese Lust nehmen zu lassen.
Erika steht auf den Schultern von Tausenden von Jahren, von Kriegern, von Frauen, die Familien aufgerufen haben, die Stadt aufgerufen haben, die Industrie aufgerufen haben, die Zivilisation aufgerufen haben, die uns aus den Wärmen und der Dunkelheit in die Licht gebracht haben. Die Licht wird den Dunkelheit verweilen. Du bist Wichser, du bist Verrückung, du bist Verrückung, du bist Hater, du bist nichts, du kannst nichts bauen, du kannst nichts produzieren, du kannst nichts kreieren. Wir sind diejenigen, die bauen, wir sind diejenigen, die kreieren, wir sind diejenigen, die die Menschheit aufüben. Du dachtest, du könntest Charlie Kirk töten? Du hast Charlie Kirk ermordet.
Also das ist einfach Fundamentalismus. In diesem Zerstörungslustsapokalypse irgendwas und da ist ihm auch völlig egal, bedient er sich halt in diesen religiösen Sachen und geht da auf so eine Veranstaltung. Einfach nur um darum zu schreien. Warum waren die Leute da?
Wenn du in ein oder zwei Worten sagen könntest, wie du dich jetzt fühlst, was würdest du sagen?
Herzgebrochen, schockiert.
Ja, bewegt durch die Bewegung.
Ja, man pickt sich auch immer jemanden raus, den man betrauern kann. Also das war auch interessant, das wurde ja dann zum Teil in Talkshows auch abgefragt, ob man Mitleid hat und so. Man wird nie abgefragt, haben sie Mitleid, damit das die Flüchtlinge Mittelmeer trinken? Haben sie Mitleid, damit dass die Leute hier nichts zu essen haben? Haben sie Mitleid? Also das ist nie die Frage, sondern man pickt sich so einzelne Akteure raus und dann muss da jetzt jeder seine Menschlichkeit dran nochmal zu Schau stellen und sagen, ja hier bin ich aber wirklich gerührt.
Ja, will man, ich will mal eine kleine Pointe machen, politisch. Donald Trump hat ja auf dieser Rede dann auch gesprochen, wir hören es hier reformuliert, ich weiß gar nicht. Von den 25, ne Moment hier, Daily.
Die Präsidentin hat gesagt, er sei wahrscheinlich richtig, aber ich konnte mich nicht helfen. Und so, als Trump sich mit Charlie Kirk an sich vergleichte, war er in dieser interessanten Art Charlie als diplomatisch-politischer Typ, und als er sich als Ausländer und Wahrheitler verbreitet.
Er hat seine Gegner nicht vergesst, er wollte die Beste für sie.
Das ist, warum ich mit Charlie nicht verabschiedet habe.
Ich hasse meinen Gegner. Und ich will nicht die Beste für sie.
Ich bin sorry, Erica.
Er hat die Erfüllung eröffnet, für alle in der Publikation eigentlich zu verbreiten, die Worte für sie zu wollen, sie wirklich zu schmieren. Und dann hat Trump es ein Stück weiter gemacht und er hat gesagt, dass er Charlie Kirk erwähnt hat, dass er an diese Campus-Events gehen würde.
Es gab Bombefälle, gebliebene Feuerärzte, und viele wütende Radikale, die versucht haben, ihn zu schreien.
Es war wütend.
Ich habe immer gesagt, Charlie, das ist wütend, was du tust.
Er dachte, es wäre toll auf der einen Seite, aber er hat auch gesagt, Charlie, das ist wütend, was du tust. Und also, er hat sicher nicht Kirk für seine Selbstmordung blämt. Aber er sagte, ich habe dir gesagt, dass so etwas passieren würde.
Diese sind diejenigen, die wir mit tun.
Und die Gewalt kommt meistens von der Linken.
Du hörst das nicht von zu vielen Leuten, oder?
In der Ende, diese Leute können nicht mit gedeiht werden. Du musst sie einfach ein bisschen steinlösen.
Das ist ja die Unterscheidung zwischen Realpolitik, in der er sich befindet. Er muss also den Gegner hassen, den Gegner bekämpfen, das ist seine Politik, die er betreibt. Während jetzt die Frau von Charlie Kirk, die sogar noch dem Attentäter vergibt, ja schon jenseitig ausgerichtet ist und sagt, aber dort wird ja Gott am Ende sowieso entscheiden. Also ich bin gar nicht mehr der, der Richter sein wird, sondern das wird vor dem jüngsten Gericht entschieden. Während Trump ja absolut diesseitig ist. Er kann nur im Hier und Jetzt und kommt sich auch offenbar unsterblich vor. Also das ist ja auch das Interessante, dass er ja immer so Dimensionen aufmacht, wo man weiß, da kann er eigentlich, auch wenn er sehr alt wird, nicht mehr dabei sein. Aber er hat so einen Ewigkeitsanspruch in seiner Diesseitigkeit, während das natürlich hier in dieser religiösen Dimension da nicht mehr vorhanden sein kann.
Genau, sehr gut, dass du das so sagst, denn wir müssen uns jetzt entscheiden. Also ich rufe jetzt jeden Hörer auf, sich hier mal wirklich für sich, man muss es niemandem sagen, aber sich zu entscheiden. Geht man jetzt diesen Erika-Kirk-Weg mit? Also wir vergeben uns alle gegenseitig, diskutieren das so aus und dann kommt einfach der nächste, der ja so Prove-Me-Wrong-Debatten macht, oder dann verschlingen wir uns so ewigen Diskussionen, während aber gleichzeitig irgendwelche Leute uns ökonomisch allem brauben. Oder machen wir es wie Trump und sagen einfach, nee, meinen politischen Gegner hasse ich eigentlich und ich will gar nicht mit dem reden, sondern ich will einfach, dass der weg ist. Und sei es, dass jemand den erschießt oder was auch immer.
Es gibt jetzt zum Beispiel in der evangelischen Kirche so zwei Positionen, also es ist jetzt sehr runtergebrochen, aber es gibt ja diese zwei reiche Theorie, also dass man sagt, es gibt das Reich Gottes und das weltliche, irdische Reich und dort findet die Politik statt. Und das soll aber bitte voneinander getrennt sein. Weshalb man also sich dann kirchlich nicht so einmischt in politische Belange, weil man sagt, wir sind für das Reich Gottes zuständig.
Aber da müsste man schon dran glauben, dass das so ist.
Ob die jetzt gerade Flüchtlinge abschieben, ja, aber das ist jetzt nicht so unser Hauptthema. Und dann gibt es genau die anderen, die sagen, nein, nein, also das gehört zusammen. Also müssen wir auch hier politisch eingreifen als Kirche. Und das ist aber dann nicht nur bezogen auf jetzt zum Beispiel Thema Migration, sondern wir sehen ja auch, dass die evangelische Kirche im Prinzip am allerstärksten eigentlich die NATO-Ziele verwirklicht sehen will.
Naja, also ich meine, genau diese Dichotomie. Ich möchte jetzt Folgendes vorschlagen. Lassen wir doch mal die Kirche Kirche sein und sagen, nein, wir sind jetzt ehrlich zu uns, wir hassen unseren politischen Gegner. Wir wollen nicht, dass Christian Dürr nächster Finanzminister wird, nachdem Christian Lindner schon in der Rolle gescheitert ist. Ich will die FDP gar nicht im Bundestag haben. Ich finde es gut, dass das so ist. Ich will nicht, dass da, ach, repräsentativ, keine Ahnung. Von mir müssen diese drei Prozent, die Zahnarztin, da nicht vertreten werden. Aber das machen wir ja nicht. Wir kommen ja immer mit diesen Butterweichen, ach nee, komm, eine Sonntagsdiskussionsforum, ein Panel noch und so, ja. Die Grünen dann, ach komm, wir machen mal so einen ostdeutschen Forum und dann fahren wir da mal hin und ich mach ein Wahlkreisbüro in Braunschweig. Ich hab zwar nichts damit zu tun. Und brauch mir noch eine Pizza connection. Genau, das muss man jetzt mal entscheiden. Und es gibt ein Denkangebot dazu.
Ich will nur eine Sache sagen. Es gibt ja einen Unterschied und der wurde ja schon gemacht. Trump hat ja Freund und Feind denken in das, also Freund und Feind denken bestimmt die Außenpolitik sowieso. Und das ist nicht nur, weil Karl Schmidt das aufgeschrieben hat, sondern das ist so. Wir haben das schon häufiger beschrieben. Die Sache ist aber in einer Demokratie, ist wie wird dort Gegnerschaft ausgehandelt. Und das macht man zum Beispiel im Parlament, macht man mit zwei Parteien oder mit mehreren Parteien. Und da gibt es natürlich diejenigen, die sagen, wir müssen da deliberativ uns mal über Argumente einig werden. Und dann werden wir da alle gemeinsam einem Boot sitzen. Und dagegen gibt es den Ansatz der Agonalität, wo man also schon von Gegnerschaft ausgeht.
Und da Wolfgang, du erklärst es gerade zum dritten Mal, aber du musst dich jetzt bekennen. Möchtest du es lieber so agonal haben?
Ja, ich will es ganz kurz sagen. Ich bin für die agonale Seite. Ich bin für die agonale Seite und die sagt, man sollte versuchen, wir haben es mal bei Adam Tos gespielt, Bulldozern, wenn man an der Reihe ist, dafür zu sorgen, dass dann nicht nächstes Jahr wieder die FDP ins Parlament kommt, um zu sagen, ach, ich finde es aber schön, wenn auch eine liberale Partei. Nein, man sagt dann, ich bin so selbstbewusst und sage, Platz da. Wir müssen sehen, dass wir am besten wie die CSU in Bayern eine absolute Mehrheit immer bekommen. Und dann können wir das durchsetzen. Und doof, wenn man das irgendwann nicht mehr hat in Bayern, dann muss man nämlich mit so anderen zusammen wie mit Aiwanger. So. Und das ist aber nicht eine Haltung, die sagt, ich töte meinen Gegner oder irgendwas, sondern es ist eine antagonistische Politikauffassung, die ich für sehr richtig empfinde. Denn sonst kommt man genau das, was du da gerade geschrieben hast. Wir brauchen mal wieder einen runden Tisch. Wen setzen wir dann da alles dran? Dann sind wir schon wieder alle in einem Boot. Nein, da, ich hebe das hier positiv hervor, muss man genau mit Nils Kumka über eine richtige Polarisierung nachdenken.
Genau. Wir sitzen nämlich nicht in einem Boot, auch wenn irgendwelche Leute das immer erzählen wollen. Wir machen einen ganz einklipp Exkurs. Deutsche Politik. Frank Staus hat einen sehr guten Podcast mit Hajo Schumacher, der ihm ab und zu so ein paar Fragen zuwirft. Frank Staus ist Wahlkämpfer für die SPD, hat unendlich viele Wahlkämpfe gemacht. Und zieht jetzt mal Schlüsse daraus, dass es Umfragen gibt unter AfD-Lern, wie ihr die jetzt so sehen. Sind die Protestwähler, wollen sie eigentlich nur mal an den Debatten Tisch geholt werden oder sind das doch alles hardcore Überzeugte, die einfach sagen, sobald ich regiere, fliegen hier die Linken raus und die Ausländer sowieso. Also die sozusagen nicht, sowohl sie sich jetzt nicht in Debatten reinzwängen lassen, und es recht nicht danach von sich aus eine Debatte beginnen. Und ich fand es erstaunlich und erfrischend und gut, es einfach mal deutlich in einem deutschen Politikpodcast, von dem ich unterstelle, dass so ein paar Leute hören, weil sie sich dafür interessieren, was Frank Stauß sagt, so wie ich, dass sie sowas mal vorgesetzt kriegen.
Von den 25, 26 Prozent AfD-Wählerinnen und Wähler haben wir rund um 20 Prozent, die sind hardcore. Die kriegst du auch nicht mehr. Die kriegst du weder als SPD schon gar nicht. Die kriegst du aber auch nicht, das hatten wir bei Lessemann drüber schon. Die kriegst du auch als Söder nicht mehr. Die kriegst du auch natürlich als März jetzt nicht mehr. Du musst einfach damit arbeiten, dass du 20 Prozent Faschos in der Republik hast, die du auch so behandeln musst. Das heißt, du musst sie auch ernst nehmen. Und das ist ja gerade das Lustige. Sie sagen immer, man muss die AfD-Wähler ernst nehmen, aber sie nehmen sie ja gar nicht ernst. Sie sagen immer noch, das sind irgendwelche verführten Schäfchen. Wenn du einen AfD-Wähler ernst nehmen willst, dann musst du ihn als Nazi ernst nehmen. Das ist ja auch eine Beleidigung ihm gegenüber, wenn du den nicht ernst nimmst. Und wenn du das mal für dich anerkannt hast, dass das Leute sind, die letztendlich diese Republik ablehnen, die diese Demokratie ablehnen und diesen Staat ablehnen, dann kann man auch offener darüber argumentieren. Und dann muss man auch natürlich ganz anders wieder über all das sprechen, über das wir ja schon häufiger gesprochen haben, nämlich auch ein AfD-Verbot. Weil wenn die Leute überzeugt sind, dann sind sie halt überzeugt.
Ich weiß noch, wie viel Ärger ich gekriegt habe, als ich 2017 nach der Bundesrepublik im Aufwarn-Podcast sagte, alle AfD-Willer sind Nazis. Ich habe das natürlich argumentiert mit diesem soziologischen Zuschnitt. Wer Nazis wählt, ist Nazi, weil Unwissendheit schützt halt nicht. Wenn du jemanden wählst, der den Staat abschaffen will, dann wird der Staat halt abgeschafft, unabhängig davon, ob du dann später sagst, ich revidiere, ich bereue oder was auch immer.
So habe ich es nicht gemeint.
Genau, so habe ich es nicht gemeint. Ich wusste nicht, dass wir hier 800 Leute pro Boot im Mittelmeer trinken lassen. So, man muss jetzt also einfach mal durchziehen.
Ja, also ich glaube ja, was hier noch mitschwingen sollte, ist, dass man dadurch ja die Leute, die das jetzt wählen, nicht grundsätzlich verloren gibt. Ja, okay, schön und gut. Sie können bei einer kommenden Wahl dann anders entscheiden.
Das ist das Wesen der Demokratie, das geht für alles.
Aber ich glaube, was aber nicht geht und was jetzt ja sehr viel gemacht wird, ist, dass man sagt, ja, wir holen die AfD-Wähler ins Boot, indem wir uns ihnen annähern, um zu glauben, dass sie dann ihre AfD-haftigkeit verlieren oder indem sie dann sagen, dann brauche ich ja die AfD nicht mehr wählen, weil ich ja dann andere wählen kann. Das glaube ich, ist der falsche Weg, wenngleich ich skeptisch bin, ob das mit einem AfD-Verbot überhaupt jetzt noch funktionieren würde.
Ja, ich will mal sagen, während wir eben noch über jeder muss Bekenntnisse ablegen und so weiter. Die Wahl in Deutschland ist geheim. Wir wissen nicht, wer die AfD wählt. Ja. Und das ist die Herausforderung, jetzt zu verdeutlichen, was es bedeutet, AfD zu wählen. Was zum Beispiel auch bedeuten kann, während wir festgestellt haben, ach so, Alexandra Dobrindt ist quasi so ein Stephen Miller, der macht schon AfD-Politik, bevor er mit ihr koaliert, was ja faktisch, finde ich, stattfindet im Innenministerium. Dann könnte man auch einfach jetzt schon mal konkret AfD-Politik machen, wie sie im AfD-Parteiprogramm steht, damit einfach mal gemerkt wird, was das so bedeutet. Also nicht nur bei den Sachen, über die man eh selber überzeugt ist, sondern auch, um mal das Signal zu setzen.
Also du solltest jetzt Dobrindt sagen, ich habe mich im Wahlprogramm der AfD inspirieren lassen, wir setzen das jetzt um.
Dobrindt macht ja AfD-Politik.
Ja, aber wie willst du quasi das deutlich machen, dass das jetzt passiert auch?
Also wie du kannst das uns deutlich machen. Wir machen Familienpolitik, wie die AfD das mal will, für ein halbes Jahr. Und dann gucken wir mal, wie den Leuten das gefällt. Schule hört 12 Uhr auf, es gibt keine Nachmittagsbetreuung mehr. Und die Oma, die oben die Großmutter pflegt, kommt halt auch nicht mehr aus Polen angereist im Sommer, damit man mal Urlaub machen kann. Und dann mal gucken, wie die Deutschen das so finden, wenn AfD-Politik ist. Also es wird halt sehr selektiv AfD-Politik gemacht, aber nicht da, wo sie mal sein müsste, damit man auch was merkt. So, du hast mich beim Live-Salon provoziert mit einer Frage.
Was habe ich dann gesagt?
Du hast mich gefragt, warum sagt Esra Klein, Charlie Kirk hat Politik richtig gemacht?
Ja, ich habe hier ein paar Auszüge dabei, soll ich das vielleicht mal ganz kurz sagen, damit die Leute wissen, worüber wir hier reden?
Dann lass uns doch erst die Entschuldigung von Esra Klein, je nachdem, wie weiter sie inhaltlich treibt.
Vielleicht sollten wir aber erst ein paar Sätze, was er gesagt hat, weil das war ja steines Anstoß. Also Esra Klein, der berühmte New York Times-Kolumnist und Podcaster.
Genau, ich habe jetzt eine Poente vorbereitet. Also ich habe gerade dafür optiert, dass Leute nicht miteinander reden. Während Wolfgang das jetzt vorliest, möchte ich, dass alle Hörer wissen, ich will das nicht, was hier als Charlie Kirk hat es richtig gemacht und so. Ich will das nicht. Das ist für mich der totale Horror, dass wir jetzt demnächst in jedem Campus überall solche Scheißdiskussionen und so weiter haben.
Ja, dass wir noch mal darüber diskutieren, Ehebrecherinnen, sollen wir sie steinigen oder nicht? Ja, prove me wrong.
Ja.
Esra Klein schreibt, man kann vieles, woran Kirk glaubte, ablehnen, aber die folgende Aussage ist dennoch wahr, Kirk betrieb Politik auf genau die richtige Art und Weise. Er besuchte Universitäten und sprach mit jedem, der mit ihm sprechen wollte. Er war einer der effektivsten Überzeugungskünstler seiner Zeit. Als Die Linke glaubte, die Herz und Köpfe der College-Studenten fast vollständig unter ihrer Kontrolle zu haben, tauchte Kirk immer wieder auf, um dies zu durchbrechen. Langsam, dann auf einmal, gelang ihm das auch. Die Wähler im College-Alter schwenkten bei den Wahlen 2024 scharf nach rechts. Das war nicht allein Kirks Verdienst, aber er war maßgeblich daran beteiligt, schreibt er dann weiter. Die Bereitschaft zum Widerspruch ist in einer Demokratie eine Tugend. Er sagte, ich kannte Kirk nicht und bin nicht die richtige Person, um ihm ein Loblied zu singen, aber ich beneide ihm um das, was er aufgebaut hat. Der Liberalismus könnte mehr von seiner Courage und Furchtlosigkeit gebrauchen. Also hier ist wirklich die Idee, wenn wir uns jetzt laufend irrsinnigen Debatten stellen, dann ist damit der Demokratie und dem Liberalismus geholfen. Und das als einfach furchtlos darzustellen, dass jemand dorthin geht und unmögliche Positionen vertritt. Also mit unmöglich meine ich Positionen, bei denen man sagen kann, ja, das denken wir jetzt seit 1500 Jahren nicht mehr, da fangen wir jetzt auch nicht wieder mit an. Das ist einfach, also ich kann natürlich auch sagen, Holocaust-Leugner sind furchtlos. Ja, aber fangen wir jetzt, wollen wir jetzt auch noch mal ausdiskutieren oder was? Also wenn man das mitgeht, was Klein hier sagt, dann kommt man wirklich nur bei Irrsinn raus. Und dann heißt es noch, die amerikanische Politik hat verschiedene Seiten. Wir haben jetzt gerade gesagt, agonale Struktur. Es hat keinen Sinn so zu tun, als wäre das nicht der Fall. Sagen wir auch, also eigentlich Polarisierung. Dann sagt er, aber beide Seiten sollten eigentlich auf derselben Seite eines größeren Projekts stehen. Wir alle oder zumindest die meisten von uns versuchen, die Lebensfähigkeit des amerikanischen Experiments aufrechtzuhalten. Also Amerika als Idee, Nationen und so weiter. Und dann würde ich sagen, nein, nein, nein. Es ist nicht dieselbe Seite, auf der Donald Trump und Mamdami stehen. Die versuchen nicht beide, das gemeinsame Projekt aufrechtzuhalten.
Deshalb man bei dem einen die Flöte spielen darf, wenn man einen kleiden würde, bei dem anderen nicht.
Das gemeinsame Projekt existiert nicht.
Genau.
Und das müsste, also ich hab dann einfach nochmal so, um das zu unterstreichen, nochmal Zahlen rausgesucht, die hatte damals Adam Toos analysiert. Zum Thema gemeinsames Projekt, ein Boot, in dem wir alle dann doch sitzen. Also am Ende geht es ja um Amerika oder so. Im Jahr 2021 hat Kuba eine höhere Lebenserwartung gehabt als die USA. Im Jahr 2020 sank die Lebenserwartung von Hispano-Amerikanern um fast vier Jahre. Im Jahr 2021 lag die Lebenserwartung schwarzer amerikanischer Männer bei 66,7 Jahren. Adam Toos schlussfolgert, eine Lebenserwartung von 66,7 Jahren bedeutet, dass schwarze Männer in den Vereinigten Staaten bei der Geburt die gleiche Lebenserwartung haben wie Männer in Pakistan, einem Land, das auf der Weltrangliste auf Platz 150 von 193 steht. Im Jahr 2021 hatte ein Junge, der in einem afrikanischen Erfolgsland wie Rwanda geboren wird, eine höhere Lebenserwartung als ein schwarzer Junge, der in den Vereinigten Staaten geboren wird. Männer in Indien, Laos und Nordkorea haben eine höhere Lebenserwartung als schwarze Männer in Amerika. Da ist kein gemeinsames Projekt, da ist nicht eine tolle Idee. Und da ist nicht das Thema, dass man sagt, wir sind uns da in einigen Fragen uneins, aber sonst sind wir uns einig. Nein, diese Einigkeit ist eine Illusion. Man sagt jetzt mit Esra Klein und Kirk, wir sind beide Nationalisten und Patrioten, und egal was ist, God bless America. Das ist leider ja oft bei diesen Liberalen dann die Auffassung. Also ich garantiere dir und ich hoffe, dass ich überhaupt nie die Chance habe, das zu beweisen. Wenn jetzt Trump in Venezuela einmarschiert, dann werden auch diese Stimmen um Esra Klein sagen, God bless our troops, nun aber voran.
Ich bemerke Esra Klein sehr und es sind immer kluge Gedanken, aber in dem Fall ist er glaube ich von der Angst getrieben, weil er auch einfach nicht erschossen werden will.
Ich glaube, dass das wirklich seine Denkweise ist, dass er sagt, wir haben eigentlich unser gemeinsames Projekt. Ich glaube, er denkt schon über Amerika als ein Boot nach.
Wir hören mal nicht seine Erklärungen, das macht uns nur noch wilder. Scott Galloway, wir hören es in 21 Sekunden.
Spiel es noch mal, ich bin mich noch ein bisschen aufregen.
In the hours after Kirk's murder, trying to process my own shock, my own fear, I wrote a piece about him. In that piece I said, you can disagree with virtually everything Kirk believed about politics. You can detest some of what he believed about politics and still believe that he was there on that stage practicing politics the right way, showing up to college campuses and trying to persuade people who disagreed with him. I said that I had often wished my own side exhibited more of that spirit, that we went more often to the places where we knew people would disagree with us and talk to them. Treated that disagreement as the beginning of a conversation rather than the end of one. I've published a lot of pieces over the years. I'm not sure I've published any where this polarizing reaction is that one.
Nein, das ist ja nicht alles, was er in diesem Artikel sagt. Also ich bin ja auch dafür, dass man mit Leuten in den Diskussionen eintreten kann und man kann sich fragen, wo ist es sinnvoll, wo ist es nicht sinnvoll. Ich habe auch schon dann festgestellt, wenn Leute eine Stunde lang am Ende doch nur über Messerstecher reden wollen, dann führt das nicht weiter, weil man dann einfach kein anderes Argument mehr machen kann als darüber zu reden. Darum ging es aber hier nicht, sondern er versucht wirklich so zu tun, als hätte man doch eigentlich auf einer Seite gestanden, nämlich im Sinne eines größeren amerikanischen Projekts. Und das ist fundamental falsch.
Ja.
Und das andere ist eine Frage von Strategie. Soll ich jetzt noch mal mit einem AfD-Wildern mich streiten oder nicht? Ja gut, das kann man dann so oder so für sich entscheiden.
Ich bleibe dabei. Dieser Text hat einfach eine ganz andere persönliche Funktion und die hat er erfüllt. So, Scott Galloway. Ich finde, 21 Sekunden reichen für alles.
I'm Scott Galloway and this is No Mercy, No Malice. The perpetrators of the horrific violence we've seen are not partisan political actors. They're isolated, angry and dangerous men, products of America's rage machine. Violence Entrepreneurs, as read by George Hahn.
Kennen wir ja so weit Steffen Mao, die, äh, wie hat er den Namen?
Polarisierungsunternehmer.
Genau, Polarisierungsunternehmer. Jetzt kommt ein sehr wichtiger Clip. Casey Newton, wir haben ihn schon häufiger hier gespielt und ich fand ihn immer gut, erklärt uns jetzt und hoffentlich hören uns ein paar Journalisten zu und so. Warum ist diese Polarisierung, also was hat es mit dieser Polarisierung auf sich? Scott Galloway hat in diesem Essay schon sehr gut herausgearbeitet. Ja, das sind einfach die größten Unternehmen der Welt, die nur noch eins im Sinne haben, uns aufzuregen, weil sie das eine Ding gefunden haben, dass sie noch besser online verkaufen können als Porn. Und das ist Konflikt. Und Casey Newton beschreibt hier mal auch so ein bisschen diese Extremely Online. Wir waren ja alle selbst dabei. Wir haben eigene Erfahrungen mit dem Internet. Wir müssen jetzt nicht nur die Milliardäre reden, auch wenn wir wissen, dass das unsere Strippenzieher sind, die diese Funktionsweise dieser Konflikt unternehmen. Im Hardfork Podcast natürlich.
Turning Point USA, die Organisation, die er begonnen hat, war eine große Fortschritte in den ersten, 2010s, Online-Aktivismus.
Und er hat viel virale Content gemacht, um ein besseres Wort zu nennen. Und das ist, wie er berühmt wurde, wie er sich wurde, wie er war.
Es war durch Videos und online Posten. Ja, und ich denke, er hat sich auf die Plattform-Nerds, die ich überreden würde, auf die Bordereinbarung ausgesprochen. Also zum Beispiel, er spekulierte, dass die Vakzine mehr als 1 Mio. Menschen töten, ohne das zu bewegen. Er sagte, es sei ein Fehler, den Zivilrechtsakt zu übernehmen. Er würde die jüdischen Donoren für die Fundierung der radikalen, offenen Bordereinbarung neoliberaler Quasi-Marxisten-Polizisten kritisieren und dann erheben, dass er antisemitisch war. Und vielleicht war er es nicht, aber wieder und wieder sieht man ihn flirten mit dieser Linie. Und das ist wichtig, weil Plattformen es lieben, wenn man mit der Linie flirrt. Es wird herausgekommen, dass das am kompellierendsten, was man auf der sozialen Medien tun kann, fast eine Politik verbreiten kann. Das ist einer der key Methoden, die Charlie Kirk nutzte, um Notarie, Prominenz und dann letztendlich Macht und Geld zu gewinnen. Und er hat es durch diese bestimmte Technik gemacht. Und das Ding an dieser Technik ist, wie effektiv es für Charlie Kirk war, ich denke, es ist wirklich korrosiv auf unserer Politik. Weil, je mehr es erzielt, desto mehr, wenn du TikTok oder Instagram Reels öffnest, siehst du etwas, das dich besitzen soll. Es soll dich unangenehm machen, dich zwingen.
Wenn man das auf die Spitze treibt, angenommen, es würde jetzt John Bolton erschossen, weil Donald Trump ihm die Sicherheitsdinger nicht mehr gibt. Charlie Kirk würde nicht erschossen. Charlie Kirk würde auf die Bühne gehen und sagen, John Bolton wurde zurecht erschossen. Prove me wrong. Ich will ja nur diskutieren. Also in dieser Logik müsste doch jetzt alles erlaubt sein zum Thema Charlie Kirk, während aber die Trump-Regierung da voll die Schotten dicht macht und sagt, es sind alles unsere Gegner, ihr seid autorisiert zum Terrorismus gegen sie.
Ja oder sieh dir an, wie hier in Deutschland die Springer-Presse verfahren ist, die auch das alles übertragen hat und ihn auch fast zum Heiligen verklärt hat, wenngleich wir wissen, wie sehr Charlie Kirk zum Beispiel mit antisemitischen Mustern gespielt hat. Immer so, dass man es nicht ganz greifen konnte, aber so, ja, da sind so Gelder aus Organisationen und hier, die zwei stecken dahinter und das sind dann Juden und das ist mit Wall Street und dann wird das immer so beschrieben, dass es nicht so ganz zu greifen ist, aber wie das gerade beschrieben wurde, es ist genau dieser Content, der so auf dieser Grenze die ganze Zeit sich bewegt, ist noch nicht völlig ausspricht, aber in den Kommentaren geht es ja dann entsprechend explizit weiter, was nur implizit angedeutet wurde. Und da wird normalerweise ja Springer wahnsinnig hellhörig, nur wenn es für die richtige Sache ist, ist auch das offenbar okay und wird nicht größer thematisiert.
Genau, das zum einen ist die inhaltliche Logik, dann gibt es eine interessante Methode, die da angewendet wird. Charlie Kirk musste ja nicht selber verbreiten, sondern er war sicher, 3000 junge Leute werden die wohl ihres Smartphones mitbringen und mich filmen. Die Antwort ist ja. Er hat diesen Content einfach nur hergestellt, produziert haben ihn andere. Also wenn man Charlie Kirk bei YouTube sucht, jedes Suchergebnis ist ein anderer Account, der das verbreitet hat. Kennt man so ein bisschen, in Deutschland gibt es das auch, der berühmte, ich habe einen neuen Podcast. Ja, was ist denn das für ein Podcast? Jede Woche rede ich mit den interessantesten Menschen und so weiter. Weil da kann man sich ziemlich sicher sein, jeder Gast verbreitet diesen Podcast, in dem er zu Gast war, an alle seine Leute. Und nach einem Jahr ist man in 50 Bubbles rausgeschwört. Und der Podcast ist plötzlich so beliebt. Ja, also ganz erstaunlich und solche Dinge. Wir hören einen Clip noch, bevor wir auf die All-In-Leute zu sprechen kommen. Doppelgänger. Ich habe auch mal Doppelgänger Podcast gehört. Dort wird es ganz gut zusammengefasst, was die nächsten Jahre jetzt prägen wird. Wir haben zum einen inhaltlich diesen ganzen religiösen Kram, auf den wir uns schon freuen können, methodisch.
Aber ich glaube, du hast Pip Klöckner bei Haken dran gehört oder hast du den Doppelgänger Podcast direkt gehört?
In dem Falle, lass mich gucken. Ah ja, stimmt. Er war bei Haken dran zu Gast, so wie hier im Clip steht.
Was ich erwähnenswert finde, ist, dass mit Larry Ellison, der hier einen entscheidenden Anteil bekommen wird, quasi ist dann...
Es geht um diesen großen TikTok-Deal, der gar nicht so groß ist, weil, oh Wunder, ist es doch nur 14 Milliarden wert oder so. Also, hier gelten einfach keine ökonomischen Gesetze mehr.
So ist das die drei größten Social-Media-Netzwerke in der Hand der drei größten Milliardäre der Welt. Das Asile Musk hat sich Twitter-Exil-Kauf, wie wir wissen. Mark Zuckerberg hat die Macht über das gesamte Metareich mit all seinen Apps und erreicht über drei Milliarden Nutzer damit. Und die drittgrößte Plattform, wenn man jetzt so möchte, wobei TikTok wahrscheinlich größer ist als X, oder die dritte relevante Plattform, kann man vielleicht sagen, würde damit unter die Kontrolle des drittreichsten Mann der Welt rutschen. Und a, sind das alles Trump-Vertraute, und b, sind aber die drei reichsten Menschen. Also die gesamte Social-Media-Welt oder die relevante Social-Media-Welt des Westens wird jetzt in der Hand von rechten Milliardären oder konservativen Milliardären konsolidiert. Und ich glaube, das ist schon erwähnenswert.
Also es gibt offenbar keine linke Hegemonie.
Nee, wo ist die linke Hegemonie? Das ist ja Fox News immer mit der Reichweite, stärkste Nachrichten und Überhauptsender der Welt. Also was die Linken da schon wieder in ihren Unterkünften gehören, die gehört ja alles und niemand guckt sie in den Enden. Okay, wir nehmen uns noch kurz Zeit, um den All-In-Podcast zu hören. Ja. Hast du den schon mal gehört?
Nein.
Solltest du vielleicht, denn da sitzen nur Leute, die für uns von Interesse sind. David Friedberg, Sharmad Palia Patitya, David Sex, Jason Kelesenics. Der Ärmste von denen ist Jason Kelesenics, denn der besitzt nur ungefähr 100 Millionen. Alle anderen sind Milliardäre. Und David Sex ist Trumps AI und Crypto Sa. Die beiden, Sharmad und David, haben je irgendwelche Firmen gegründet, die sie dann verkauft haben und so weiter. David Sex ist auch hier Papel Mafia und so. Also, das ist all in, ja. Also, das ist wirklich all in. Der heißt nicht ohne Grund all in. Und die vier sitzen immer zusammen und reden dann über so über Sachen. Und wir hören in diesen ersten Podcasts rein, der direkt nach dem Attentat auf Charlie Kirk stattfand, weshalb der natürlich begann mit der großen Lobhudelei.
Charlie wurde nicht von jemand anderem platziert. Er hat seine eigene Plattform gegründet. Er hat diese Organisation von Anfang an gegründet. Und er platzierte Liberale, oder Leftern oder Wöcher oder wer auch immer. Er gab ihnen die Gelegenheit, mit ihm zu diskutieren. Und seine Gruppe wurde größer und größer. Die Leute lieben ihn zu sehen und ihn zu diskutieren.
So, wir können uns ungefähr vorstellen wie das war. Also toll, dass er das ermöglicht hatte. Genau. Und er hat allen die Plattform geboten, wo man sich denkt, nein, deine Milliardärsfreunde haben ihm die Plattform geboten. So, und David Friedberg. So, also sehr viel Free Speech, Point of View, jeder darf seine Meinung haben und so. Ist doch toll, wenn Freunde miteinander im Gespräch sind.
Ich will jetzt auch noch mal sagen, ich habe mir in den letzten Tagen einfach noch mal so wahllos irgendwelche Debattenformate angesehen, die da so auf den US-Campussen stattfinden. Das ist ja fast alles erstaunlich dumm. Also zum Teil empörend blöde. Es geht ja nur darum, ob man jetzt so rhetorisch versiert genug ist, sich irgendwie die Bälle zuzuspielen oder gegenseitig an den Kopf zu werfen. Aber das sind ja Leute, die ja ein performatives Talent haben, aber die ja sehr wenig wissen. Von Bildung will ich da gar nicht reden. Und es ist so eine Idee von, jetzt werden wir das mal im Disput auf eine andere Ebene heben können. Aber das passiert alles gar nicht. Also ich muss sagen, diese ganze Debattenkultur, die da so ja schon lange da ist, das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues durch Charlie Kirk, sorgt nicht dafür, dass dort besonders intelligente Menschen zu Wort kommen, sorgt nicht dafür, dass ich da interessante Auseinandersetzungen finde, sondern ich sehe da eine Show, aber ich kann mir auch einen MMA-Kampf ansehen, das scheint mir ähnlich gedankenvoll zu sein.
Also ich kann zur amerikanischen Debattenkultur auf Campus nichts sagen, und zwar aus einem einfachen Grund, ich will es einfach nicht. Denn du sagst jetzt, dass es alles so dumm ist, und so, guck mal, da sind Erstsemester. Die wissen gar nicht, wie ihnen geschieht, und die haben alle TikTok. Klar gehen die mit dem Charlie Kirk-Ding und debattieren da. Und klar sehen wir das dann und sagen uns, das ist ja alles dumm. Also wenn man sich so ein bisschen reinfuckt, es gibt, klar, es gibt nur die ersten zehn Suchseiten Charlie Kirk, irgendwas. Aber es gibt auch Charlie Kirk besucht Cambridge. So und dann sitzen die ja in so einem Holz verteveltem Saal und da geht es da richtig zur Sache. Und das ist weder dumm noch ungefährlich für die Beteiligten, sondern da wird Charlie Kirk einfach richtig auseinandergenommen. Und da bleibt auch von diesem ganzen religiösen Überbau und hier und da. Und meine Antwort lebt vor allem davon, dass sie nur 90 Sekunden lang ist. Danach kommt ja jemand anders dran und hier stellt niemand eine Nachfrage und so. Wird komplett aufgehoben. Und ich bin sowieso dagegen, dass wir ein Urteil über was im amerikanischen Campus passiert, weil wir das sehen, was auf TikTok davon uns dargeboten wird, was Valerie Allisons Sohn meint, das sollten wir uns jetzt mal angucken. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass in amerikanischen Universitäten nicht ohne Grund wird diese Art von Intelligenz gerade so hart bekämpft von Trump, dass es da ziemlich cool zur Sache geht.
Ich glaube nur nicht bei diesen Debattenformaten. Ja, wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich sind die Klospüche da genauso lame, wie in der Uni Bielefeld. Alles zugestanden und richtig. Nur daraus leitet jetzt kein Urteil ab über diese Campus-Sachen. Da wird nicht nur sinnvolle Forschung, da wird auch im Vorfeld dieser Forschung sinnvolle Seminare und sinnvolle Hörlese für Veranstaltungen.
Ja, das will ich ja gar nicht hören.
Da finden auch sinnvolle Abendveranstaltungen statt.
Was hier aber so hervorgehoben wird und was wir jetzt auch als, also wir haben ja jetzt ganz viele Formate, die daraus abgeleitet wurden. Es gibt ja inzwischen Medienhäuser in den USA, die von diesen Campus-Debatten sich abgeschaut haben, wie man also konfligierende Parteien zusammenbringt. Und dann müssen die sich da irgendwie betteln. Und ich halte von diesen Formaten, die diese Campus-Tradition haben, nichts. Dass es natürlich ein anderes intellektuelles, universitäres Leben gibt. Davon gehe ich fest aus und ich will es auch hoffen.
Aber stell dir mal vor, du bekämpfst jetzt Besuch aus Frankreich. Und jemand sagt, also ich habe mir drei Maybritt-Illner-Sendungen angeguckt und dann noch mal historisch nachgeschaut, was ihr da bei Sabine Christensen, ich finde ihr Deutsche debattiert alle Scheiße. Da würdest du sofort sagen, ja genau.
Ja.
Bei dem, was du gesehen hast, würde ich auch sofort sagen, wir Deutschen sind das dümmste Volk der Welt. Und niemand könnte da widersprechen. Und ich sage nur, ja ja, bei dem, was ein Algorithmus uns vorspielt.
Ich beziehe das ja nicht auf Amerikaner allgemein, sondern ich beziehe das auf diese Art der Debatten, die offenbar wahnsinnig beliebt sind.
Ich bin nur sehr allergisch.
Und wir werden ja auch immer gefragt, wir sollen doch bitte auch in die Debatte und da und dort reingehen. Und ich gehe ja zum Beispiel auch nicht in politische Talkshows, weil ich sage, dass es sinnlos ist, dort sich hinzusetzen. Es ist völlig sinnlos, dort zu sitzen und drei Sätze mal einzuwerfen. Und danach ist wieder Wolfgang Kubicki dran. Es hatte einfach keinen Zweck. Man wird nur selbst blöde dabei und verblödet das Publikum mit. Und genau das, finde ich, ist bei sehr vielen dieser Formate, die jetzt von diesen Herrschaften offenbar auch so gefeiert werden als Sorte des Liberalismus. Das, was ich mir jetzt nochmal so angeguckt habe in dem Bereich, ist dumm. Die Forschung ist was anderes und in den Seminaren wird es auch anders zugehen. Aber ich finde interessant, dass das jetzt gerade etwas ist, was für viele so ein Aushängeschild ist, dass sich jetzt große Medienhäuser daran anstießen und sagen, das machen wir jetzt als Großshow.
Also was amerikanischen Campus angeht, bin ich 101% Free Speech.
Ja, das können wir gerne machen.
Jeder soll einfach reden, was er will. Das Problem ist, irgendwer hält eine Kamera drauf und dann landet irgendwas bei TikTok und dann bilden wir uns 10.000 Kilometer und zehn Monate später ein Urteil hier in Deutschland. Ich kann mich an sowas nicht beteiligen.
Aber du findest doch jetzt auch, dass diese Debatten von Charlie Kirk so nichts führen.
Ja genau. Aber nur weil das in einem Campus stattfindet, würde ich doch niemals eine Argumentation über einen Campus machen.
Nein, über diese Art der Debattenart.
Ich habe doch als Ausführlicher im Podcast gesagt, ich will, dass gar keiner mehr miteinander redet, sondern das einfach, wenn alle eine politische Frage stellen, haben, erst mal mir Gemini klären.
Ja, genau. Du gehst ja viel weiter tatsächlich. Und ich sage, das, was ich dort beobachtet habe, und ich habe ja nicht nur Charlie Kirk geguckt, ist, dass Leute nicht auf einer Grundlage miteinander argumentieren, sondern man hat in der Regel zwei konfligierende Meinungen, die kommen zusammen und dann wird auf so einer entweder formalogischen Weise so ein bisschen was verargumentiert oder man versucht mit rhetorischen Kniffen, sich gegenseitig in die Knie zu zwingen. Und du kommst ja genau mit der richtigen Antwort, dass man vielleicht erstmal sagt, ach so, wir reden über Gewalt in Städten, dann wäre vielleicht mal gut, die Statistiken zu haben und die Zahlen zu wissen, wie sieht es denn jetzt gerade aus? Und das ist interessanterweise etwas, was ich dort wenig finde.
Ja, aber wenn es dir um diese Debattenform geht und du mich fragst, wie ich das finde, dann sage ich dir oder dann wiederhole ich einfach, also diese Debatte, die von diesen Silicon-Villain-Milliardären, deren Podcast wir jetzt gerade hören, von der Trump-Regierung, von Stephen Miller und der ganzen Veranstaltung, die da organisiert wurde, abgefeiert wurde, finde ich natürlich nicht gut. Ja. Das ist meine Antwort darauf. Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass in einem Satz, in dem der amerikanische Unicampus vorkommt, automatisch von mir hinten dran gehängt wird, ja Unicampus ist natürlich blöd, alles Antisemiten, Debatten, alle bescheuert und so weiter. Nein, nein, da würde ich sagen, sind wir schon in dieser Falle getappt. Diese Leute, diese Milliardäre und deren Freunde organisieren für uns. Das ist so krass in diesem Podcast hier. Die reden darüber, dass eins ihrer Videos bei YouTube offenbar geshadowband wurde, während wir dann einfach sagen, ja, das ist ein bisschen blöd, das ist mit dem ausgeliefert, wie auch immer, ist ja alles weit weg. Drei Tage später nehmen die nächsten Podcasts auf. Ja, wir haben das mit YouTube geklärt. Blablabla, wo ich genau weiß, das ist ganz kurzer Dienstweg hier und so.
Können wir nicht machen.
Wenn uns diese Leute irgendwas voren, ach, das ist so schön, wenn die jungen Leute Free Speech machen und so weiter. Nee, das ist so schön, dass ihr uns das hinorganisiert habt, dass die da so ein Pseudo-Free Speech, und dann ist mal Charlie Kirk gemacht, prove me wrong und so. Also das ist alles schon verdorben, verlogen und wirklich schlimm, hier der dritte.
Also du würdest ja dann festhalten, dass wir, um das jetzt noch mal zu einem Fazit zu bekommen, du würdest also, wenn du das so polemisch sagst mit Gemini, eigentlich wollen, dass die Debatten weniger werden und man sich eigentlich mehr inhaltlich auseinandersetzt. Weil ich ja gerade gesagt habe, dass ich festgestellt habe, dass diese Debatten nicht besonders einen weiterbringen, es sei dann, man sieht gerne, wie Leute sich kappeln. Da hatten wir früher eine schöne Institution in den 90er Jahren und 00er Jahren. Das war nämlich die Talkshow am Nachmittag, Verbal Schäfer und Brit und wie sie alle hießen. Und dann haben sich Leute über irgendeinen Unsinn die Köpfe eingeschlagen. Aber das hat jetzt politisch nicht so eine wahnsinnig wichtige Dimension. Und jetzt geht es aber auf ein anderes Feld, wo ich sagen würde, ja, ihr redet jetzt da über Entwicklungshilfe, ihr habt aber da eigentlich gar keine Ahnung von. Versucht jetzt aber mit eurer entsprechenden rhetorischen Versiertheit, euch Punkte zu verschaffen. Dann sage ich, das führt nicht weiter inhaltlich. Und deswegen bin ich auch eher der, der sagt, weniger Debatte wagen.
Ja, also ich kann natürlich...
Das war meine Kritik an der Debattenkultur des amerikanischen Campus, weil die immer glauben, wir müssen mal ständig ins Gespräch kommen. Und ich sage, nee, muss man eigentlich nicht.
Das ist sowieso eine ganz arrogante Debattenführung. Also ich diskutiere jetzt mit dir und ich weiß ja, hier hören viele Leute zu, wenn jetzt bei irgendwelchen Abend-Treffen drei Leute anfangen, politischen Diskurs zu führen. Ich halte mich da raus. Also was soll ich denn da, damit zwei Leute irgendwie hören, was ich sage in dem Moment, zu irgendwas, was eh links rein, rechts raus. Also ich finde es, eine politische Meinung zu haben und sie zu äußern in so einem Gespräch, ist doch auch langsam lächerlich.
Ja, sagst du.
Ja, also ich weiß, junge Studenten stehen gerne in der Küche und diskutieren dann irgendwie die großen Fragen und so. Aber irgendwie, ich denke mir dann bei den meisten Sachen, gerade wenn man so älteren Leuten zuhört, sorry, aber hier kann man einen Live-Fact-Check machen, in dem man einfach tippity auf den Tisch legt und sagt, immer wenn du was hörst, was Quatsch ist, melde dich kurz. Weißte?
Gewiss.
Das öffnet ja auch wieder den Raum für nicht politische Fragestellungen, wo sie auch halt nicht hingehören. Also wenn sich das noch ein bisschen etabliert in der Breite, denn ehrlicherweise, ich finde es auch überraschend, aber ich höre immer, diese KI verbraucht so viel Strom und macht den Planeten so kaputt, aber ich sehe sie überall. Man kann ja keine App mehr öffnen, ohne dass einem die ganze Zeit irgend so eine Pseudointelligenz nochmal irgendetwas unterjubelt. Von daher, diese Omnipräsenz wird glaube ich schon, also ich glaube, wir werden, früher war immer, Leute machen so Selbstgespräche auf der Straße. Nein, Mama, die telefonieren. Okay. Und in fünf Jahren so, ey, die haben noch politisch diskutiert, weißt du? Und die haben nicht zwischendurch.
Aber das meinte ich ja mit Debattenkultur, die vielleicht an sich da gar nicht funktioniert. Also wenn ich einfach nur sage, ich will versuchen, eine Kontroverse herzustellen, dann komme ich ja nicht automatisch dahin, dass man Erkenntnis produziert. Wenn ich jemanden wie Milo Yiannopoulos einlade, der sagt, es gibt eigentlich gar keine richtigen Lesben, das ist keine Realität, dass Frauen lesbisch begehren, dann kann ich mit dem nicht mehr diskutieren, um einen Erkenntnisgewinn zu erzeugen. Dann kann man nur noch gucken, wer ist gerade rhetorisch versierter, wer hat die besseren Pointen parat. Aber es kann nicht darum gehen, dass man auf ein gemeinsames Erkenntnisinteresse kommt.
Das kommt in eh nie.
Doch. Wenn ich mit dir jetzt über etwas diskutiere, zum Beispiel, wie könnten wir Wohnen in Deutschland günstiger machen, dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich verschiedene Ansichten, oder wir können uns ergänzen, dann kommen wir aber auf ein anderes Niveau, wenn wir gemeinsam darüber reden. Aber wenn ich jetzt hier sitzen würde und sage, kein Problem, wenn wir zehn Millionen Obdachlose haben, dann kannst du nicht mehr mit mir vernünftig reden. So, und das ist aber eine Struktur, die ich jetzt bei meiner zugegebenermaßen etwas oberflächlichen Recherche zur US-Campus-Debattenkultur gesehen habe, dass man, und das sehen wir in Talkshows häufig auch in Deutschland, das ist ja auch nicht nur ein US-amerikanisches Phänomen, dass man sehr darauf bedacht ist, extreme Positionen zusammenzubringen, die aber gar nicht mehr zu einer Erkenntnis führen können, sondern es geht nur noch um den großen Knall. Und das ist eigentlich wie so ein MMA-Kampf, möglichst groteske Gestalten aufeinander los zu jagen. Und das ist etwas, was in dieser Debattenkultur am US-Campus schon sehr ausgeprägt ist und das jetzt migriert in sehr viele andere Bereiche und Formate. Und da würde ich generell sagen, warum sollen wir das jetzt reden? Soll ich jetzt eine Debatte führen mit Identitären? Soll ich das jetzt auch noch mal auf dem Campus austragen?
Also das sind alles rhetorische Fragen, weil ich hab ja schon gesagt, richtig.
Und das war meine Generalkritik an dieser Debattenkultur, was nicht meint, dass es im Seminar von Adam Toos eine interessante Diskussion geben kann über kainsianische Wirtschaftspolitik. Aber genau das ist nicht die Debatte, die viele Leute heranzieht, sondern es ist meist die Debatte, in der Milo Janopoulis irgendeinen Unsinn erzählt.
Ja, ich würde ja auch lieber eine Diskussion oder eine mögliche Aufklärung darüber haben, was passiert in Campus-Diskussionen, wenn der Professor feststellt, Mist, GPT diskutiert hier immer mit. Also im Sinne von, ich kriege eigentlich zu kluge Fragen, ich komme gar nicht mehr mit. Ich muss die ganze Zeit selber nachschauen und so. Gut, wir hören mal noch den dritten im Bunde, Schamath. Das ist allerdings Jason Calisthenics, aber danach macht Schamath noch eine hörenseite Sache. Es gibt hier eine Fraktion, die sagt, die Leute sind irgendwie krank, es gibt eine Covid-Generation und so.
Wie kann eine Person, die vermutlich ein 4.0 Student ist, auf der richtigen Strecke, eine Schauspielerin bekommt, so schwer auf die Reifen gehen? Und dann, wie endest du in einem Ort, wo du glaubst, dass so etwas wie das sogar toleriert oder justifiziert ist? Wie kann eine Person, die so vermutlich intelligent ist, in diesem Ort kommen?
Von einer konservativen Familie.
Das sieht so aus, als ob er sein ganzes Leben vor ihm hatte und an einer richtigen Strecke war, an einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt.
Und wenn er es kann, wie viele andere Menschen werden in diesem Ort enden?
Ich spreche gerade über diese Generationen im Allgemeinen. Wenn sie permanent online sind, sie sind Teil dieser Subkulturen, wenn sie ihren Gehirn mit all diesen Drogen schramblen, sind viele junge Menschen mit zwei oder drei anderen Medikamenten.
So, bla, bla, bla. Da muss natürlich David Sex jetzt eingreifen, das Worte ergreifen für die amerikanische Regierung und sagen, nein, es geht ja gegen Konservative, gegen Liberale. Das ist der Diskurs.
Wir wissen einiges über den Täter, die Ideologie, was seine Familie gesagt hat, was andere Leute gesagt haben, und was er in seine eigenen Textmessagen erklärt hat, warum er dieses Mörder verbreitet hat. Ich denke, ein großer Teil davon ist, dass in seinem Ansatz... Ich glaube, die grundsätzlichen konservativen Ansichten, die Charlie diskutiert hat, waren in seinem Ansatz, dass sie wütend waren und dass sie Faschisten waren. Ich glaube, in einer der Bullet-Casings hat er diese Faschisten getroffen. Er hatte diese Ansicht, dass, vor allem, die Gewalt als eine Weise ist, eine politische Debatte zu enden und dass die relativ mainstream konservative Denkweise so wütend war und über den Schaden, dass es geblieben war, dass es geblieben war.
Jetzt versucht der Jason das Gespräch wieder. Nein, wir wollen es hier nicht so politisch, nur weil du und von der Trump-Regierung...
Wir reden hier über die Aufnahme von 20% unserer Kinder auf SSRIs, oder auf Adderall oder auf irgendeinem Stimulant.
Ich würde ja sagen, der dritte Pol ist es, diese Vereinsammung vom Internet. Jeden Tag zehn Stunden irgendwelche Spiele und dann nochmal diese Verbotschaftung. Guck mal, ich war in diesen und diesen und diesen Diskurses, also schreib ich jetzt das und das und das und folgen das auf die Munition drauf. Das waren ja wirklich absurde Memes, muss man sagen. Hier der eine geht auf, nein, das sind die Medikamente und der andere sagt, nein, das ist der Kampf gegen die Konservativen.
Es ist nicht möglich, dass all diese Kinder das brauchen. Und es gibt viele andere Lösungen zu dem. Und dann werde ich die Algorithmen hinweisen. Nicht, dass ein Algorithm für den Mord verantwortlich ist, aber wir nehmen Menschen online die Hügel runter. Und in der Wahrheit war Charlie's Content exzellent für engagierte Menschen, kurze Formen, wirklich interessante Debaten und all das. Und diese Kombination, dass man online zu viel ist, übermediziert wird, isoliert wird, das alles zusammenfasst, Chamath. Ich denke, das ist das, was diese extremen Theorien und Verlust von der Realität führt. Aber wir könnten auch mit jemandem reden, der sehr mental ill ist. Und wir versuchen, eine sehr mental ille Person zu verstehen.
Warte, du beginnst zu klingen wie Paul Graham dort. Das ist einfach ein gewisser Nutz.
Das ist kein random nut. Wir haben es hier mit jemandem zu tun, der uns angreift.
In order to have civil society, we have to have the ability to engage in conversations, to have debates without fear of violence or murder.
Ja, und das wird jetzt natürlich ausformuliert.
Ich glaube, das, was du hier siehst, ist eine aufregende Moralität. Was Tyler Robinson gemacht hat, war ein Trag des Hates. Das ultimative Trag des Hates. Er hat Mörder gemacht. Er hat eine Frau verlassen, ohne einen Mann. Er hat zwei Kinder verlassen, ohne einen Vater. Es war das ultimative Trag des Hates. Aber in seinem entgegnenen Geheimnis war es irgendwie ein Trag des Liebens. Und die Frage ist, wie kommen wir hierher? Und wieder, wenn es nur Tyler Robinson gewesen wäre, könnten wir es einfach mit der Rande-Nut-Theorie sprechen.
Und wir wissen nicht, wer Trump geschossen hat. Wir haben keine Informationen von dieser Person.
Aber was mich mehr bemerkt, sind all diese Menschen in Reddit-Gruppen, oder online, in Blue Sky, was jetzt nur ein Schleifpunkt der Hate ist, wer......
feiern....
feiern, auf einigen Gründen.
Nein, es gibt definitiv Leute, die feiern.
Das ist, warum ich wirklich denke, einer der meisten konstruktivsten Dinge, die wir machen können, die aus dieser Sache kommen, ist, dass wir herausfinden müssen, wie diese Menschen den Kurs korrektieren.
So, hier müssen also Leute Kurs korrektiert werden. Hier haben wir es ja offenbar mit einem verdrehten Moral zu tun. Jetzt wollen sie über Jimmy Kimmel reden, während sie gerade, ne, also der ganze Online-Diskurs muss beschränkt werden und wir müssen hier eingreifen und so weiter. Wie ist das jetzt mit Free Speech in dieser Region hier bei diesen konservativen Milliardären?
Das ist eine ähnliche Geschichte. Wir haben keine Antworten hier.
Siehst du die Kommentare von Jimmy Kimmel? Sollen wir die spielen und darüber reden?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist ein ziemlich gutes Zeug hier. Also politischer Diskurs, adjacent, beziehungsweise. Der Fallout vom Mörder von Charlie Kirk wird uns hier für ein bisschen Zeit bleiben. ABC hat Jimmy Kimmel von Jimmy Kimmel Live indefinit ausgesucht, nachdem er die folgenden Kommentare und Druck von der FCC und den Affiliaten von ABC gemacht hat. Hier ist der 15-Secunden-Klip.
Wir hatten einige neue Lohne am Wochenende, mit der Maggagang, die zerstört versuchten, diesen Kind, der Charlie Kirk ermordet, als was anderes als einer von ihnen zu machen, was sie tun, um politische Punkte zu zerstören.
Ja, aber ich denke, du hast auch danach diese Sitzung verlassen, Du hast ja vergessen, den Clip reinzuspielen, wie er sagt und so weiter. Und jetzt muss man sagen, er war David Sacks, er hat auch vergessen reinzuspielen, wie Trump darauf reagierte, weshalb er zu dem Spruch kam, weil er hat ja nur sein Ballroom da abgefeiert, nachdem er gefragt wurde, wie geht es ihm jetzt, wo Charlie Kirk und so weiter. Holding up, ja mir geht es gut und guck mal der Ballroom. Ich müsste mal sozusagen alles wieder reinholen und so eine Exegese machen. Aber wie ist das nun? Ist das jetzt Free Speech? Was ist da los oder welche Kriterien sollen jetzt hier plötzlich gelten? Weil David Sacks muss jetzt verteidigen, warum das eine richtige Entscheidung war, Jimmy Kimmel zu canceln, obwohl die doch immer Free Speech sind.
Megyn Kelly hat eine sehr lange Deskription von allem, was vorher von Jimmy Kimmels Reden bekannt war. Und es gab eine große Menge Informationen, die zeigen, dass das jemand war, der in den Händen einer radikalen, schweizer Ideologie war. Und keine Evidenz zu zeigen, dass sie irgendwie Teil von MAGA waren. Und was Jimmy Kimmel dort gemacht hat, war, ich denke, ein furchtbares Lied, das befürchtet, dass Charlie Kirk. Von einer seiner eigenen, von einer MAGA-Person getötet wurde. Und dann zerstört er die genannte Schmerz und Ausdruck, die Millionen von Menschen fühlen. Und nicht nur von uns, die mit Charlie und Charlie zusammen waren, sondern von Millionen von Leuten.
Aber das ist okay. In Free Speech, Sachs, das Statement, Das ist seine Wahl, er könnte die Zuschauer verlieren, aber Free Speech schützt ihn, das zu tun. Die Herausforderung war, ob er etwas gesagt hat, das er nicht wahr war und es als Fakt erklärt hat. Und das war die Reaktion, die er bekommen hat. Ja, und wenn er etwas gesagt hat, das er wusste...
Er sagte, wir haben einige neue Lohne am Wochenende mit der Maga Gang und versuchten den Kind, der Charlie Kirk ermordet hat, als etwas anderes als einer von ihnen zu bezeichnen. Also bezeichnet er den Wochenende. Du kannst sagen, dass er hier ungenuos ist, aber ich denke, er ist nicht fasziniert.
Es ist sehr ungenuos.
Um das mal kurz zu übersetzen, was sie da besprechen, denn das war ja auch in den deutschen Medien nur ganz irre, wie das dann dargestellt wurde. Er bezieht sich auf das Wochenende und da war ja noch ein bisschen unklar, welch geistes Kind dieser Attentäter ist. Zumindest hatte man gesagt, es gibt da eine sehr große Nähe zu den Republikanern und das ist auch so ein kleiner Waffenlar gewesen. Und das stellte sich dann nachher als anders heraus. Da war Kimmel entweder nicht mehr auf dem neuesten Stand oder er hat sich nicht auf den neuesten Stand bringen können, weil dann schon gedreht wurde. Jedenfalls war er dort nicht akkurat oder man kann auch sagen, er hat dort falsch etwas erzählt. Nur, das gehört ja zu Free Speech auch dazu.
Innerlich falsch und nicht lustig war der Vorwurf der Zwente über Sex.
Lustig ist ja keine Verpflichtung, lustig zu sein. Und inhaltlich falsch bei so einer Sache, ja, das kann durchaus sein, dass er da falsch ist, aber dann wird man ja nicht vom Netz genommen normalerweise.
Sie bauen das jetzt hier so ein bisschen aus.
Ich kann ja auch sagen, der Attentäter war wahrscheinlich ein Zugehöriger dieser Sekte. Und dann stimmt das nicht, aber dann wird man mich jetzt nicht gleich irgendwie canceln.
Genau, es gab ja kein direktes staatliches Handeln, soweit ich weiß, sondern der FCC-Chef war halt in einem Podcast, wo er sagte, wir können das auf die oder die Art lösen, aber Jimmy Kimmel wird offline gehen.
Ja, und die FCC ist eben die Behörde, die darüber entscheidet.
Genau, die darf am Ende die Fernsehlizenz entziehen, aber ob man auf YouTube ein Video hochbringt, nicht.
Es ging ja nicht nur um die Fernsehlizenz, die entzogen wird, sondern gerade versucht ja der Sender zu expandieren, versucht also in mehreren Regionalprogrammen auch noch präsent zu sein. Dafür braucht man aber eine Zustimmung der FCC und die könnte in Gefahr sein, wenn man dann weiter an Kimmel festgehalten hätte.
Also deswegen gab es ja kein direkt staatliches Handeln, weil man diesen Bogen hat. Aber der FCC-Chef, da ging es schon darum, Jimmy Kimmel soll nicht on air sein. Wir können es auf diese oder jene und es gäbe auch die Möglichkeit, dem Sender einfach direkt die Lizenz zu entziehen. Jetzt hat man es über Banden gespielt und hat gesagt, ihr habt ja hier ein ökonomisches Anliegen, das wir genehmigen müssen. Also kommt uns doch mal entgegen und kanzelt Jimmy Kimmel.
Ja. Aber so funktioniert ja heute, ich glaube, das musst du noch mal deutlich machen, weil Zensur würde ja so bedeuten, wir schreiben ein Gesetz nieder und da steht das und das darf nicht gesagt werden.
Und das gibt es erstaunlicherweise in Amerika.
Wir hören das hier mal. Ich will gerade eine Sache sagen. Das ist ja nicht die Art, wie heute hauptsächlich Zensur betrieben wird, sondern Zensur kann man ja eben auch damit betreiben, dass man zum Beispiel dann droht, den Rundfunkbeitrag nicht mehr zu erhöhen. Damit droht, dass die und die Gelder nicht mehr gezahlt werden.
Genau, also indirekte Einflussnahme.
Am Dienstag hat der FCC-Chair, Brendan Carr, den wir alle kennen, gesagt, dass der FCC sich in die Broadcast-License der ABC-Affiliate anschauen würde, weil Jimmy Kimmel in die Zeit von News-Distortion engagierte, durch eine falsche Erklärung von Tyler Robinson als MAGA.
So, News-Distortion gibt es durchaus. Also da kann man einfach sagen, ihr habt News-Distortion gesehen, obwohl ich mir denke, in der EU Times gab es einen sehr interessanten Text. Die Trump-Anhängerschaft in der Regierung macht sich langsam Sorgen darüber, welche Benchmark Trump etabliert für und dafür verfolgen wir unsere Gegner, weil sie sich vorstellen können, dass sie nach Trumps Tod, wenn mal wieder jemand anderes regiert, selber dieser Gegner sein können. Und die Anklage von Comey ist ja so halb gar. Und so haben sie Informationen an den Fernsehsender geleakt. Und selbst wenn, was ist das für eine Information? Ja, das ist völlig absurd. Wenn diese Benchmarks für alle dort gelten, sitzen die alle im Gefängnis. Und das bringt die natürlich gerade diese jungen Leute, also Stephen Miller und so, die leben ja noch 60 Jahre über Trump hinaus. Also das muss man sich auch mal vorstellen, was da eigentlich für Lebensplanung noch sein muss. Jetzt kommt David Sacks, jetzt wird's hier heikel...
.we see after all that, Paul Jimmy Kimmel in definitely. So I guess the question here, Sacks...
Pull up the ratings, pull up the ratings over time.
No, no, no, we'll get to all that, but let me just ask the question. Do you have concerns about this, Sacks? Obviously you've been very pro Free Speech here. Do you think that this is overreaching? If he hurt people's feelings, if he said something inaccurate, do you think he should be, the government should be taking him off the air or putting pressure on them to take him off the air?
Well, no, the government shouldn't be ordering him to be taken off the air, but neither President Trump nor the FCC Chairman Brendan Carr did that. The reason why Kimmel lost his job is because the two largest affiliates, which is Nextar and Sinclair, told ABC Disney that they wouldn't air it anymore. And I think part of this is due to the genuine offense at what he said, which, okay, I guess you can put the best face you want on it. It was false and it was a flip way of describing something that was causing pain to millions of Americans. Nextar called his remarks offensive and insensitive, that is true. And then Sinclair said that they're going to air a Kirk Tribute in Kimmel's time slot on Friday.
So, also er nimmt jetzt schon einen Anlauf, der die Gewaltdefinition beginnt relativ früh, so. Und nachdem sie dann so ein bisschen klären, inwieweit man eine Verantwortung Wir haben jetzt eine sehr intensive Debatte über die Bildungsaufgaben, die der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk hat als Sender, was man sendet auf terrestrischen, es gibt da ein Public Interest Requirement, also so wie in Deutschland auch, dass der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk so einen Bildungsauftrag hat oder was auch immer. Wir machen jetzt hier nach dem Jason Kelesenics so ein bisschen widerspricht, eine sehr intensive Debatte, bei der auch so ein bisschen David Sex dann in die Engel getrieben wird, sag ich mal. Also wir haben jetzt so viel über, wie man debattiert und das Departieren und so, wie hier jetzt versucht wird, Free Speech, aber dann doch nicht durchzudrücken, ist schon interessant.
Niemand sieht das.
Aber ich habe große Sorgen über mich persönlich, was Brendan Carr tut. Ich denke nicht, dass die FCC...
Er hat nichts getan.
Ich kann vielleicht meine Sitzung beenden.
Okay.
Oder du kannst mich jedes Mal verabschieden, wenn ich eine Sitzung starte. Wir haben gerade über den Zivildiskurs gesprochen. Willst du den Zivildiskurs haben? Oder willst du mich verabschieden?
Ich bin zivile, dass er nichts getan hat.
Du bist nicht zivile, wenn du mich in der ersten Sitzung verabschiedest.
Bitte, los.
Ich habe auch Gefühle über die Behandlung der Administration.
Also das sind alles Milliardäre soweit, außer er. Ja, die kriegen alle jeden Tag einfach 100.000 Dollar überwiesen für nichts. Die könnten machen, was sie wollen und sie führen so einen Diskurs-Po-Panzer auf. Ich versteh das manchmal gar nicht so richtig.
Ich finde es schrecklich. Ich mag nicht die Druck, die CBS unterzulegen, um Kobera zu verhörten und ich mag nicht die Druck, die ABC-News unterzulegen. Wir sollten eine Tradition von Free Speech haben und Comedians sollten geschützt werden, auch wenn du nicht magst, was sie sagen müssen. Das ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was viele Leute, und warum sie diese Administration gegründet haben, ist, dass es weniger Sensoren gibt. Wir haben hier seit vielen Jahren in diesem Programm über Biden-Sensoren, Covid-Talks und Biden-Sensoren, soziale Medien, das Twitter-File, es ist eine direkte Linie in diesem Programm, um das zu erzielen.
Ich denke, dass das...
Kann ich deine Frage stellen?
Es ist ein schrecklicher Moment für diese Administration, um so versetzt mit dem Versuch, ihre Kritiker zu silen. Und es wird nicht funktionieren, es wird sie nur an den Podcasts starten und mehr machen.
Ja.
Zuerst möchte ich eine Statementation machen. Ich denke, deine Kommentare sind verrückte. Aber hier ist meine Frage.
Ich glaube, du bist so sykophant für Trump.
Was habe ich gesagt? Ich habe gesagt, er hat nichts getan.
Nein, ich glaube, du versuchst es Trump zu verbreiten, indem du sagst, es ist ein schreckliches Show, er ist nicht lustig, nichts davon mattert, in Bezug auf die Freiheit der Rede.
Ich versuche, dir eine Frage zu stellen. Weil die Regierung nichts getan hat, lass uns einfach klar sein, sie hat nichts getan.
Sie haben ihn verletzt.
Nachdem er bereits nicht konnte.
Nein, und sie sollten keine Druck machen. Die Regierung sollte ihn bleiben.
Okay, lass mich deine Frage fragen. Denken du, dass die Leute, die die Entscheidung gemacht haben, Kimmel zu verpüren, was für einen Anteil ist die wirtschaftliche Realität eines bester Show? Und was für einen Anteil ist das Verbrechen von Free Speech, wie du es bezeichnest?
So, also das, was du jetzt gerade als indirektes Canceln oder Zensur, weil die ökonomischen Sachverhalte eben von der amerikanischen Regierung mitbestimmt werden, Also wenn das stattfindet, ist das ja eine ökonomische Entscheidung, die halt unabhängig politischer Einflussnahme getroffen wird. Jetzt kommt David Sexer zurück ins Gespräch. Er ploppt ja wahrscheinlich manchmal so raus aus Technikgründen oder wie auch immer. Und wir wissen ja, Stephen Colbert wurde auf jeden Fall über diesen Bandeweg daraus gecancelt. Jetzt kriegst du hier die Aufklärung.
Du glaubst, Trump ist der Grund, warum Colbert wurde gecancelt? Was redest du hier?
Ich denke, dass die Druck...
Das ist wie eine ganze Mythologie, die jetzt geschaffen wurde.
Nein, nein, das ist keine Pathologie. Ich denke, sie wollten den Paramount-Deal durch. Nein, nein, ich denke, dass die Paramount-Deal durch den Verkauf des Paramounts geht. Und ich denke, sie haben viele dieser Begriffe besetzt, weil sie nicht wollen, dass sie...
Das Geschäftsmodell ist weg.
Das kann alles wahr sein. Zwei Dinge können gleichzeitig wahr sein.
John Stewart versteht das Medium und sagt, es ist eine Blockbuster-Store. Sie können nicht warten, dass diese Jungs weg sind. Diese Jungs sind überpaid. Sie sind enttäuscht, weil sie grosslich überpaid sind. Sie denken, sie verdienen das. Übrigens, Free Speech bedeutet nicht, dass du ein ABC-Show hast. Entschuldigung. Du musst tatsächlich Ratings bekommen. Du musst talentiert sein. Du musst lustig sein, was keine dieser Jungs mehr sind. Das ist der Grund, warum sie verhäuert werden. Genau. Sie reden über den Replacement von Kimmel, nicht nur ein späterer Performer. Celebrity Family Feud. Sie werden ihn mit einem Spielshow verändern. Das ist das, was sie mit Replacement reden.
Es ist ein mehr erfreuliches Show. Sie hätten weder von diesen Leuten oder von der Regierung keine Replacement von Kimmel gecancelt. Die FCC-Fraktion hat gesagt, wir werden das eine oder andere Weise machen. Ich glaube, das ist das, was wir nicht sehen wollen, bei der Trump-Administration. Und, übrigens, Tucker Carlson, Glenn Greenwald und ich sind alle in Synch auf das Thema. Wir alle denken, dass das ein schlechter Blick für Trump und die Trump-Administration ist. Ihr könnt euch nicht begreifen, aber das tun wir hier. Wir haben mehrere Verabredungen.
Das ist ja auch zu erleben jetzt, dass Tucker Carlson bisweilen die US-Administration dafür kritisiert, dass sie Free Speech einschränken. Jetzt weiß man natürlich nicht, wie lange Tucker Carlson bei so einer grundsätzlichen Kritik bleibt oder ob er dann am Ende doch wieder froh ist, wenn Linke den Mund verboten bekommen. Aber da sieht man, da rumortet es gerade schon.
Ja, das sind alles so Testbalancen.
Da rumortet es nicht wirklich.
Ja, ich würde aber schon sagen, dass das Free Speech schon noch für einige der republikanischen Amerikaner eine grundsätzliche Sache ist und auch eine rote Linie, die überschritten wird.
Ja, aber guck mal, Takerl Carlson, der hat uns gesagt, lieber facke ich mein Haus ab, bevor da ein Afrikaner einschiebt.
Das stimmt ja alles.
Der möchte lieber kein Free Speech, solange der steht an Trumps Seite.
Ja, aber nicht, wenn es plötzlich auch darum geht, dass das dann sein Sprechen bedroht sein könnte.
Sein Sprechen ist ja nicht bedroht. Man muss auch ein bisschen sondieren. Das größere Problem ist, dass Tucker Carlson aussortiert wird, weil jemand anders plötzlich die Free Speech-Fackel aufnimmt und ihm die Sauerstoff, also dass das passiert. Also geht er natürlich in diese Richtung, aber das ist fast wie DGB und SPD. Da ruft man morgens an und sagt, ich mach heute mal einen Spruch zu Free Speech, nicht übel nehmen, ich halte für euch auch so ein bisschen das Becken sauber.
Ja, okay, das mag ja sein. Nur, was ich glaube, was jetzt bei Republikanern durchaus ein Punkt sein kann, ist, dass sie Free Speech als so etwas Grundsätzliches erachten, das geschützt gehört. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich schon alles dorthin gedreht hat.
Ja, mal sehen, wie es sich auch dann einfordert.
Nur sehe ich ja generell das Problem, dass Free Speech bedroht ist, nicht nur von der republikanischen Seite jetzt, weil das sind ja immer so die offensichtlichen Dinge jetzt mit Kimmel oder Colbert, und das geht dann so einmal über Bande, also nicht der Präsident verbietet direkt die Sendung, der geht ja nicht da hin und zieht den Stecker raus, sondern das wird dann über Bande gespielt, dass aber generell diese Free Speech immer weniger wichtig wird. Ich meine, wir haben da im Sommer-Live-Salon sehr lange drüber diskutiert. Wir sehen auch jetzt wieder im Zuge von Charlie Kirk, dass auch jemand wie Scott Galloway dann sehr schnell dahin kommt, zu sagen, ja, wir wollen eigentlich Social-Media-Verbot bis zum 16. Lebensjahr oder am besten bis zum 18. Lebensjahr. Und dass man also jetzt diesen Anlass nimmt und plötzlich sagt, ach, da gab es einen Attentäter, der hat sich wohl auch zum Teil online radikalisiert. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt die sozialen Medien abstellen. Oder wir müssen die sozialen Medien dann nur noch mit elterlicher Kontrolle. Und das wird aber dann alles über die entsprechenden Dienststellen palantieren und so weiter gemacht. Und da sehe ich ein generelles Problem, dass wir uns immer mehr eigentlich dem annähern, dass wir sagen, es muss alles gelenkt und reguliert sein, was natürlich bedeutet, dass ganz viel dann nicht mehr stattfinden soll. Und wir sehen das ja jetzt gerade, sind das hier so Galionsfiguren, die angegriffen werden wie Jimmy Kimmel. Aber was wir ja schon die ganze Zeit sehen, ist, dass man laufend unterstellt, dass aufgrund von ausländischer Einwirkungen die sozialen Medien infiziert sind. Und deswegen müssen wir lieber da Ganze aufräumen. Bedeutet aber, dass eben sehr viele Positionen, die in den sozialen Medien sonst vertreten werden, auch immer stärker marginalisiert werden. Und das ist schon eine generelle Entwicklung, dass es einen Kampf gibt, sowohl einer Trump-Administration, aber auch zum Beispiel einer EU, gegen Free Speech. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die wir haben. Und das ist etwas, was mich sehr mit Sorge erfüllt.
Ich weiß, aber mich erfüllt mit Sorge, dass...
Und mich kann nicht jetzt...
13-Jährige jeden Morgen sieben Todesfälle live fast mit ansehen müssen.
Ja, aber muss ich dafür jetzt allen das Internet verbieten?
Nein, aber was machen wir dagegen? Um das Problem haben wir uns noch nie gekümmert.
Ja, dann müssen...
Niemand kümmert sich darum.
Dann müssen 13-Jährige so erzogen werden, dass sie sich nicht für...
Also die Eltern müssen es machen.
Na ja, wie soll es denn sonst gehen?
Du hast die reichsten Männer der Welt, die das auf die attraktivste Technik bis unter die Bette gedrückt haben und die Eltern sollen das Problem lösen.
Du sagst jetzt Todesfälle. Wir sagen alle natürlich gleich, ja, das ist ja schlimm.
Nee, ich sag Todesfälle und ich bleibe auch bei Todesfällen. Ich will jetzt nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie aufgeweicht wird, heute sagst du Todesfälle, morgen sagst du irgendwas. Ich sage heute Todesfälle. Und ich sage auch in einer Woche Todesfälle.
Aber bleiben wir bei den Todesfällen.
Ich will keine Todesfälle mehr im Verkehr, im Fitnessstudio, weil jemand das Gewicht doch nicht halten kann und sich den Hals und so weiter. Ja, diese Videos gibt es.
So, was wir aber und Taylor Lawrence hat das ja sehr gut ausgeführt, dann erleben ist Folgendes, dass man sagt, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, keine Ausflüchte. Wir bleiben bei den Todesfällen.
Keine Ausflüchte. Ich will wissen, Tote Palästinense. Ich will jetzt nicht hören. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich möchte jetzt nicht hören.
Aber das passiert.
Dass die amerikanische Regierung und sonst wer immer nur Vorschläge macht, in denen nicht nur die Todesfälle, sondern auch andere Sachen ausgeblendet werden. Scheiß drauf. Das will ich nicht hören. Ich will hören, wie wir diese Todesfälle und anderes traumatisches Zeug nicht mehr bei Instagram sehen. Ich will nicht...
Ja, bedeutet, bedeutet...
Ich will keinen Diskurs über das, was schon stattfindet.
Ja, bedeutet, man müsste dann ja ein Gesetz so...
Warum ein Gesetz? Warum kommst du auf ein Gesetz? Ich will doch nur keine Todesfälle. Ich will kein Gesetz. Ich möchte einfach, dass da keine Todesfälle zu sehen sind.
Man muss ja irgendwelche Regularien, kannst du es auch nennen, aber die müssen ja irgendwie umgesetzt werden, damit man das eine vom anderen unterscheiden kann.
Wer soll diese Unterscheidung denn einführen?
Genau, und da wird es ja schwierig.
Ja genau, und warum lösen wir das Problem nicht, nur weil es schwierig ist? Wir können doch jetzt nicht sagen, ah, das ist zu schwierig, wir lösen das Problem nicht.
Aber was wäre denn jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn du sagst, ich will nicht, dass Minderjährige oder generell Leute da irgendwelche Todesfälle verfolgen können, also wie Menschen zu Tode kommen bei irgendetwas. Und das ist ja erstmal ein richtiges Anliegen. Und wir haben das ja auch zum Beispiel bei irgendwelchen, also es gibt ja Dinge, die wir dort nicht zu sehen bekommen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir immer alles zu sehen bekommen, sondern zum Beispiel wird ja Pornografie sehr restriktiv behandelt. Auf diesen Plattformen, das ist ja dort, findet dort nicht statt.
Bei YouTube gibt es kein Porno, aber Todesfälle. Warum?
So, das ist aber dann ja ein ganz konkreter Fall, über den zu sprechen ist. Was wir aber jetzt bei einem Scott Galloway zum Beispiel...
Ich will jetzt nicht über Scott Galloway, ich will über diesen Fall. Warum sehen wir Todesfälle, aber kein Porn?
Aber genau, darüber...
Warum blendet YouTube und Instagram Todesfälle nicht aus? Sie wissen auch, was ein Todesfall ist. Das ist doch das Besondere. Sie zeigen es dir doch, weil es ein Todesfall ist.
Ja, natürlich zeigen sie es.
Also wissen sie, dass es ein Todesfall ist. Und sie zeigen es dir trotzdem an. Weil es spektakulär ist, deswegen zeigen sie es. Das kann man, sage ich, etwas dagegen tun, ohne dass man deswegen Taylor Lawrence und dich aufscheucht, weil immer auch irgendwas anderes. Mir geht es um die Todesfälle.
Aber findest du jetzt gerade, dass etwas sinnvoll passiert in diese Richtung? Wo nicht?
Ich möchte einen politischen Diskurs, und zwar geführt gerade von dir und Taylor Lawrence zu diesem Todesfallthema. Dass die amerikanischen Regierungen alle immer die Stränge schlagen, weiß ich jetzt schon. Und das weiß ich auch schon seit 15 Jahren oder seit 20, seitdem das gibt. Ich brauche dazu keine weitere Aufklärung. Ich will nur wissen, wie wir jetzt diese Todesfälle draufkriegen.
Und was wäre deine Antwort darauf?
Also, wir verbieten diesen Unternehmen, diese Todesfälle zu zeigen. Wenn ein Todesfall auftaucht, wird dieses Ding wie auf der Autobahn, da kommt die Autobahnpolizei und sagt, das ist ein Gefahrguttransporter, der nicht ordentlich gesichert ist. Die Antwort ist Betriebsstilllegung. Dieses Auto bremst sofort auf 0 kmh ab, wird entladen und entsorgt. So, jetzt bin ich dafür. Die Konsequenz ist, wenn bekannt wird, dass Todesfälle auf Instagram gezeigt werden, muss Instagram ausgeschaltet werden, bis Instagram zeigt, dass keine Todesfälle gezeigt werden. Und da bist du nicht dafür. Und da bin ich aber dafür. Ich bin dafür, dass die Betriebsstilllegung ein echtes operatives Handwerkszeug wird.
Also es gibt andere Handhabungen, als das komplett lahmzulegen.
Wie liegt immer der deutsche Arbeitsschutz? Wie weit der die Sachen treibt? Da werden Treppenhäuser gesperrt, weil irgendwie der Handlauf ein bisschen locker ist und so weiter. Und dann wird da, weil durchs Treppenhaus nicht gegangen werden kann, überhaupt nicht gearbeitet in diesem Gebäude. Das sind alles richtige Konsequenzen. Wir wollen das so.
Aber wir haben doch momentan noch nicht mal Strafen, die wir richtig umsetzen. Also es gibt die ganzen...
Ja, ich will jetzt schon wieder nicht über das Strafen nicht durch und so weiter.
Nein, aber warum gehst du so manchmal und sagst, ich meine, du kannst das fordern, aber du weißt, dass gerade die EU Washington unter den Rock riecht und alles, was man an DSA und so weiter machen will.
Du warst bei einer Veranstaltung, wo du mit der SPD diskutiert hast, wo du gesagt hast, ich möchte, dass die Leute billig wohnen. Und sie sagte, ja, das können sie immer so fordern, von ihrem YouTube-Sitz aus, aber wir haben die Mehrheiten nicht. Und als du gefragt hast, es gibt eine Mehrheit für teures Wohnen, ich sehe die nicht und genauso ist das hier auch. Ja, die Silicon Valley-Unternehmen und tun viel dafür, immer so, wir gehen so bis an die Grenze ran und kommen den Politikern entgegen.
Ich hatte jetzt die EU kritisiert. Die EU macht nichts effektiv gegen das Silicon Valley, die schreibt hin und wieder ein Knöllchen, dass sie dann meistens noch nicht mehr bezahlen müssen.
Da sind wir uns ganz einig.
So, und?
Aber Taylor Lawrence Ansatz ist, es darf nichts reguliert werden, der Jeff Jarvis Style. Und das finde ich nicht gut.
Es müsste das, was du jetzt konkret gerade rausgepickt hast, müsste reguliert werden. Bedeutet aber, dann müsste man sich mit dem Silicon Valley anlegen. Die EU will sich aber nicht mit dem Silicon Valley anlegen, sondern will sagen, lieber Mark Zuckerberg, lieber Palantir-Chef und so weiter, könnt ihr vielleicht eine Alterskontrolle einführen, sagen wir ab 16 Jahren und außerdem politische Inhalte, also sowas zu Gaza und so, das wollen wir auch nicht mehr sehen. Und außerdem würden wir aber gerne die und die Punkte auch nicht haben. Aber damit wir das öffentlich rechtfertigen können, erzählen wir irgendwas über Pornografie und Menschen, die zu Tode kommen in Live-Videos.
Um es abzukürzen.
Und genau da hakt ja meine Kritik ein und da ist mein Plädoyer für Free Speech. Und dann denke ich, bevor die jetzt mir so etwas anbieten, wo plötzlich meine Meinungsfreiheit eingeschränkt wird, dann sage ich lieber, dann macht nichts. Ich sage aber auch, es gäbe andere Möglichkeiten. Und die Pornografie beweist es ja. Wir sehen keine Pornos bei YouTube. Also kann man es machen. Und das bedeutet aber, dass man sich entsprechend politisch mit dem Lager Trump anlegen muss. Das macht aber keiner.
Da ich ja nicht auf Konsens abstelle, will ich es mit einer ganz scharfen These hier beenden, was wir gerade diskutieren. Für mich mittlerweile, und ich habe noch mal intensiver gehört, nachdem wir es auch im Sommersalat besprochen haben, Taylor Lawrence ist für mich mittlerweile der Ulf Poscha der Datenautobahn. Kein Tempolimit. Nirgendwo. Sobald das diskutiert wird, dass es da auch Probleme gibt, schön und gut, können wir irgendwann mal klären. Ich rede auch nicht darüber, was die Silicon-Welle macht. Ich rede nur darüber, wie böse Politiker sind, weil sie halbgarere Antworten finden. Deshalb ich, und es ist mir ganz wichtig, diese ganz knallharte, wenn jeden Morgen die 10 Millionen Schüler in Deutschland sich erstmal 20 Millionen Todesfälle anschauen, muss dieser Betrieb stillgelegt werden.
Punkt.
Und wer macht das?
Wie wer macht das?
Also siehst du irgendeine politische Richtung, die dahin geht?
Naja, ich möchte, ich wünsche mir eine Politik, die damit genauso wie auf einer regulären Autobahn Betriebsstilllegung verordnet. Kommt die Autobahnpolizei, sagt sie fahren jetzt hier rechts ran, dann fährst du rechts ran. Fertig. Ach, dann kann das nicht ausgeliefert werden? Ja, schön und gut. Ist mir egal, was sie geladen haben. Das wird hier nicht ausgeliefert.
Was wir real in der Politik erleben, ist ja zum Beispiel, dass Demokraten und Republikaner plötzlich dann doch in den USA zusammenarbeiten.
Ich weiß, ich weiß. Und das macht mich auch so fuchsig, dass jedes Mal, wenn ich so ein Thema anspreche, du, ja, aber die Demokraten auch und so weiter und die Gesetze, das weiß ich doch alles. Ich habe darüber vor zehn Jahren schon aufgehört, Texte zu schreiben mit der FAZ, weil das alles nichts bringt. Ich will diese Diskussion nicht mehr. Ich weiß, dass das Silicon Valley von Männern gemacht wird, die nichts Gutes im Schilde führen und nicht ohne Grund die reichsten Leute der Welt sind. Die haben die ganze amerikanische Regierung unter ihren Fittichen. Sie haben sich richtig unterworfen. Dass das Probleme sind, weiß ich. Nur, wir sind hier in Deutschland und es geht mir um die deutschen Kinder. Ich will keine UK macht irgendwas, die US macht irgendwas und irgendeine Podcasterin erzählt dazu irgendwas. Sondern ich möchte ein Movement starten. Wenn in Deutschland etwas passiert, das uns nicht gefällt, überleg mal, wie schnell wir Grenzen zumachen. In einer anderen Welt würde ich sagen, niemals würden die 3000 Kilometer Grenze zumachen, nur bei mal jemand und so weiter. Wird aber gemacht. Und dieses fordere ich jetzt auch ihr für.
Du kannst das ja fordern. Das ist ja so, wie zu sagen.
Ich bin natürlich Anhänger. Ich möchte, dass du ein Anhänger dieser Idee bist, dass man diese großen Dienste einfach ausschaltet, wenn sie nicht so funktionieren, wie wir das wollen. Und damit meine ich wirklich nur ausschalten.
Ich kann das nachvollziehen. Ich wollte nur, weil das vielleicht nicht alle da so drin sind und das beobachten, was wir jetzt gerade gesehen haben, war, dass eine EU sich aufgestellt hat und versucht hat, den Datenschutz zu stärken. An sich, ich kenne nicht alle Details, aber an sich ja mal keine schlechte Idee. Und jetzt merkt man, dass man alles tun muss, um Trump zu gefallen. Und das erste, was man schleift, ist das, was man mühsam da auf EU-Ebene erarbeitet hat. Das bedeutet also, diese Forderungen, die du da hast, sind etwa so weit weg wie das Leben von Elon Musk auf dem Mars.
Wie billiges Wohnen.
Nee, weiter weg. Und ich finde einfach nur, dass man das, und ich sehe eine Gefahr darin, dass man jetzt dann plötzlich aus so einer Haltung heraus, die müssten das eigentlich abstellen, sagt, toll, wenn Ministerpräsident XY demnächst ein Smartphone-Verbot für unter 18 Jahre gefordert. Weil ich dann einfach sagen muss, nein, das kann nicht die Antwort darauf sein. Die Antwort wäre hier zum Beispiel mit Milliardenstrafen, die Konzerne zu überziehen, sobald diese Videos online sind. Da bin ich sehr dafür. Ich will ja nicht solche Videos auf dem Plattform haben. Aber wenn man nicht einmal bereit ist, diese Strafen zu verhängen und immer sagt, und da wissen wir nicht und tun wir nicht, dann kommt man da einfach nicht weiter. Was ich jetzt gerade sehe, ist aber, dass dieser ganze Diskurs so ist, dass wir inzwischen im Handelsblatt-Podcast Werbung vorgespielt bekommen von Instagram, der uns gesagt wird, Parental Control. Und das klingt immer noch so, als würden sich alle um die Kinder bemühen. Und das finde ich im höchsten Maße verlogen. Und da finde ich auch richtig, dass Taylor Lawrence dagegen sich laut macht.
Aber ich möchte gerne jetzt die konstruktive Wende einführen. Ich will von Regulierung nichts mehr hören, wirklich nichts mehr. Die Unternehmen wissen, wie sie es machen sollen. Die müssen nicht von uns reguliert werden. Die wissen das. Sie wissen, was Pornografie ist und sortieren das bei YouTube einfach aus. Also die wissen, wie es geht. Was ich fordere, ist der strafende Staat, der keine Vorgaben macht, sondern der einfach nur sagt, das ist verboten, wenn du es trotzdem machst. Gefängnis. Das können wir Unternehmen nicht ins Gefängnis stecken. Deswegen Betriebsschließung.
Die CEO's schon.
Ich will keine Diskussion mehr über, ach Politiker und ja, das muss man verstehen, wie die miteinander zusammenhängen. Ich will auch nicht mehr, ja, also auf Seite drei dieses Vorschlags für ein Regularium und so weiter. Beim Thema Internet will ich jetzt den strafenden Staat. Ganz einfache Regel in eine Zeile. Wenn Todesfälle auf YouTube gezeigt werden, darf YouTube nicht senden. Und dann wird YouTube einfach ausgeschaltet. Und ehrlicherweise, vielleicht ist das auch ein Insentl für Friedrich Merz, er will ja mal Produktivitätswachstum. Instagram für eine Woche ausschalten. Deutschland zwei Prozent mehr Wirtschaftswachstum.
Das glaube ich auch.
Wir gucken jetzt den letzten Clip. David Sex zitiert uns jetzt Voltaire. Ja, jetzt wird es richtig Voltaire.
Ich habe mit Frebergs Rap begonnen, aber ich dachte es war bemerkenswert, wie das Ganze am Ende zusammengekommen ist. Und es scheint ein starker Wahlpunkt zu sein. Und ich glaube, dass Charlie am nächsten Tag assassiniert wurde. Ich habe die Summe nicht mehr gedacht, aber ich glaube, dass es wirklich in der Idee des Schicksals der Westen geht. In dem Sinne, dass es, wie wir gesagt haben, eine große Kontingente von Leuten gibt, die nicht glauben, was ich als die zentrale.
Aber es muss auch akkurat und lustig sein, ansonsten darf es es doch nicht sein.
Freiheit ist, das Recht zu denken und zu glauben und zu wüsten, wie du willst, Freiheit der Religion, Freiheit der Sprache, Freiheit der Presse, es kommt alles aus dem. Und was du hier hast, ist, Leute wie Tyler Robinson oder die Leute, die er feiern, was er getan hat, ist das exakt andere. Ich entgegne, was du sagst, und ich werde dich töten, um dein Recht zu sagen, zu verhindern. Das ist...
Die Antithese.
Das ist die Antithese, und es ist nicht die westliche Zivilisation. Es ist etwas anderes und zerstört. Und wo es zu führen wird, ist eine Zivilwarschaft, die wir auf der einen Seite des politischen Spektrums nicht wollen.
Ja, interessant, dass er jetzt so den Moderaten gibt, wo sie sich genau an dieses Zitat nicht halten. Und man ja auch im Übrigen sagen kann, wenn jemand über Charlie Kirks Tod Witze macht, dann mag man das geschmacklos finden. Es würde aber genau zu dieser Free Speech dazugehören.
Ja, es wäre Charlie Kirks Ansinnen auch, so wie er sich drüber lustig gemacht hat über alles das auch. Naja, das sind einfach vergiftete Diskurse, die sich um nichts innerliches mehr drehen, sondern nur noch den Hegemon versuchen, auf seine Seite zu ziehen. Weshalb ich sage, nicht mehr diskutieren. Also wirklich nachfragen, ob das Gespräch, dessen Offerte man gerade bekommt, nicht einfach mit Gemini besser wäre.
Ich glaube, dass wir jetzt tatsächlich noch mal einen Debattenboom dadurch erleben.
Ja, aber das ist ein Fehler. Es gibt nichts zu diskutieren. Wenn wirklich jemand glaubt, eine inhaltliche Aufklärung würde noch einen Unterschied machen. Das muss man erstmal beweisen.
Aber schau doch mal, alle Formate, ja, das glaube ich, ich weiß, dass alle in die falsche Richtung laufen, aber ich bleibe trotzdem dabei. Ich will nur sagen, die Formate, die in den letzten Jahren entwickelt wurden für Fernsehsender, Podcasts, YouTube, waren alle darauf aus, dass man Konfrontation hat.
Absolut. Keiner braucht Konfrontation. Heiratet früh.
Es sei denn, wir diskutieren über Free Speech, dann brauchen wir natürlich Konfrontation.
Absolut. Okay.
Über 100.000 Menschen haben in London demonstriert gegen die Migrationspolitik. Wir hören jetzt zunächst einmal ein paar Clips aus dem Ronzheimer Podcast. Dort spricht Philipp Jartoff über die Situation in Großbritannien.
Briten ja raus sind aus der Europäischen Union, weil sie die Kontrolle zurückerlangen wollten, auch über ihre Grenzen. Das war zumindest das Versprechen der konservativen Tories, von Boris Johnson, der ja auch Premierminister wurde. Tja und dann haben sie so ein bisschen an den Schrauben gedreht, um eine neue Migrationspolitik sich so ein bisschen einzustellen und dann begann es. Also die Briten erleben aktuell die größte Migrationswelle aller Zeiten.
Klingt komisch, ist aber so. Man wollte eigentlich weniger Migranten haben. Deswegen müssen wir uns von der EU auch lösen. Die macht die Grenzen nicht genügend dicht. Wir müssen daraus take back control. Was passiert zum Beispiel?
Pakistan, Indien, aus Zimbabwe und und und. Und man wollte, dass sie kommen, aber man wollte nicht, dass so viele kommen. Und man hat das auch gar nicht kommen gesehen, dass so viele kommen könnten. Also ein Beispiel, die Regierung hat angenommen, dass 6000 Pfleger pro Jahr kommen würden. Und dann sind innerhalb von vier Jahren fast 700.000 Menschen gekommen.
Hat man sich ein bisschen verschätzt. Hat falsch kalkuliert. Also wir sind hier bei der Ära Boris Johnson. Man spricht von der Boris Johnson Wave. Der hat das also ausgelöst. Das heißt, wir sind gerade in einer Situation, in der Sozialdemokraten regieren, also Labour regiert. Die konservativen Tories haben die Grenzen geöffnet, in einem Maße, wie das noch nicht dagewesen ist. Und jetzt gibt es noch Nigel Farage, der völlig abgemeldet war, dieses Brexit-Ungeheuer, der aber jetzt wieder da ist und in manchen Prognosen schon ganz vorne steht. Wir hören uns da mal noch eine Zahl an.
Das Wall Street Journal hat letztens über diese Migrationskrise in dem Vereinigten Königreich berichtet und da hieß es, dass vier Prozent der aktuellen Bevölkerung in den vergangenen vier Jahren gekommen sind.
Vier Prozent der aktuellen Bevölkerung sind in den letzten Jahren gekommen. Bedeutet also, da gibt es wirklich ein Problem im Sinne von, das kann ja gar nicht funktionieren. In dieser Masse, zumal die Tories sich einfach nicht darum entsprechend gekümmert haben, und wir kennen das Chaos-Kabinett von Boris Johnson, wir können uns das lebhaft vorstellen, wie irre es dazu gegangen ist, folglich hat also diese Anti-Migrations-Bewegung, hat auch der Rassismus gerade einen sehr guten Nährboden bekommen. Wir gehen aber jetzt erstmal weit weg von London und wir hören uns wirklich ein herausragendes Feature an, man sollte das sich ganz anhören am besten. Vom Deutschlandfunk Thomas Kroochem hat ein Feature gemacht zum Thema Pflege, zwar national wie international. Können wir jetzt einfach Pflegekräfte aus dem Ausland nehmen? Sollten wir das tun? Wie sollten wir das tun? Und er kommt dabei auch auf Großbritannien zu sprechen. Wir hören uns das an. Es ist so interessant. Man könnte sich im Prinzip 100 Clips davon machen. Wir hören uns jetzt so 20 etwa an. Also beginnen wir.
Der junge Kenianer Willis Omwola hat sich um einen Job als Krankenpfleger in Süddeutschland beworben. Zunächst aber muss er Deutsch lernen an der Sprachschule DE German Institute in Nairobi.
Aus Leidenschaft habe ich diese Ausbildung ausgewählt.
Helena Mbanda ist schon einen Schritt weiter. Die Kenianerin absolviert eine Ausbildung zur Pflegekraft im baden-württembergischen Bad Mergentheim.
Mir gefällt es, wenn nicht andere Leute helfen.
Das ist erstmal der Einstieg. Wie sieht die Situation in Deutschland aus?
Allein in Deutschlands Krankenhäusern, Altenheimen und Privathaushalten fehlen schon heute 100.000 Pflegekräfte, schätzt der Deutsche Pflegerat.
Die Prognose?
Bis 2034 könnten eine halbe Million Kräfte fehlen. Und danach, wenn die sogenannten Babyboomer ins Pflegealter kommen, noch weit mehr.
Aber wir schaffen jetzt den Pflegegrad 1 ab.
Ja, ich wollte es gerade nennen. Ich habe es nämlich hier liegen. Man hat tatsächlich die Idee, Geld zu sparen, indem man sagt, man schafft den Pflegegrad 1 ab. Also das ist laut Bildzeitung. Davon werden 860.000 Menschen betroffen. Und das ist ja wirklich so eine kleine Finanzspritze, die man bekommt. Also Pflegegrad 1 bedeutet, dass man 131 Euro im Monat zur Verfügung gestellt bekommt, um zum Beispiel dann auch eine Einkaufshilfe oder so zu haben. Aber da gibt es jetzt die Idee, wenn man das einfach wegkürzt, dann könnten dadurch so zwei Milliarden oder was gespart werden insgesamt. 1,8 Milliarden Euro will man sparen und glaubt dann wird schon alles besser. Also das ist auch so eine Pflegegrad 1 wird überhaupt nur gezahlt, wenn zum Beispiel schon eine Demenz da ist, also eine leicht anfangende Demenz. Dann gibt es solche Hilfen und dann denkt man noch, vielleicht schaffen die Leute das auch noch so irgendwie.
Ich würde mal sagen, über diesen Pflegegrad hat man sich dadurch, dass das ja eh relativ neu war, sehr viele Gedanken gemacht. Während viele andere politische Entscheidungen, die man so mitschleppt, von vielleicht vor 100 Jahren getroffen wurden. Also in der Hinsicht muss man das gar nicht rechtfertigen.
Nee, das ist Wahnsinn. Ja, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, es werden aber doch wahnsinnig viele Leute ausgebildet in Deutschland zu Pflegekraft. Wie kann das sein? Wo bleiben die denn dann?
Schon in den ersten fünf Jahren nach der Ausbildung verlasse jede vierte Pflegekraft ihren Beruf, berichtet Christian Lebrenz, Professor für Personalmanagement an der Hochschule Koblenz.
Lange Zeit war Pflege unattraktiv wegen der geringen Vergütung. Das hat sich in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren deutlich geändert, sodass, was die finanziellen Rahmenbedingungen angeht, die Pflege durchaus attraktiv ist im Vergleich zu anderen Ausbildungsberufen. Was aber immer noch schwierig ist, ist dieser Teufelskreis durch Pflegenotstand oder Pflegemangel, sehr hohe Arbeitsbelastung, hoher Stresslevel.
Es ist also die Belastung, gar nicht so sehr die Bezahlung, die dafür sorgt, dass Leute aus diesem Beruf recht schnell wieder aussteigen. Dann könnte man ja sagen, wir nehmen einfach Menschen aus dem globalen Süden. Und da beginnt jetzt das größere Problem, das in diesem Feature aufgearbeitet wird.
Das Problem? Auch im globalen Süden herrscht ein großer Mangel an Gesundheitsfachkräften. Nach einer Prognose der Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO werden 2030 weltweit rund 10 Millionen Kräfte fehlen, vor allem in Afrika.
Es gibt also dort viele Menschen, aber die Pflegekräfte sind dennoch rar gesät.
Dort gibt es, so die WHO, gerade 15 Gesundheitsfachkräfte pro 10.000 Einwohner. In Deutschland sind es 724, fast 50 mal so viel.
Also das war jetzt eine Zahl aus afrikanischen Ländern.
Ein bizarres Missverhältnis, das sich weiter verschärft. Durch die Abwanderung von Fachkräften in den globalen Norden und durch die auch in Afrika beginnende Alterung der Gesellschaft.
Ja, also diese Alterung in afrikanischen Ländern hängt ja auch mit diesem wirtschaftlichen Prosperieren zusammen, was ja eh wieder die Schwelle anhebt zum das Land verlassen und so weiter. Von daher ist das eh, ich habe bei meinen Abendveranstaltungen zur Alten Republik immer gefragt, können wir uns das vorstellen, hier eine Million Nigerianer, die uns das Problem vom Hals schaffen, nur die wollen natürlich auch immer weniger kommen, wenn die Attraktivität in dem eigenen Land steigt und ein Indikator Lebenserwartung steigt. Du hast es ja gerade für Amerika mit umgedrehtem Vorzeichen. Das ist eben ein klarer Indikator dafür, dass man da dann doch vielleicht auch gerne lebt und sein Leben plant und so weiter.
Beziehungsweise ja, die Bezahlung ist natürlich immer noch deutlich besser und die Zustände sind auch häufig sehr viel besser.
Ich will nur dieses große Panorama-Thema, denn wir haben die Hälfte der Länder der Welt schrumpfen. Und vom afrikanischen Kontinent wissen wir, ist die aktuelle Prognose immer noch, also die Bevölkerung wächst von 1,5 Milliarden auf 4,5 Milliarden. Also da kommt sozusagen das ganze weltweite Bevölkerungswachstum findet nur in afrikanischen Ländern statt und dort recht viel. Und eigentlich war das immer die große politische Hoffnung. Es gab auch Bücher dazu, dass sich jedes europäische Land ein Partnerland sucht und man das dann so ein bisschen intensiviert, die Afrikanische Union zur EU einlädt und so.
Und Partnerstädte gibt es ja dann auch noch mal.
Genau solche Sachen, dass sich das so richtig, dass man einfach völlig normal sagt, ja klar geht unsere Tochter zum Auslandsjahr nach Nairobi und so. Nur das findet ja alles gar nicht statt. Was aber stattfindet ist die Prosperität Afrikas. Und damit fällt sozusagen das allerletzte Zuzugsgebiet und damit auch die letzte Hoffnung Europas, nachdem Osteuropa leergeplündert wurde, Asien eigentlich immer zu weit weg und kulturell auch merkwürdig. Hätte man eben mit afrikanischen Ländern klären müssen. Jetzt wird die Schlinge so ein bisschen weiter zugezogen.
Ja und wir haben zugleich Brain Drain.
Ist es vor diesem Hintergrund vertretbar, wenn reiche Länder wie Deutschland Gesundheitsfachkräfte im globalen Süden rekrutieren?
Das hatten wir schon immer. Das haben wir auch in Osteuropa. Das hat noch niemanden interessiert. Das wäre ja kein Hinterungsgrund.
Ja, aber es gibt tatsächlich ja da auch Maßgaben, an die man sich halten könnte. Oder es gibt Wege, wie man es anders machen kann. Ein Pflegeleiter aus Kakuma, also im Norden von Kenia, kommt hier zu Wort.
Von meinen Mitarbeitern in diesem Krankenhaus haben sich schon zwei Drittel um einen Job im Ausland beworben, weil sie sich hier überfordert fühlen, konfrontiert mit einfach zu vielen Patienten und ohne Ressourcen sie zu behandeln. Gute und erfahrene Kräfte. Aber sie halten es hier nicht aus und können ihre Familien nicht ernähren. Deshalb gehen sie nach Europa.
Wie steht Kenias Regierung dazu?
Kenias Regierung hat die Abwerbung medizinischer Fachkräfte lange Zeit kritisch gesehen. Seit dem Amtsantritt von Präsident William Ruto 2022 jedoch, fördert sie die Abwanderung als Baustein einer Strategie, Kenias Arbeitsmarkt zu entlasten und durch Geldtransfers der Emigranten an ihre Familie die Wiesen ins Land zu holen.
Man sagt sich also, die sind im Ausland, verdienen dort Geld, schicken was nach Hause, das macht uns dann auch ein bisschen reicher. Kenya setzt dabei auf bilaterale Abkommen.
Am 1. Mai 2025 betonte Ruto in einer öffentlichen Rede, Kenya könne derzeit nur 200.000 der eine Million jährlich neu auf den Arbeitsmarkt drängenden Arbeitskräfte beschäftigen.
Arbeitsmigration ist deshalb eine entscheidende Komponente unserer sozioökonomischen Entwicklung. Sie hilft sowohl Kenya als auch den Ländern, die unsere Arbeitskräfte aufnehmen. Und um die Arbeitsmigration zu fördern, schließen wir bilaterale Abkommen dazu ab. Solche Abkommen ermöglichen eine sichere und geordnete Arbeitsmigration. Sie schützen die Rechte kenianischer Fachkräfte im Ausland und erleichtern ihnen den Zugang zum internationalen Arbeitsmarkt.
Das gibt es dann auch für Deutschland.
Am 13. September 2024 unterzeichneten in Berlin Regierungsvertreter Deutschlands und Kenias ein Abkommen zur Arbeitsmigration. Es soll Kenianern den Zugang zum deutschen Arbeitsmarkt erleichtern, insbesondere Pflegekräften.
Das Problem ist, dass häufig sehr unseriöse Vermittlungsagenturen dazwischen stehen. Hier mal ein Beispiel.
Unseriöse Vermittlungspraktiken zeichnen sich ja dadurch aus, dass die Kandidaten Sprachkurse, Reisekosten, Dokumenten, Übersetzungskosten, solche Dinge alles selber bezahlen müssen. Und dann ist es nämlich auch möglich, dass der Arbeitgeber ein ganz günstiges Angebot bekommt. Und da muss man sich dann natürlich hinterfragen, ist das denn seriös, beziehungsweise wer bezahlt eigentlich die Kosten, die damit verbunden sind?
Die sind damit dann doppelt ausgebeutete. Und der Westen greift da gerne drauf zurück, ist also eine neue Form von Kolonialismus, könnte man sagen. Wir besuchen jetzt Nairobi in diesem Feature.
Besuch bei Dennis Miskela in Nairobi. Er arbeitet in einem etwas heruntergekommenen Bürogebäude, dessen Aufzug kaputt ist. Treppen steigen in den fünften Stock. Miskela ist Gynäkologe und Chef der Ärztegewerkschaft KMPDU. Es sei ein Märchen, dass die Immigration medizinischer Fachkräfte Arbeitslosigkeit in Kenia bekämpfe, sagt er spöttisch. Krankenhäuser und Pflegeheime im globalen Norden seien ausschließlich an den besten Köpfen interessiert, an hochqualifizierten und hochspezialisierten Fachkräften mit reichlich Berufserfahrung in guten Krankenhäusern.
Vor allem US-Krankenhäuser holen sich unsere Pflegekräfte, speziell ausgebildete Kräfte, die sich in der Krebsbehandlung auskennen, in der Intensivmedizin, im OP. Tausende sind es jedes Jahr.
Ich kenne ein Krankenhaus in Nairobi, das Woche für Woche sieben Pflegekräfte verliert. Das heißt, Nairobi ohnehin kein reiches Land bildet Leute aus, macht sie sogar zu Experten, die dann im Ausland gefragt werden und dort hingehen, weil das für sie ein enormer wirtschaftlicher Fortschritt ist, für Nairobi zum Problem wird. Vor allem dann, wenn ja keine Kompensation dafür gezahlt werden muss. Das heißt, die Ausbildung erhalten dann die Unternehmen im Westen quasi gratis. Die ist ja schon vollzogen worden in Nairobi und dann kann man einfach die so rauspicken. Und das hört man ja auch sehr häufig jetzt, wenn so über Fachkräfte geredet wird. Man möchte ja gar nicht hier Menschen hinholen, die man erstmal ausbildet groß, sondern man hätte ja gerne die reifen Früchte, die man dann nur noch sich in den Korb legen muss, um das mal im übertragenen Sinne zu sagen.
Das ist ja die Standard-rassistische Migrationspolitik von vor allem der FDP, die ja immer, die Christian Dürr noch im Kopf und auch Lindner selber, mit diesem, ja, aber sie müssen es auch verstehen, wir brauchen natürlich Fachkräfte und so.
Ja, aber bitte mit Doktortitel schon.
Genau.
Ja, es ist ein absurdes Agenturgeschäft.
Und keine Agentur nimmt frisch ausgebildete Kräfte. Nein, sie wollen nur die Besten der Besten, die dann hohe Gebühren zahlen müssen. Und wenn sie kein Geld haben, werden ihnen die Gebühren von ihrem Lohn in den USA abgezogen.
Ich kenne Leute, die drei Jahre lang 70 Prozent ihres Lohns an die Agentur abdrücken mussten.
Bei Branko Milanovic können wir ja nachlesen, wie ungleich die Welt ist. Der schaut sich ja dann die Einkommen immer an und vergleicht die. Und dann kommt man natürlich an den Punkt, bei dem man sagt, da ist also der Bürgergeldempfänger immer noch weit über dem Niveau, wie das in vielen afrikanischen Ländern der Fall ist. Und hier kann man auch sehen, also die 30 Prozent in den USA, die man nur erhält, weil man 70 Prozent abgeben muss an der Agentur. Drei Jahre lang rechnen sich immer noch mehr als dort zu bleiben in Nairobi. Und das ist natürlich eine Struktur, die so harte Fakten schafft, dass es für diese Länder immer schwieriger wird, überhaupt dann den Aufstieg zu schaffen, wenn jetzt die Leute weggenommen werden. Zugleich brauchen wir sie. Und muss es ja auch ein digitimes Ansinnen sein, der Menschen dort zu sagen, ich würde aber gerne woanders arbeiten, zum Beispiel in Europa. Die Frage ist nur dann, wie wird was kompensiert? Du kannst ja nochmal Zahlen anschauen.
Das ist gar nicht so wenig. Wir blicken aber jetzt nach Großbritannien. Ist das nicht so wenig? Ich weiß nicht, seit... 55.000 ausgebildete Ärzte?
Wenn die jetzt gesagt hätten, 500.000, dann... Okay, aber ich meine, es ist schon... Also wir reden über die ganze Welt.
Aber das sind ausgebildete Ärzte.
Das heißt also 55.000 Mal wurden da ausgebildete Ärzte ausgebildet. Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen...
Aber es ist schon ein bisschen...
Es ist schon ein bisschen...
Es ist schon ein bisschen... Es ist schon ein bisschen...
Das heißt also 55.000 Mal wurden da Ausbildungen bezahlt. Das ist schon aufwendig. Und die Ärztedichte ist ja viel viel geringer als jetzt hier.
Also bei 15 pro 10.000 Einwohner, also ja, da ist 55.000 entführt.
So muss man es rechnen. An sich gibt es natürlich viel viel mehr Ärzte.
Besonders offene Türen finden afrikanische Fachkräfte in Großbritannien. Mit dem Brexit zum 1. Januar 2021 verschlechterte sich dort schlagartig die Situation von Gesundheitsfachkräften aus der EU. Ihre Freizügigkeit entfiel. Ab sofort brauchten sie ein spezielles Visum, um in Großbritannien zu arbeiten. Außerdem mussten sie nun in komplizierten Verfahren ihre Berufsabschlüsse anerkennen lassen.
Die Briten wollten weniger EU und bekamen mehr Afrika.
Ja, dass die Briten 2016 den Brexit gemacht haben. Seit zehn Jahren das ganze Ding zum Tabu erklären. Ja. Und jetzt, kurz davor, sind Nigel Farage mehr zum Thema, bitte einfach nicht mehr politisch diskutieren, okay? Kann man gar nicht sagen.
Also die Briten sind doof, wenn ich mir das mal so allgemein erlauben darf zu sagen.
Ja, das soll ich auch sagen.
Innerhalb eines Jahres nach dem Brexit sank, nach einer Erhebung der Denkfabrik Nuffield Trust, die Zahl der in Großbritannien neu registrierten Pflegekräfte aus der EU um 93 Prozent.
Oh, Wunder.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
93 Prozent weniger.
Aber wenn die jetzt alle, weil da so große Lücken sind und die Polen nicht mehr in Großbritannien arbeiten, nach Großbritannien ziehen, weil Kenianer denken, da kann ich Englisch sprechen, das ist ein leichter Einstieg in die westliche Welt, dann stellen sie dort fest irgendwie ungemütlich und kommen dann mit britischer Arbeitserfahrung nach Deutschland. Dann haben wir natürlich einen kleinen Benefit daraus geschlagen. Wir haben ja aus vielen Brexit-Sachen einen kleinen Benefit geschlagen.
Ja, das britische Gesundheitssystem steckt in der Krise.
Oh ja.
Verschärft wird die Pflegekrise in Großbritannien durch die auch dort fortschreitende Alterung der Gesellschaft und strukturelle Probleme des seit Jahrzehnten kriselnden staatlichen Gesundheitsdienstes NHS, erklärt Sebastian Rees, Gesundheitsexperte des britischen ThinkTanks Institute for Public Policy Research.
Großbritannien hat in den letzten Jahren nur wenig in die Ausbildung medizinischer Fachkräfte investiert. Eine Rekrutierung im Ausland ist einfacher und die boomt auch deshalb, weil unserem Gesundheitsdienst NHS immer mehr einheimische Ärzte und Pflegekräfte davonlaufen. Bezahlung und Arbeitsbedingungen sind für die einfach zu schlecht.
Die gigantischen Lücken in seinem Personalbestand versucht der NHS nun, um jeden Preis zu schließen. Vorwiegend mit Fachkräften aus afrikanischen Ländern, die auf einer roten Liste stehen.
Es ist so verrückt, wenn man sich das mal vergegenwärtigt. Also die haben das Gesundheitssystem inzwischen so schlecht ausgestattet, dass da die Leute, die dort gearbeitet haben, sagen, das tue ich mir nicht mehr an, ich gehe da raus. Dann sagen sie, aus der EU wollen wir aber jetzt nicht mehr die Pflegekräfte haben, beziehungsweise wir machen eine Konstruktion, die so kompliziert ist, dass die nicht mehr kommen. Und dann rekrutiert man aus afrikanischen Ländern. Und wenn sie dann da sind, dann organisiert man das sowieso nicht richtig und weiß auch gar nicht, wie sind die Bedarfe und setzt die eigentlich jetzt fortwährend einem Rassismus von der Straße aus, für den die Briten selbst verantwortlich ist, dass sie sich in diese Misere hineingebracht haben.
Also der NHS ist so in der Krise, dass die Zahl der Menschen, die auf einen Arzttermin warten, in Millionen gemessen wird. Und teilweise Top-Thema in der BBC News Night ist. Ja. So wie wir über Bürgergeldempfänger oder so reden.
Diese rote Liste, was ist denn das?
Diese rote Liste des globalen Verhaltenskodex der Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO für die internationale Rekrutierung von Gesundheitspersonal nennt 55 Länder mit extremen Mangel an Gesundheitspersonal. Darunter 37 aus Afrika. Industrieländer sollen deshalb in diesen Ländern keine Fachkräfte rekrutieren.
Genau das aber tut der NHS. Allein 2021, im Jahr nach dem Brexit, unterschrieben 14.000 Pflegekräfte aus den rote Listeländern Nigeria, Ghana und Zimbabwe Arbeitsverträge in Großbritannien.
Na, das wär's ja noch, wenn man aus dem Brexit aussteigt, um sich an diese Regularien nicht mehr zu halten und dann eine UN-Liste befolgt.
Aber wir sehen also, man kann nicht einfach diesen Transfer machen, sondern es gibt da schon eine rote Liste, von der ich noch nie gehört hatte, dass man sagt, okay, da gibt es einen erheblichen Mangel. Jetzt fragen sich viele, ja, aber es gibt auch ganz viele Leute, wie kann der Mangel da sein? Ja, weil diese Länder finanziell so schlecht ausgestattet sind, dass sie natürlich gar nicht eine flächendeckte Ausbildungsstruktur anbieten können. Und die wenigen, die dann eine Ausbildung bekommen oder sich das vielleicht leisten können, weil sie aus etwas besseren Familien kommen, also Familien mit etwas mehr Geld kommen, die sind dann vielleicht sogar bereit, das Land wieder zu verlassen. Das bedeutet also, die Ferien dann sehr schnell wieder werden ausgebildet und gehen. Wir gehen mal nach Zimbabwe.
Und der Exodus geht weiter. Aus Zimbabwe berichtet David Colthard, Bürgermeister der zweitgrößten Stadt Bulawayo.
Wegen unseres niedrigen Gesundheitsbudgets bezahlen wir unsere Pflegekräfte und Ärzte katastrophal schlecht und erleben deshalb einen massiven Brain Drain nach Großbritannien. Das zeigt eine triviale Tatsache, von der mir Mitarbeiter der britischen Botschaft in Harare erzählt haben. Zimbabwe, die in Großbritannien arbeiten wollen, müssen bei der Botschaft eine Englischprüfung ablegen, haben sie mir erklärt. Früher hätten sich 2.000 Personen jährlich für diese Prüfung gemeldet. Letztes Jahr waren es über 20.000 und die meisten von ihnen Gesundheitsfachkräfte.
Wie verhält sich Deutschland dazu?
Tatsächlich beschäftigen auch deutsche Krankenhäuser und Pflegeheime zahlreiche Pflegekräfte aus Ländern auf der roten WHO-Liste. Allein in den Pandemiejahren 2020 bis 2022 stieg deren Zahl um durchschnittlich rund 50 Prozent. Auf 1.700 Kräfte zum Beispiel aus Nigeria, 1.000 aus Zimbabwe, 1.800 aus Madagaskar und 900 aus Ghana.
Ja, unsere Impfung bekommt ihr nicht gratis, aber wir hätten gerne gratis die Pflegekräfte dann hier. Zugleich gibt es die zerbrochenen Familien. Wir haben das ja auch, das Gesetz, Familiennachzug wird gestoppt und das ist ja nicht nur hier der Fall.
Wenn von einem Ehepaar die Frau ins Ausland geht und der Mann bleibt mit den Kindern zurück, zerbricht unweigerlich die Familie. Und die Kinder wachsen in einer zerbrochenen Familie auf. Ich bin deshalb sehr enttäuscht darüber, dass die britische Regierung seit Kurzem keine Visa mehr an Ehepartner und Kinder ausländischer Gesundheitsfachkräfte vergibt. Die Briten zerbrechen so ganz bewusst Familien. Und nichts anderes tun die USA. Bei denen darf zwar der Ehepartner mit einreisen, aber er darf nicht arbeiten.
Da werden dann die Republikaner wieder was draus machen, dass die ja alle Frauen sind und nicht arbeiten.
Oder eher Eis vorgefahren werden, ist es egal.
Ja.
Oh je.
Die Ausbildungskosten nochmal.
Zudem weigerten sich die Industrieländer, afrikanischen Ländern Ausbildungskosten, für hier rekrutierte Fachkräfte zu erstatten, sagt Miss Kehler bitter.
Könnte man ja machen, für jeden hunderttausend Euro oder was auch immer.
Das ist ja eh mein Argument, auch beim Zuzug aus der Familie in den Arbeitsmarkt, dass man nicht sagt, ah, ich kann Menschen einstellen und muss keine Maschine kaufen, cool, dann spare ich mir drei Millionen und zahle einfach im ersten Monat tausend Euro.
Ja, jaja.
Das könnte man hier auch, dass man das alles rückwirkend vergütet. Also wenn man aus Deutschland auswandert, sich ummeldet, muss man ja so eine Wegzugssteuer zahlen. Das ist natürlich eine, die das Geberland, das Superreichen, die wir nicht gehen lassen möchten. Aber ja, man kann es nicht über EU und Afrikanische Union Gipfel klären, sondern das müssten die afrikanischen Länder von sich aus proaktiv und auch gemeinsam. Sie sehen ja, wenn 37 Länder von 45 auf der roten Liste aus Afrika sind, wahrscheinlich deckt sich das ein bisschen mit der afrikanischen Union Mitgliedschaft.
Ja, da könnte man eigentlich was machen. Aber stattdessen geht der Kolonialismus weiter.
Großbritannien, Kanada und Australien zum Beispiel hätten den Codex des Commonwealth Secretariat zur Rekrutierung von Gesundheitsfachkräften nicht unterschrieben, weil dieser Codex die Erstattung der Ausbildungskosten vorsieht. Und auch Deutschland vermeide in seinem bilateralen Migrationsabkommen mit Kenia jedes Wort zur Erstattung von Ausbildungskosten.
In Ihren bilateralen Migrationsabkommen mit Kenia sollten die Industrieländer zumindest eine Erstattung der Ausbildungskosten verankern. Mit dem Geld könnte unsere Regierung dann die Ausbildung bei uns verbessern, zum beiderseitigen Vorteil. Was zurzeit geschieht, begünstigt einfach nur den globalen Norden.
Gibt es einen Weg, die Abwanderung von afrikanischen Pflegekräften in die Industrieländer fairer zu gestalten? So, dass auch die Heimatländer davon profitieren?
Wir haben das ja gerade gesagt, mit den Zahlungen gibt es diese Möglichkeit. Aber dann sind ja immer noch die Pflegekräfte, die ausgebildet wurden oder die Ärzte weg. Die sind ja dann nicht mehr da. Dann gibt es 50.000 oder 100.000 Euro, aber sind sie nicht da. Es gibt aber noch eine Möglichkeit. Denn wir haben es schon mehrmals betont, aber es gibt auch viele Menschen dort. Die können sich aber keine Ausbildung leisten oder bekommen nicht die Möglichkeit. Was wäre also zu tun? Eigentlich ganz einfach.
Suche nach einer Antwort im Caritas-Krankenhaus der baden-württembergischen Kleinstadt Bad Mergentheim. In ihre Heimat Kenia, erzählt Pflegeschülerin Helena Mbanda, müsse man für ein Studium oder eine Berufsausbildung bezahlen. Das war zu teuer für sie. Eine Weile hielt sie sich mit Gelegenheitsjobs über Wasser.
Dann aber hörte Helena von einem Pilotprojekt der Mount Kenya University, der Universität Koblenz und des Krankenhauses in Bad Mergentheim. Ausbildung zur Pflegekraft in Deutschland, ohne dafür bezahlen zu müssen.
Aha, man kann also Menschen, die gerne eigentlich eine Ausbildung machen würden, aber in ihrem Land keine Chance haben, sagen, hier könnt ihr die aber machen. Und dann habt ihr hier eine berufliche Perspektive.
Und dann, wer zahlt das genau?
Das zahlt halt Deutschland dann. Beziehungsweise, die bekommen ein Angebot, hier zu arbeiten. Und dann ist natürlich der Ausbildungsbetrieb zahlt. Da wird sicherlich das noch bezuschusst werden, entsprechend. Das muss ja auch erstmal organisiert werden, die Reise. Das wird jetzt nicht im Einzelnen alles ausgeführt. Aber das sorgt eben dafür, dass niemand fertig ausgebildet einfach weggeschnappt wird. Sondern man sagt, ja, wir finanzieren die Ausbildung. Und zwar auch direkt hier. Also ich finde, das ist wirklich ein sehr gutes Feature von Thomas Kuchen, weil das so gut miteinander verzahnt ist. Die Leiterin des Projekts kommt jetzt zu Wort.
Wir nehmen Kenia keine fertigen ausgebildeten Pflegekräfte weg, sondern wir schaffen eine Möglichkeit für junge Leute, die dort keine Ausbildung bekommen könnten, hier in Deutschland eine sehr gute pflegerische Ausbildung zu bieten.
Das ist ja das, was ich immer gefordert habe, dass man hier einfach Leute importiert und die durch das eigene Integrationsbildungssystem schickt. Dann hätte man sie auch so ausgebildet. Das ist sozusagen Win-Win-Win-Win.
Nur leicht ist es auch für die hier in Deutschland nicht. Hier kommen sie mal zu Wort.
Aber immer wieder erleben sie auch Rassismus im Arbeitsalltag.
Ich wollte irgendwas bei einem Patienten machen und er wollte nicht von mir versorgt werden, weil ich dunkel bin. Dann hat er zu dem anderen Kollegen gesagt, ich will nicht von der dunkelhäutigen Schwester versorgt werden. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, es gibt andere Patienten, die brauchen Hilfe, nicht nur ihm. Am Anfang, das war ganz schwierig, habe ich gefragt, warum mich, warum nicht die anderen? Ich muss stark bleiben und wenn die Tage zu schwer sind, dann habe ich einer von meinen Freunden in die Klasse, dann trüfe ich jemanden an und ich erzähle, was passiert ist und wir bleiben stark zusammen.
Ja, also ich verstehe das nicht, wie man Hilfe, also man liegt schon in so einem Krankenbett und weiß, ich brauche hier Hilfe, ich kann es nicht selber, schon allein der Kompetenz wegen, was auch immer. Und dann sagt man, nee, nicht von dir. Was macht man in der Notarzt-Situation? Ich weiß nicht, also ich... Du siehst, der eine Krankenwagen ist da und dann steckt die eine Ärztin aus. Dann sagst du, nee, sorry, ich brauche einen anderen, oder?
Ja, lieber einen Mann. Ja, also ich bin auch da erstaunt, dass man da so ruhig bleiben kann. Ich würde wahrscheinlich das Kissen drauf drücken, aber naja. Springen wir zurück nach England. Erstmal mit einer Zahl aus der Financial Times. Sie haben ja so eine Grafik veröffentlicht. Da geht es darum, wie die Löhne sich entwickelt haben. Adam Toos hatte die aufgegriffen, diese Grafik, und diese Zahlen sind unglaublich. Es geht also da um die Living Standards Review von 2025, und da schaute man sich die Pro-Kopf-Einkommen in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten in Großbritannien an und kann feststellen, dass zwischen 1990 und 2007 die Einkommen um 48 Prozent gestiegen sind insgesamt in der Zeitspanne.
In welcher Zeitspanne?
1990 bis 2007. Geht man aber von 2007 bis in die Gegenwart, stellt man fest, da sind sie nur um 14 Prozent gestiegen. Wenn man sich diesen Lohntrend ansieht, wie er in den 90er Jahren begann, müssten eigentlich die Haushalte pro Quartal 2000 Pfund mehr haben, pro Kopf Einkommen 2000 Pfund mehr. Man ist aber bei 6000. Also das ist so drastisch und generell steht hier noch, laut IWF betrug das Trendwachstum des BEP pro Kopf im Vereinigten Königreich von 1990 bis 2007 2,5 Prozent pro Jahr. Zwischen 2008 und 2025 lag es dann bei nur 0,7 Prozent. Dieser Rückgang der Wachstumsrate um 1,8 Prozentpunkte war der größte in der Gruppe der sieben Länder mit hohem Einkommen. Infolgedessen wird das britische Pro Kopf BEP im Jahr 2025 voraussichtlich um 33 Prozent niedriger ausfallen, als es bei einer Fortsetzung des Trendwachstums von 1990 bis 2007 der Fall gewesen wäre. Die Lage ist katastrophal. Man könnte also jetzt sehr viel über Ökonomie, Umverteilung, Ungleichheit, all das reden. Aber nein, man redet jetzt über Migration. Ja, da läuft natürlich auch gerade sehr viel schief. Also wenn Boris Johnson sagt, take back control und dann sagt, wie viele Pflegekräfte? 7000, 700.000. Ich habe gerade nicht so richtig zugehört. Also Wohnungsnot ist ja da auch ein ganz großes Thema. Und dann zu sagen, wir nehmen mal eine Million, mal schauen, was wir dann wieder machen. Es ist nur Chaos, aber es wird jetzt die Wut natürlich entladen, vor allem an den Migranten. Wir hören jetzt mal hier gerade Tagesschau 24 über die Demonstration in London.
Das Thema Einwanderung hat heute Zehntausende in Großbritannien auf die Straße gebracht. In London folgen sie dem Aufruf United.
Ich spring mal kurz zurück.
Ja.
Da rennt jemand mit dem Charlie Kirk-Bild rum in London, weil jetzt alles, alles ist und wir hier ganz wichtig über solche Sachen diskutieren müssen.
Es wurde bei diesen Protesten auch viel für Charlie Kirk gebetet.
Also jetzt mal das einfache Szenario, ne?
Ja.
Man sitzt zu Hause an seinem Küchentisch, hat ein Smartphone, das kostet 100 Euro, der heute billig und ein Gemini-kostenlosen-Account. Und man fragt Gemini, ich möchte gern aufklären, warum ich mich so unzufrieden fühle. Kannst du mir entsprechende Fragen stellen? Lass uns einen Quiz machen. Gemini so, klar, hier, hast du einen Quiz, zack. Nach zehn Minuten wäre man doch komplett aufgeklärt über das eigene Schicksal.
Wie können in dieser Zeit überhaupt noch Leute auf die Straße gehen, in England mit einem Charlie Kirk-Bild, um irgendwas zum Thema Migration einzufordern?
Ja, wir werden jetzt aber gleich sehen. Es gibt ja noch jemand, der ist noch irre als Charlie Kirk, würde ich mal fast behaupten....
Zehntausende in Großbritannien auf die Straße gebracht. In London folgten sie dem Aufruf Unite the Kingdom des rechtsextremen Aktivisten Tommy Robinson. Die Demonstrierenden fordern ein Ende der Migration nach Großbritannien. Die Teilnehmer gedachten auch, dass am Mittwoch in den USA ermordeten rechtsnationalen Aktivisten Kirk. Es gab auch groß angelegte Gegenproteste. Die Polizei hatte 1600 Einsatzkräfte in die britische Hauptstadt geschickt. Und darüber spreche ich jetzt mit Valerika in London. Wie ist im Moment die Lage?
Dieser große Protest ist mittlerweile in Whitehall, also im Regierungsviertel nördlich der Themse angekommen. Dort sind einige große Leinwände aufgebaut. Und die Demonstrierenden hören jetzt verschiedene Redner sprechen. Was extrem aufhält bei diesen Bildern, ist ein Flaggenmeer von St. Georgs Flaggen. Also nicht der Union Jack, den gibt es auch, aber vor allen Dingen die englische Flagge, die über den ganzen Sommer schon immer mehr von Rechtsaußenbewegungen aufgehängt gezeigt wurde, um eben diese englische Identität zu betonen und sich gegen Migration auszusprechen. Es gibt viele Schilder mit Stop the Boats und schickt sie zurück. Also klare Äußerungen vor allen Dingen gegen Asylsuchende, die ja schon seit Jahren immer mit in Booten über den Ärmelkanal nach Großbritannien kommen. Also diese Anti-Migrations-Botschaft ist sehr, sehr stark zu sehen. Und anfangs hieß es, dass es einige Zehntausende Teilnehmer sind. Die letzten Infos von der Polizei sind sogar, dass es mehr als hunderttausende, also etwa hundertzehntausende sein können. Das scheint also wirklich einer der größten Proteste dieser Art zu sein.
Ach, wer genau hat denn zu diesem Protest aufgerufen?
Ja, da flog eine Kamera drüber. Wir haben jetzt gerade Straßen voller Leute gesehen. Die Flakken machen den Unterschied. So sieht die Frankfurter Innenstadt jeden Samstag auch aus. Also man könnte da auch drüber fliegen und sagen, okay, es ist ein Happening. Nur würde ich jetzt, also es wäre super interessant, wenn wir jetzt sagen, in England ist es die Migration, die die so auf die Straße treibt. In Amerika ist es Charlie Kirk. Dort dreht das die Regierung direkt in so ein religiöses Ding. Nun haben hier die Leute gerade keine Regierungsverantwortung, aber da stehen trotzdem mehrere Leinwände. Er wird die dann aufgebaut. Das kostet ja auch alles wahnsinnig viel Geld. Kann man dem nicht nachgehen und einfach uns aufklären darüber, wer will das denn da, aus welchen Gründen. Naja, das ist ja so eine Berichterstattung, wie man geht in die Wildnis und sieht Tiere und dann filmt man sie einfach ohne weitere Fragen.
Ja, das ist in der Tat so. Ich würde mich auch mal interessieren für diese Organisationsstrukturen dahinter. Was wir aber jetzt schon gehört haben, ist, dass es da diese Galeonsfigur gibt. Also der britische Charlie Kirk ist Tommy Robbins. Das ist wer? Nun, wir lassen uns das mal von einem YouTube-Short von Weltspiegel zusammenfassen.
Er hat in London eine der größten rechten Demos in der Geschichte des Landes angeführt. Es geht um den hier, Tommy Robinson. Er brachte hunderttausend auf die Straße, mit seinen Slogans hetzt er heftig gegen Migranten. Eigentlich heißt er Stephen Yexley Lennon. Der 42-Jährige nennt sich aber heute Tommy Robinson, nach einem britischen Hooligan. 2009 gründete er mit anderen Rechtsextremen die Gruppe English Defense League in seiner Heimatstadt Luton. Die Gruppe verbreitete vor allem islamophobe Propaganda. 2018 wurde sie aufgelöst. Stattdessen sind die Rechtsextremen in vielen kleinen Gruppen organisiert. Robinson wurde schon mehrmals verurteilt, unter anderem auch wegen Körperverletzung und Verbreitung von Lügen. 2018 wurde sein Twitter-Account gesperrt. Doch seit Elon Muskets Ex gehört, darf er wieder fleißig Hass auf der Plattform verbreiten, wo er sich sogar Journalist nennt. Dort folgen ihm über eine Million Menschen.
Dieser Tommy Robinson ist schon mehrmals im Knast gewesen. Er prügelt sich unglaublich gern, kommt aus dieser Hooligan-Szene. Er lässt nichts anbrennen, wo irgendwie ein Konflikt entstehen kann mit dem Staat. Und er hat es aber jetzt geschafft, auch so ein bürgerliches Publikum mitzumobilisieren. Denn sonst war das natürlich auch eine randständige Person, die dann über Social Media funktioniert hat. Aber er hat es dann vor allem durch die Produktion von Dokumentationen über die Migrationskrise, über die Gewalt in den Straßen, immer wieder neue Dokumentationen geschafft.
Plötzlich auch ein bürgerliches Lager, das um seine Sicherheit besorgt ist, für seine Bewegung zu begeistern. Also man macht das alles über das Thema Sicherheit. Interessant ist hier auch nochmal, dass eine die illegale Migration, wenn wir mal bei dieser Unterscheidung bleiben wollen, ist das Problem. Zum anderen aber ebenso das Problem, dass man sehr viele legale Migrationen durch Boris Johnson genehmigt hat, womit man aber eigentlich da auch nicht einverstanden ist. Nun hat Philippiato von Der Bild Tommy Robinson getroffen und ich will nur mal so ein bisschen wie darüber geredet wird, weil jetzt wurde auch bei Charlie Kirsch schon gesagt, ja rechtsnational und sagt man rechtsradikal, rechts. Was denn nun?
Der jetzt sagt, das klingt ja schon ziemlich krass, also sehr rechtsextrem rassistisch oder wie siehst du das?
Ich habe mir eigentlich vorgenommen, diese Wörter in der heutigen Folge nicht zu sagen, zum einen, weil sie sehr wirklich vernichtend sind, zum anderen, weil sie einfach zu oft wirklich inflationär gebraucht werden. Was man auf jeden Fall sagen kann, ist, dass er wirklich radikal ist. Also er pauschalisiert gerne und er zeichnet mal wirklich gerne den Teufel an die Wand.
Ja, was ist denn das jetzt? Also nicht so ganz rassistisch. Ronzheimer fragt noch mal nach.
Philipp, jetzt sagst du, du bist vorsichtig mit solchen Wörtern. Versuche ich auch zu sein. Aber wenn jemand sagt, dass er bewusst eine Gruppe oder eine Religion ablehnt, dann ist es ja nichts anderes als Rassismus.
Ja, Rassismus basiert ja erstmal darauf, dass man eine bestimmte Herkunft oder Hautfarbe ablehnt. Keine, nicht unbedingt eine Religion oder Ideologie. Und er ist da so ein bisschen widersprüchlich. Also manchmal wird er wahnsinnig allgemein und spricht dann über Muslime, Muslime, Muslime. Und dann, wenn er vielleicht merkt, dass der Zuhörer etwas zu kritisch schaut, dann sagt er übrigens, ich meine natürlich nicht alle, ich habe ganz viele Freunde, die sind Muslime und ich würde natürlich auch nicht alle abschieben. Es gibt ganz großartige Leute, mir geht es nur um die, die die Scharia möchten.
Man wechselt so hin und her und das ist mir jetzt...
Das ist so ein bisschen wie, ich bin Flexitarier. Ah ja, du isst also nicht immer bei allem, was du isst, Fleisch, also wie normale Menschen. Ja, also er ist Rassist, aber nicht in jedem Satz.
Ja, bzw. wenn wir über Rassismus reden, haben wir sehr schnell ja so die Nazis vor Augen und die Nazis...
Ich ja nicht, aber ja, also typischerweise.
Zum Beispiel hat man Nazis vor Augen. Oder man, also man hat, wenn man über eine rechtsradikale, rechtsextreme Bewegung spricht, hat man Nazis vor Augen. Und die Nazis, und deswegen, du hast ja eben noch mal so gesagt, du hast da die AfD-Wähler als Nazis bezeichnet. Ich glaube, also das kannst du machen. Mein Problem ist ja folgendes, wenn wir jetzt bei dem Definitorischen sind. Bei den Nazis ist es ja so, dass sie eine Politik machen, also allererstes gegen Juden, und dann kommen alle anderen, die sie nicht wollen. Also gibt es dann die entsprechenden sogenannten Rassegesetze gegen homosexuelle Menschen mit Behinderung und und und. Was jetzt dort stattfindet bei den Nationalsozialisten ist, die gehen ja durch alle Gesellschaftsschichten durch und sortieren aus, deportieren. Der jüdische Professor, der jüdische Kaufmann, der jüdische Straßenkehrer, alles wird deportiert und so weiter. Was wir jetzt hier bei diesen neuen rechten Bewegungen erleben, ist ja gerade nicht, dass sie eine solche Reinheitsfantasie umsetzen wollen, bei der sie jetzt sagen, wir müssen alle Briten sehen, dass sie weiß bleiben und dass wir jetzt alles, was wir in Migration zu tun haben, rausnehmen. Und deswegen fangen wir jetzt mal bei den Schäferärzten oder so etwas an, sondern was jetzt die große rechte Bewegung heute, nicht nur in Großbritannien, sondern europaweit und USA und so weiter ist, ist, dass man unterscheidet, also zwischen denen, die gut verwertbar sind im Sinne von, die sind wahnsinnig qualifiziert und irgendwie da da oben, dann ist es auch kein Problem, wenn der Silicon Valley-Chef nicht ein Amerikaner ist, oder wenn Elon Musk gar nicht in den USA geboren ist. Solche Dinge spielen dann keine Rolle. Ja, aber die darunter, die sind dran. Und dann macht man das ja auch oft mit der Argumentation der Kriminalität. Also es ist nicht eine Argumentation mehr nur mit Ethnizität, sondern man verbindet das gleich mit Kriminalität und versucht, aber dann immer so zu tun, weil man natürlich auch weiß, dass man da sonst mit dem Verfassungsschutz und so weiter Ärger bekommen könnte, wenn wir jetzt den deutschen Diskurs uns ansehen, dann versucht man nicht ganz pauschal in allen Fällen zu sein, weil man sonst ein Problem bekommt mit dem Rechtsstaat. Also sagt man, es gibt aber Statistiken, die gehen in die Richtung und die sagen das und das und das. Und damit glaube ich, werden diese Begrifflichkeiten sehr schwierig zu verwenden, weil die dann immer sagen, naja wieso, ich habe ja auch nichts gegen Alice Weidel, die ist ja auch nicht mit einer Deutschen zusammen und die ist sogar lesbisch. Also wieso soll ich denn jetzt ein Nazi sein? Und ich glaube, dass aus dieser Begriffsverunkklärung, die da stattfindet, wir in so einem permanenten Diskurs darum sind, ja wer ist denn wie rechts gerade? Und das führt uns ja zu dem Punkt, dass damit so Anschluss fähig wird für eine bürgerliche Mitte, weil sie am Ende sagen kann, ja das mit der Kriminalität in unseren Straßen gefällt mir aber nicht.
Genau, also aus pädagogischen, in der Hoffnung, dass didaktische Folgen noch etwas machen, verstehe ich das. Nur der Rassismus der Nazis war einfach, also in der Ausprägung, wie du es beschrieben hast, dem geschuldet. Es gab gar keine Ausländer, die Ausländerkode war ein Prozent. Es gab aber Juden und die haben das Kohärente, ist ja das neue Modell, homogene, war der Begriff von damals. Dann hat man so eine Hygiene durchgeführt und man ist auch nicht auf Abschiebung gegangen, sondern auf Vernichtung. Und in Ländern, die grundsätzlich schon mal 20 Prozent Migrationshintergrund so Pi mal Daumen haben und dann in urbanen Zentren, auf die es politisch ankommt, die man nicht einfach aussatieren kann wie den ländlichen Raum, auf 50 Prozent, kannst du natürlich so eine Taktik nicht fahren, auch wenn du es gerne würdest, dass die dann abschwächen und sagen, okay, unser Rassismus ist so ein bisschen leid, weil wir wollen ja anschlussfähig bleiben, das würde ich denen jetzt unter, wie gesagt, pädagogischen, didaktischen, in der Hoffnung, dass ein Gespräch noch was führt, aber unter Frank Staus Gesichtspunkten würde ich sagen, na, wir sollten jetzt schon langsam mal einsehen. Die sind wirklich überzeugte Rassisten, die würden es gern wie die Nazis machen, die finden andere Gesellschaften vor, also zeigen sie sich so.
Ja, das ist die Anpassung der Rechten an die Zeit, an die Gewalt des Faktischen. Sie können nicht in das Jahr 1933 zurück mit einem Migrationsanteil von 1, 2, 3 Prozent. Da können sie nicht hin. Sie leben in Köln, da ist ein Migrationsanteil von über 50 Prozent und noch ein sehr hoher Teil von Schwulen und Lesben, also überdurchschnittlich verglichen.
Da muss ja Notfall-Liebertär werden.
Da ist die Frage, was wollen sie jetzt da gerade tun? Und das ist aber, was wir so erleben. Und dadurch werden diese Denkgebäude natürlich in einem hohen Maße inkonsistent, weil man dann plötzlich sagen muss, ja, genau. Also Alice Weidel, die ist zwar eine lesbische Frau, die ist auch nicht mit einer Deutschen verheiratet, aber trotzdem vertritt die Sache. Und dann, um aber wieder eine gemeinsame Basis herzustellen, redet man die ganze Zeit über Kriminalität. Weil da sind sich ja irgendwie erst mal alle einig, dass man sagt, genau, wir sollen uns ja nicht abknallen, nicht schießen auf der Straße, wir sollen nicht irgendwelche Geschäfte ausrauben. Und jetzt ist interessant, was noch hinzukommt, wir haben natürlich das christliche Abendland, das auch dieser Robinson verteidigen will gegen den Islam. Denn er setzt jetzt den Islam vor allem als den Kontrapunkt an und da muss er dagegen arbeiten. Bedeutet natürlich auch, Verbündete suchen. Hier wird es ausgeführt.
Aber auch zu den sehr muslimisch und dann auch links geprägten Demonstrationen, die es seit dem 7. Oktober 2023 gibt. Also seit dem Überfall der Hamas auf Israel, seit dem Beginn dieses Krieges im Gaza-Streifen hat man natürlich im London auch massive Demonstrationen gesehen. Oft noch viel, viel größer als in anderen Städten, natürlich auch größer als in Berlin. Das ist angesprochen, da leben sehr viele Menschen aus verschiedenen Ländern, auch sehr, sehr viele Muslime. Und die Stadt ist auch überhaupt nicht konservativ, sondern eher links. Deswegen gab es da einen riesigen Zulauf. Und Tommy Robinson, der übrigens selbst extrem pro-israelisch ist, sagt, dass viele Menschen einfach genug davon haben.
Also das soll jetzt quasi so als Gegenprotest auch da zu sein, denn das ist ja an sich ein muslimischer Protest, wird dann gesagt. Jetzt kommt ja noch hinzu, dass die Briten aus Europa, aus der EU raus wollten, weil sie sagten, das machen wir lieber mit uns selbst. Wir wollen nicht mehr diesen Internationalismus haben. Ja, jetzt ist Robinson wahnsinnig erfolgreich mit dieser Demo gewesen und macht diese Dokumentation, die millionenfach geklickt werden im Internet. Und was hat der jetzt vor? Naja, der will eigentlich seine eigene Demonstrations-EU, würde ich es mal nennen.
Richtig, ich habe ihn gefragt, was als nächstes kommt. Also er plant jetzt wieder ein neues Doku. Aber er möchte auch seine Demo-Bewegung noch vergrößern und auch internationalisieren. Also es war so, dass jetzt schon bei diesem Aufmarsch am vergangenen Samstag sehr viele internationale Gäste da waren, vor allem natürlich aus dem rechten Spektrum. Es war zum Beispiel auch Peter Bistron von der AfD da, AfD-Abgeordneter. Und jetzt möchte Tommy Robinson, dass beim nächsten Mal Alice Weidel dabei ist, also dass es sein großes Ziele möchte.
Elon Musk ist ja auch Unterstützer von Robinson. Alice Weidel soll noch bitte dazu, dass man möchte jetzt einfach auch wieder so einen Überkonstrukt haben. Also verlässt eigentlich den nationalstaatlichen Rahmen. Und das ist ja auch eine Veränderung, die wir jetzt erleben, also die Internationalisierung des Rechten. Denn man würde ja eigentlich sagen, naja, dann wollen die also offenbar wirklich nur vor der eigenen Haustür kehren oder Ruhe schaffen und sagen, hier sollen die Migranten raus. Was schert mich das, was in Deutschland der Fall ist? Also das ist ja an sich ein irrsinniges Denken von jemandem, der sagt, für mich als Engländer muss England englisch bleiben, was auch immer, ja. Deshalb dürfen hier keine Migranten sein. Aber dann wäre mir eigentlich völlig egal, ob Deutschland 10 Millionen oder niemand aufnimmt. Aber nein, es muss also jetzt plötzlich doch so ein Internationalismus hergestellt werden. Viel stärker ja interessanterweise, als das momentan in der internationalen Linken oder so. Gelingt.
Aber dieser Edno-Pluralismus gilt halt nicht nur für die Gegner, sondern auch für einen selber. Also klar versteht man sich als britischer Rechtsextremer sehr gut mit einem deutschen Rechtsextremen, solange alle ihren Rechtsextremismus bei sich zu Hause machen. Und dann ist man in der, wie nennen die das dann? Die wollen ja auch die EU als Nation der Völker und so. Wie ist hier der Begriff?
Als Union der Vaterländer.
Vaterländer, genau. Also die Vaterländer, der eine Vater ist immer klar definiert. Die gehen dann, das haben wir ja auch, die Familie, der Clan und dann kommt die Nation und dann kommt aus der Nation wieder neue Familienbündel. Diese Logik kann ich sogar nachvollziehen. Er hat eine sehr große, inhärente Plausibilität. Das ist halt nur Quatsch.
Jaja, sie hat da keine Plausibilität, wo man sagen könnte, uns geht es nur um uns. Nein, es muss also doch noch ein größeres Projekt sein und deswegen migrieren auch die Zeichen. Also das ist ja völlig unsinnig, dass jetzt Charlie Kirk in London hochgehalten wird. Also wenn man sich jetzt an die alten rechten Bewegungen erinnert, also da hat er jetzt nicht, also natürlich gab es immer wieder irgendwelche Kollaborationen, dass man gesagt hat, Deutschland und der italienische Faschismus arbeiten zusammen oder der spanische. Aber in dieser Weise, wie das jetzt hier so stattfindet, dass das alles so ein Meme nach dem anderen ist, das überall viral gehen kann und dann miteinander vernetzt wird, das ist die neue Dimension. Daraufhin habe ich mir gedacht, wie wird denn sowas eigentlich bei YouTube rezipiert? Also mir ist schon aufgefallen, als ich die Sachen dann mir dort ergoogelt habe, dass häufig nicht mehr Tagesschau 24 als erstes angezeigt wurde oder andere seriösere Quellen, sondern es sind merkwürdige Dinge aufgetaucht, und zwar gleich ganz weit oben. Und auch zum Beispiel hier das, ein Kanal der heißt Kapitän Klausi, mit 500.000 Aufrufen auf diesem Video. Und es gibt also wirklich zahlreiche solcher Sachen. Vielleicht kannst du uns auch mal beschreiben, wie dieses Video aussieht. Wir hören da auch mal rein, wie der Ton ist. Also erstmal Eskalation wird ein.
Großbritannien versickt im Chaos. England kämpft gegen eine Welle aus Gewalt, Rut und Zensur. Seit Tagen treibt das die Menschen im ganzen Land auf die Straße.
Wir haben genug. Es sind keine Familien.
Es kommen nur undokumentierte Männer.
Den größten Fehler, den meine Regierung gemacht hat, sie haben die Fluttore für Migranten geöffnet. Niemand sollte Gebäude anzünden. Aber unsere Politik drängt die Leute in die Ecke. Sie erzeugen die Angst in den Gemeinden. Und das führt zu solchen Aktionen. Da sind diejenigen, die rufen Englisch, bis wir sterben, stoppt die Boote und die damit meinen, erst die Engländer, dann die Ausländer.
Das ist kein Protest.
Es ist nicht legitim.
Wir werden das stoppen.
Doch es hörte nicht auf. Neue Unruhen flammen auf in mehr als 20 Städten. Es brodelt im Vereinigungskönigreich. Jetzt fragt sich das Land, was da eigentlich passiert ist.
Jetzt sagen wir, wir haben einen Zusammenschnitt von irgendwelchem Pressematerial mit diesem Ton dann unterlegt. Jetzt steht dort England im Ausnahmezustand am Rande eines Bürgerkriegs. Da müsste eigentlich eines Bürgerkrieges stehen.
Das kann jetzt nicht so pänglich sein.
Ich gehe bewusst darauf ein, weil hier sehr viel KI-Generiertes passiert.
Jawohl, wenn das Volk genug hat, dann hilft auch kein Beamter, der nach Genehmigung fragt, dann wird demonstriert und auf Englern Straßen herrscht aktuell Rambo Zambo, denn links ist vorbei, aber nur wenn es nach dem Willen der Bevölkerung geht.
Geil.
Das ist also jetzt ein Typ mit einem kräftigen Schnurrbart in einem blauen T-Shirt, der in einer Straße steht, in dem die Autos alle gelbe Nummernschilder haben und uns jetzt erklärt, was dort los ist und das ist KI.
Also man sieht es auch relativ deutlich noch, dass es KI ist.
Ja, das ist nicht gut gemacht, aber 500.000 Aufruf hören, mal weiter.
Grüßt euch Freunde, in Großbritannien herrscht aktuell Ausnahmezustand. In allen größeren Städten wie Liverpool, Manchester oder Norwich explodieren die Menschen regelrecht vor Wut. Einfache Bürger protestieren tagelang auf den Straßen vor sogenannten Migrantenhotels. Polizisten kämpfen wie in einem Bürgerkrieg gegen die eigene Bevölkerung.
Bürgerkrieg, Bürgerkrieg, Bürgerkrieg, das ist das Thema, das sich durch all diese Videos zieht und sie sind zunehmend KI generiert.
Wir werden auch zunehmend heute's Genal- und Tagesthemenberichte bekommen, in denen es heißt, das ist gar nicht gut und so weiter und so fort. Hier bin ich allerdings ganz axeleterist. Jeder, der sich für solche Sachen interessiert und auf YouTube geht, muss irgendwann total genervt davon sein, weil er weiß, sorry, ich kann nicht 10.000 Videos, die 30 Minuten lang sind zu diesem Thema, ich werde es nicht mehr überblicken und so weiter. Und dass man einfach erschöpft aufgibt und nicht mehr ein noch aus.
Das ist dein Wunsch und diese Erschöpfung hat er bei mir eingesetzt. Wir spielen jetzt gleich noch vier Clips, ich will alle so ein bisschen mit erschöpfen.
Hier müssen wir uns erschöpfen, hier müssen wir jetzt wirklich so ein schlingsiefartiges, hier muss die Erschöpfung jetzt rein.
Wir müssen da mal richtig rein.
Jeden Tag 20 Stunden solcher Videos.
Ja, denn die Leute gucken es ja, und du hast uns ja hier zu genüge Hoss und Hopf vorgespielt und Hoss und Hopf sitzen ja immer da und sagen, es kann nicht mehr so weitergehen in den deutschen Innenstädten. Wer traut sich da eigentlich noch ein? Da laufen die Männer mit dem Messer schon gezückt herum. Und in dieser Art sind ja diese ganzen KI-Videos jetzt. Wir hören jetzt ein anderes Video, da taucht jetzt niemand der KI generiertes auf, aber das ganze Material ist KI-mäßig zusammengefrickelt. Anders kann man es nicht ausdrücken.
Sehr gut.
Und auch der Text ist Tzetsipiti, sag es mir dreimal in leichter Variation. Wir hören rein, dieser Kanal heißt Deutsch Politik. Man würde ja auch sagen, ich nenne es deutsche Politik. Nein, der Kanal heißt Deutsch Politik.
England steht am Abgrund. Was wir in diesen Tagen aus London sehen, ist mehr als nur ein Protest. Es ist ein Fanal, ein Schock für das gesamte westliche Europa. Eine Hauptstadt, die von Gewalt erschüttert wird, eine Regierung, die kaum noch handlungsfähig wirkt und ein Volk, das sich in zwei feindliche Lager spaltet. Am vergangenen Samstag marschierten, nach offiziellen Angaben, rund 105.000 Noisent-Menschen durch die Straßenleuchten.
Wir hören, also die Zahlen, die Zahlen stimmen nicht, die können nicht so richtig ausgesprochen werden, aber macht nix. Hat trotzdem 100.000 Klicks oder 30.000.
London's 150.000. Es war die größte rechte Demonstration seit Jahrzehnten, angeführt von keinem Geringeren als dem berüchtigten Aktivisten Tommy Robinson. Unter dem Motto Unite the Kingdom erhoben sie ihre Stimmen. Gegen Migration, gegen den unkontrollierten Zustrom über den Ärmelkanal, gegen eine Politik, die in ihren Augen Meinungsfreiheit zerstört und den Bürgern das Wort verbietet. Union Jacks wehten in den Straßen. Parolen halten durch die Hauptstadt. Stoppt die Boote! Schickte sie nach Hause. Für viele Demonstranten war es nicht einfach ein Protest, sie nannten es offen einen Aufstand. Ein letztes Warnsignal an die Politik, bevor die Lage endgültig explodiert.
Stümperhaft gemacht.
Fickst du aber dann in die Kommentare. Reger Austausch über das dort Fall gebotene. Wir hören einfach weiter rein.
Sorgen, die jeden sozialen Frieden sprengen. Es ist kein Einzelfall, sondern ein Muster, das sich wiederholt. Und genau dieses Muster macht die Menschen wütend. Gleichzeitig kämpft Großbritannien mit einer Kriminalitätswelle, die das Vertrauen in Polizei und Staat weiter untergräbt. Einzelhandelsverbände sprechen von einer Ladendiebstahl-Pandemie über 20 Millionen Fälle pro Jahr. Fast 56. Nosen am Tag. Supermärkte. Apotheken. Elektronikmärkte. Überall wird gestohlen. Mitarbeiter berichten von Drohungen mit Messern. Mit Hämmern. Von Banden. Die ganze Regale leerräumen. Die Polizei ist überfordert. Anzeigen verschwinden in Schubladen. Täter bleiben unbestraft. Früher hatten die Leute noch Scham. Heute ist Stehlen normal, sagt ein Apotheker. Ein Satz, der mehr aussagt als jede Statistik.
Ja, denn wir brauchen ja gar keine Statistik. Wir brauchen nur diesen Vibe, mit dem man mitgehen kann.
Ein unendliches Gespräch, ja.
Es geht unendlich so weiter. Nochmal rein.
Deckender Aufstand. Gespeist aus Wut, Frust und Verzweiflung.
Denn während die Regierung in London beschwichtigt und von Einzelfällen spricht, dazu sehen wir ja nur Medienmaterial, das so leicht verfremdet ist, damit man nicht mehr sehen kann, ist es BBC oder CNN und die ganze Zeit werden Menschen, die durch die Gegend rennen oder Polizisten gezeigt.
Wächst in den Städten und Dörfern ein Widerstand, der längst die Kontrolle der Behörden übersteigt.
Das ist jetzt interessant, denn in gewisser Weise wird die Logik, nach der das Video und all dieser Content funktioniert, selbst bloßgelegt von dem KI-Sprecher.
Der längst die Kontrolle der Behörden übersteigt. Was in Essex begann, hat sich wie ein Lauffeuer ausgebreitet. Menschen versammeln sich vor Hotels, rufen, schließen die Heime, blockieren Straßen, zünden Feuerwerkskörper und liefern sich Straßenschlachten mit der Polizei. Die Eskalation folgt einem Muster. Ein Vorfall, ein Video, ein Post in den sozialen Netzwerken. Und binnen Stunden brennt eine ganze Stadt. In Liverpool, in Birmingham, in Sheffield. Überall dieselben Bilder. Bürger, die ihrem Staat nicht mehr trauen. Und ein Staat, der auf seine Bürger mit Schlagstöcken reagiert.
Was man hier die ganze Zeit versucht, ist, dem Bürgerkrieg herbeizureden und dabei auch noch zu sagen, wir können den Bürgerkrieg herstellen, indem wir jetzt ein Video von einem Fall online viral gehen lassen. Und dann geht es los. Und das ist ja genau auch die Strategie immer gewesen von Bild-TV oder jetzt von Nios oder auch von Springer aktuell, dass man den einen Vorfall nimmt, dann ist Ulf Poschert schon wieder in Rage bei NTV zu hören. Und dann geht das immer weiter und wir können wieder eine Reaktion, eine Reaktion, eine Reaktion machen. Und sie sagen das sogar so und sehnen sich eigentlich so sehr nach diesem Zustand. Das Video schließt dann nach etwa 20 Minuten hiermit, dass sie längst das Vertrauen verloren haben.
Es ist nicht mehr die Frage, ob, sondern wann der nächste Funke das Pulver fast zur Explosion bringt. Und genau deshalb müssen wir uns fragen, ist das der Anfang einer patriotischen Wende in Europa oder der Beginn eines Abgrunds, aus dem keiner mehr herauskommt? Denn eines ist klar, was in London begann, wird nicht in London enden.
Ja, Alpha, Omega, alles dreht sich im Kreis, die Wiederkehr. Ich würde ja sagen, mein Urteil dazu ist, die Erlösung ist nah, wenn wir nicht mehr rausfinden, ob das gerade echt ist oder nicht, also was uns da gezeigt wird, wenn wir es nicht mehr verorten können.
Das musst du jetzt ausführen, denn ich saß mit Michel Friedman im Städel auf der Bühne und sagte, ja die Sache ist ja, wenn die Fiktion funktioniert, dann funktioniert eben die Fiktion. Und da hat Michel Friedman sehr vehement widersprochen. Und jetzt gehst du ja noch viel weiter als ich.
Also, wir haben hier noch Clips offen, die wir heute nicht schaffen. Christian Uhle war bei Sternstunde Philosophie und unser Lieblingsphilosoph Markus Gabriel war bei unserem Lieblingspodcaster Matze Hilscher. Ich habe einen Clip-Rundown aus beiden gleichzeitig. Also wo wir nicht, wir gucken das eine, dann das andere, sondern die klären dir die gleiche Fragestellung. Was hat es mit der KI auf sich und so. Und es könnte nicht desparater sein. Der eine, Christian Uhle, sagt, also wir werden so überschwemmt mit dem Zeug, aber es geht jetzt erst los. Sagen sie nicht einfach, was in zehn Jahren ist. Geben sie nicht auf, wie auch immer. Denn im Zweifel werden sie immer Liebe, Freude und Lebenskraft daraus schöpfen, dass sie einfach zu Hause bei Menschen, die sie lieben und so weiter, Halt finden können. Während Markus Gabriel daneben steht und sagt, also die KI, die macht jetzt schon Emotionen, nicht mehr nur Sprache, die macht jetzt auch Emotionen. Und dann geht es so eine Stunde lang, blablabla. Und dann ist seine Lösung am Ende, ja, wir müssen uns jetzt überlegen, wie wir die KI hacken, so wie in Matrix. Weißt du, wir müssen uns die Frage stellen, was würde Neo tun?
Denn es gibt ja auch nur eine KI.
Und jetzt hört man mir vielleicht zu und denkt, ich spinne irgendwie, das kann doch nicht ernsthaft ein Philosophie-Professor und so weiter sagen, aber er. Und wir werden uns darüber noch ausführlich lustig machen. Was bedeutet für mich, da wir hoffentlich alle immer einen sozialen Rückzugsraum haben, wo wir wissen, die Person, mit der ich hier gerade vor Ort rede, ist eine echte Person, es ist noch nicht Westworld, ist es sehr erlösend zu wissen, wenn ich den Bildschirm einschalte, ich weiß es nicht. Kannst du nicht sagen. Es gibt kein Kriterium mehr, an dem ich festmache, ob das gerade echte Menschen sind, die mir eine echte Nachricht bringen oder ob das alles ausgedacht ist und so weiter und so fort. Ich kann es an dem Absender nicht abhängen, ich kann es an der Menge des Materials nicht aufhängen, an nichts. Sondern ob ich den Bildschirm an oder ausmache, ist im Grunde egal. Mit dem einen Unterschied, und das ist jetzt wichtig, wenn ich die Tagesschau einschalte, dann kommt Susanne Daubner und erzählt mir eine Viertelstunde lang und ich vertraue ihr und verlasse mich darauf, das sind die Nachrichten. Aber was ansonsten stattfindet?
Ja, also da würde ich dann doch widersprechen wollen, so sehr ich ja auch ein Anhänger von Flusser und Baudrillard bin. Aber wenn ich jetzt diese Unterscheidung mache, aber bitte die Tagesschau soll real sein. Also die Tagesschau wählt ja erst mal Dinge aus und zeigt sie so oder so. Also es ist ja nicht einfach nur die Realität. Nein, lass mich das mal ausführen. Es ist ja nicht einfach nur die Realität, sondern es ist ja eine Auswahl von Bildern. Und die Frage, was benennt man wie, wo ist es eine Widerstandsgruppe, wo sind es Terroristen, das sind ja alles schon Verformungen der Wirklichkeit, beziehungsweise die Wirklichkeit kann nur verformt gewisserweise dort reinkommen, weil sie nun nicht, das Fernsehen ist nicht die Wirklichkeit. Und die Wirklichkeit können wir aber nur über die Massenmedien wahrnehmen, die Realität der Massenmedien lumern. Jetzt kommen wir aber an den Punkt, bei dem zum einen diese Journalisten, die zum Beispiel die Tagesschau betreiben, ja in die Gemengelage kommen, dass sie gar nicht wissen. Mehr durch KI dann irgendwann. Gab es Proteste, die so und so gestaltet sind? Stimmt dieses Video des Anschlags gerade? Kriegen wir überhaupt noch raus, ob das ein echter Terroranschlag war oder ob das jetzt gerade ein KI-Fake ist? Das ist schon mal eine ganz große Schwierigkeit, die dadurch entsteht, denn sonst können wir ja der Tagesschau nicht weiter vertrauen. Und zudem kommt ja hinzu, dass wir über die Tagesschau hinaus doch bitte auch noch Wirklichkeitsberichterstattung wahrnehmen wollen. Also nicht nur so zwei, drei Fixpunkte haben, weil dann müssen wir sagen, dann richten wir uns auf den Staatsfernsehen ein, dass das vorher checkt und dann veröffentlicht es es. Und da kommen wir natürlich in diese Gemengelage, bei der man sagen kann, ja, was ist denn hier eigentlich noch real oder was nicht? Also wir sind da schon an einem Punkt, bei dem man sagen kann, ich kann ja nicht mein Leben darauf ausdenken, zu sagen, alles könnte fake sein, bis auf die Tagesschau.
Ja, die Antwort darauf ist ganz einfach. Der Christian Uhle macht einen ganz interessanten Punkt. Wenn jetzt die KI kommt und den ganzen Arbeitsmarkt aufräumt, stellen Leute jetzt gerade fest, dann betrifft mich das ja, weil ich arbeite ja am Computer. Das heißt, alle Leute, die heute am Computer sehen, müssen sich Gedanken darüber machen, was mache ich die nächsten zehn Jahre oder so ganz konkret, was mache ich in zehn Jahren? Weil wahrscheinlich wird eine KI besser können, was ich am Computer kann, weil die KI ist der Computer, als ich, der vor dem Computer sitzt. Was bedeutet, das ist gar nicht der Untergang der Welt, sondern die Arbeitswelt verwandelt sich wieder in das, was sie immer war, bis so ungefähr vor 30 Jahren. Menschen saßen plötzlich nur noch vor dem Computer. Wir haben uns also sehr an eine Arbeitswelt gewöhnt, in der einfach alle am Computer sitzen. Nur das ist in der Arbeits-, in der Geschichte der menschlichen Arbeit, ist das der ganz kleine Vorgeschiss am Ende, den werden wir so schnell vergessen. Was bedeutet, wir haben dann wieder Zeit für, ja was denn eigentlich, ja was würden wir denn gerne machen eigentlich, vielleicht mit echten Menschen arbeiten, statt mit einem Computerbildschirm und so. Also wir haben plötzlich wieder Freiheiten, aber man muss es halt organisieren. Deswegen, wir gucken dann die Clips, wie der Moderator sagt, ich will in so einer Welt nicht leben, man macht alles die KI und Christian Ull so, wir können auch darüber entscheiden. Aber wenn man nicht darüber entscheidet, dann ist man halt ausgeliefert.
Gut, das wäre nochmal ein anderes Thema, aber wie ist es bei den Medien?
Du hast dich sehr lange darauf verlassen, dass dir die Tagesschau einfach die Welt erklärt, weil welche andere Möglichkeit hast du denn?
Und willst du ja weiter haben wieder?
Jetzt kommt der große Kniff. Irgendwann begann es, dass ich so vorm Fernseher aus dem Saal, also ich jetzt, ich schäfere die Menschheit und so, belügt mich die Tagesschau eigentlich. Ich habe doch hier Twitter. Ich lese mal lieber auf Twitter nach. Ich finde dieses, ich lese mal lieber auf Twitter nach, ich vertraue Journalisten nicht. Journalisten, die lügen doch auch und so. Hat der Welt nicht sehr gut getan. Also der Zustand der heutigen Welt hat auch viel damit zu tun, dass Social Media so ein bisschen außerhand umwandt.
Ich bin wirklich verwundert, dass du so gegen Social Media inzwischen bist. Also ich meine, wir verdanken ja zum Beispiel unseren Erfolg ja auch den sozialen Medien bzw. der Tatsache, dass Leute sagen, wenn ich jetzt über Bürgergeld was Sinnvolles erfahren will, dann finde ich das nicht bei Karen Miosga und finde das meistens auch nicht in den Tagesthemen, sondern wahrscheinlich ist es sinnvoller, man hört uns zu oder vielleicht Maurice Höfgen dazu.
Wo haben wir denn die Sachen her, die wir hier spielen? Wir spielen Clips am laufenden Band aus großen Medien.
Schon etwas daraus, nur die Einordnung, die ist jetzt zum Beispiel häufig nicht die entsprechende, die gemacht wird. Wir gehen ja bei der Medienkritik, du gehst ja viel härter da oft ins Gericht, als ich das tue.
Die sind ja auch zu kritisieren.
So und das bedeutet aber doch, dass jetzt durch diese Pluralisierung, die stattgefunden hat, ist das, das ist doch erst mal gut. Ich kann doch nicht immer nur jetzt mir die negativen Dinge raussuchen und sagen, weil die Menschen das und das und das machen, weil sie plötzlich mit radikalisiert werden in eine Richtung, wie mir das nicht gefällt. Dann sagen ja, dann war Social Media ein Problem. Da sind wir ja bald bei Jürgen Habermas, der eigentlich sagte, ich hätte gerne die Gatekeeper-Medien zurück.
Ja, nein, nein.
Und deswegen glaube ich, ist das doch eine viel wichtigere Sache.
Du entgrenzt ja immer das Thema so. Du machst ja immer den, also ich stehe ja so ein Topf Essenhilden und dann holst du das ganze Menü.
Du musst dich ja mal entscheiden. Also eben hast du uns, ich will das nur mal, weil wir in dieser Folge bleiben, eben hast du uns gesagt, du würdest am liebsten, dass Instagram abgestellt wird, solange die noch irgendwelche Videos von sterbenden Menschen zeigen.
Ja, aber das ist ja klar. So, das habe ich jetzt verstanden. Das wird dann einmal abgeschaltet für einen halben Tag, danach ist das Problem gelöst. Das ist ja die Lösung.
Jetzt sehen wir hier, dass Menschen sich offenbar an KI-Videos nicht satt sehen können, die die ganze Zeit bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände ausrufen, die so nicht ganz der Wahrheit entspannend sind.
Und wie hast du darauf reagiert? Ich habe nicht gesagt Betriebsschließungen, ich habe gesagt, überall, zeigt es den Leuten überall.
Genau, das kommt ja nicht in meinen Kopf rein, weil die Leute sind nicht erschöpft davon, die Leute hören es Stunde um Stunde sicher an.
Also das Phänomen, das, was wir jetzt gerade sehen, ist überhaupt erst seit drei Monaten möglich. Und die Frage ist immer, kann man es auf Dauer stellen? Diese Produktion, in welcher Qualität, ästhetisch auch immer, kriegst du nicht auf Dauer gestellt, weil du daran keine Orientierung festmachen kannst. Die Leute werden irgendwas sehen und sie werden spüren, oh, das trifft ja genau meinen Nerv. Und dann werden sie sofort merken, bin ich jetzt alleine oder nicht? Also was ist eigentlich der Anhaltspunkt? Ich überleg mal, wie lange die Nachrichtenredaktion, also ich hab noch das Lombard vor Augen, wie sie da sitzt bei der Republika. Ja, wir haben ganz lange gedacht, wenn da so 30.000 Retweets sind, dann ist das ganz wichtig. Und wie haben wir so, seid ihr bescheuert? Nur weil 30.000 mal irgendwas geteilt wurde, ist das doch nicht wichtig. Und hier der Zählbe. Man hat keinen Maßstab mehr dafür. Das, was ich gerade sehe, es sieht aus wie Hollywood. Aber ist es Hollywood? Es hat doch irgendwer zusammengepromptet, oder? Und so. Und umso mehr das stattfindet, umso mehr kommen die alten Prinzipien wieder zurück, dass man nämlich einfach sagt, also an Sinneseindrücken hat es noch nie gemangelt. Heute macht sie halt hauptsächlich der Bildschirm, was trotzdem bedeutet, 20.15 Uhr auf dieser Welle kriegst du deine Nachrichten.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, dass aufgrund dieser KI-Flut es wieder eine Rückkehr zur Tagesschau geben wird bei den Leuten.
Die Tagesschau war ja immer präsent. Die hatte immer noch acht Millionen Zuschauer. Und Deutschlandfunk hat steigende Zuhörerzahlen, weil die Leute jetzt langsam mal wieder so, ich weiß schon, dass da viel los ist in den Medien.
Das ist eine gute Nachricht. Ich gehe ja auch nicht davon aus, dass jetzt die einzelnen Content-Creator, die ich jetzt hier vorgespielt habe, also diese KI-Creator, dass unbedingt die, die erfolgreich sind. Ich glaube nur, dass diese KI-Maschinerie, die dort in Gang gesetzt wird, um dann sehr schnell so bürgerlich-kriegsähnliche Zustände zu simulieren und das dann viral zu verbreiten, dass das zunehmen wird und dass es offenbar ein Publikum gibt, das völlig okay damit ist zu sagen, ich gucke mir die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Stockvideos von Polizisten an und irgendwelchen Straßen schlachten und lasse mir von der KI-Stimme erklären, dass alles immer schlimmer wird. Dass das bei uns beiden Ermüdungserscheinungen führt und dass alle, die hier zugehört haben, wahrscheinlich auch schon fix unter alle sind, das glaube ich ja. Nur das größere Publikum leider in Deutschland und in anderen Ländern ist ja offenbar anders gepolt.
Mal sehen, ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn einem einer das Angebot macht, wir könnten dir den selben Rechenaufwand auch, und du sagst uns einfach, wie die Frau aussehen sollen, die wir dir als Porno hinstellen und dann macht sie hoch individuelles Angebot für dich, dass das vielleicht mehr Leute zieht als, wenn man eh weiß, alles nur KI generiert.
Ja, aber es ist ja eigentlich ein ganz guter Vergleich. Also es ist ja schon so eine Art von von Pornografie, die da stattfindet, dass man so in einer permanenten Wiederholung sich in so eine Ekstase reinredet, und es wird immer schlimmer, immer schlimmer, immer schlimmer. Und das ist etwas, was algorithmisch präferiert wird, was viele Content-Creator jetzt dazu führt, dass sie immer stärker auf jedes einzelne Ereignis eingehen. Also es gibt eine Sondersendung, wenn ein Holzow irgendeinen Tweet macht, dann müssen 15 Kommentatoren zur Seite stehen und müssen irgendetwas sagen. Bedeutet also, diese permanente Empörung ist etwas, die so gut funktioniert, schon jetzt, dass man sagen kann, wenn man es mit KI noch flächendeckender verteilen kann, überall ausbreiten kann, und es genügt den Leuten offenbar. Und sie brauchen noch nicht mal mehr ein Hoss und Hopf persönlich, der es ihnen sagt, sondern es reicht, wenn das ein KI-Kapitän Klausi ihnen sagt. Dann finden wir das natürlich merkwürdig, aber das scheint die Realität zu sein.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben es wie bei La Bubu mit einem Phänomen zu tun, dass so eine, also sehr schnell wieder abflacht.
Aber das Herbeirufen des Bürgerkriegs wird, glaube ich, nicht abflachen, jetzt mal von KI unabhängig. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass das etwas ist, was sich jetzt so viele herbeisehnen. Endlich passiert was auf den Straßen, und dann kann man das auch wieder viral verbreiten. Wir sind uns ja auch einig, dass das Charlie Kirk-Phänomen funktionierte besonders gut, weil da so Leute mitfilten. Dann hat man das Video daraus gemacht, das ist irgendwie hochgeladen, und dann verbreitete es sich, dass dadurch diese tatsächliche Viralität entsteht. Diesen Wunsch gibt es, glaube ich, jetzt gerade sehr groß. Das Herbeirepen des Bürgerkriegs.
Da sieht man noch echte Menschen, und man hat eine Vermutung darüber, dass man erfährt, wo der Hegemon gerade steht. Und das ist hier immer weniger der Fall, glaube ich.
Kommen wir zum Deutschlandfunk. Du hast eben schon betont, wie wichtig dann die klassischen Medien werden. Wir hören Deutschlandfunk. Dort war Sebastian Enskert zu Gast von der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung. Worum geht es denn da?
In ganz Europa gewinnen Rechtspopulisten an Wahlen und an Einfluss von den wahren Finnen in Finnland über den RN in Frankreich bis zu den Spartanern in Griechenland. Und in vielen Parlamenten stehen die Mitteparteien, die Konservativen, vor der Frage, tolerieren, koalieren oder Brandmauer. Das Gleiche gilt natürlich auch für das Europäische Parlament. Die CDU-nahe Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung hat jetzt in einer Studie untersucht, wie konservative Parteien in Europa mit den Rechtspopulisten jeweils umgehen. Zwischen Abgrenzung, Einbindung und Tolerierung ist der Titel der Analyse. Und einer der Autoren ist Sebastian Enskert von der Kassin Wien.
Wie mit ihnen umgehen, wie sie kategorisieren. Wie ist man überhaupt herangegangen an die Frage, wie recht sind die denn? Das ist ja eigentlich die Frage, wie weit können wir kooperieren? Wenn sie zu weit rechts sind, dann geht es offenbar nicht mehr. Die CDU-nahe Stiftung hat jetzt da Kriterien festgelegt, um das herauszufinden. Und die fand ich im höchsten Maße irritierend.
Also wenn wir über Rechtspopulisten sprechen, insgesamt vielleicht auch ein bisschen unglückliche Formulierung, dann ist das in Wirklichkeit ein sehr, sehr breites Spektrum an unterschiedlichen Parteien und dementsprechend auch sehr unterschiedliche Strategien im Umgang mit diesen Parteien.
Erstmal alles recht unterschiedlich.
Sie teilen diese rechtspopulistischen oder rechtsaußen Parteien in drei Kategorien ein. Da gibt es zum einen die gemäßigt rechtspopulistischen Parteien. Was zeichnet die aus? Und in welchen Ländern sind die besonders stark vertreten?
Was könnte das also sein?
Wir versuchen in diesem Spektrum zu zeigen, dass im Wesentlichen sind es drei Fragen, die man stellen kann. Wie ist das Verhältnis zu Europa und zur Europäischen Union? Wie ist das Verhältnis zum Rechtsstaat? Und im dritten Punkt, wie ist das Verhältnis zu Russland und dem Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine?
Wären dir diese drei Fragen als allererstes eingefallen?
Das ist ja völlig absurd. Ich kann mir das dritte gar nicht erklären. Ich weiß, dass die AfD in Ostdeutschland durch Nostalgie und andere Verklärungsversuche da irgendwie so eine Nähe hergestellt hat, aber das scheint mir doch nicht mit Melonis oder mit Le Penz oder mit...
Und auch nicht mit Adi Zweidels Kurs. Also das ist ein ziemlich spezieller Ostes Kurs und den wird man dann bei Höcke auch wiederfinden. Wenn man jetzt zur AfD nach NRW oder Baden-Württemberg geht, wird da mit der Ossand-Connection es eher schwierig werden. Rechtsstaat ist natürlich dann noch eine Frage. Also wollen die den Rechtsstaat aushebeln? Also das ist eine Frage, die sich stellt. Und bei der EU, naja, wollen die überhaupt noch aus der EU raus? Da habe ich ja schon mehrmals betont, wollen die eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Die sagen dann, wir brauchen Europa der Vaterländer, aber die wollen ja die Konstruktion nicht gänzlich verlassen. Das ist ja die frühe AfD, die wir so gar nicht mehr sehen. Also gibt es gemäßigte Parteien in diesem Spektrum?
Und da sieht man schon, dass es gemäßigte Parteien gibt in diesem Lager, die im Wesentlichen vielleicht Europa skeptisch sind, aber grundsätzlich sich zu Europa bekennen, nicht den Rechtsstaat bekämpfen und sich im Wesentlichen zur Ukraine bekennen und deren Recht auf Selbstverteidigung.
Ich werde das jetzt spoilern schon mal. Wir werden in diesem ganzen Gespräch, das zehn Minuten gedauert hat, nicht einmal das Wort Migration hören. Ich hätte ja jetzt, wenn ich über rechte Parteien nachdenke, zum Beispiel über Migrationspolitik, wie stehen die dazu? Wie stehen die zu der Anerkennung von gleichgeschlechtlichen Ehen? Wie stehen die zum Thema Antisemitismus? Wie stehen die zum Thema Rassismus? Das hätte mich ja doch interessiert. Also es hat ja doch eine gewisse Tradition den Rechten, dass das alles heikle Felder sind. Aber nein, das spielte hier keine Rolle. Wer gehört dann zu diesen Gemäßigten? Wir können das uns schon fast denken.
Und in diesem Topf sind zum Beispiel inzwischen, muss man sagen, die italienischen Fratelli d'Italia von Giorgia Meloni. Wir würden die Schweden-Demokraten dort einsortieren oder auch die tschechische ODS. Bei der tschechischen ODS oder bei einigen dieser Parteien, zumindest bei der tschechischen ODS, könnte man sogar fragen, ob dieses Label des Rechtspopulismus überhaupt noch angemessen ist. Deswegen heißen diese Parteien auch bei uns gemäßigt rechtspopulistische und konservative Parteien.
Bitte, also die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung will uns gerade versuchen zu erklären über Bande natürlich. Das ist ganz indirekt formuliert, aber dass die CSU und die CDU angeblich nicht auch ein bisschen rechtspopulistisch sind.
Ja, ja, da müssen wir nochmal drüber reden. Die Brandmauer ist ohnehin eine deutsche Eigenart. Ich glaube, da haben sie erstmal recht in der Aussage.
Ja, also ich glaube, eine ganz wichtige Botschaft, die von dieser Studie ausgeht, ist, dass Deutschland eine ganz große Ausnahme ist in Europa mit der sogenannten Brandmauer. Es gibt kaum noch Länder, in denen man von einer Brandmauer sprechen kann. Am ehesten vielleicht in Frankreich. Allerdings auch da müsste man, wenn man über Frankreich spricht, vielleicht auch nochmal über die Unterschiede sprechen. Aber Deutschland und dann meinetwegen Frankreich sind die große Ausnahme in Europa. In vielen anderen Ländern gab es nie eine Brandmauer. In vielen anderen Ländern ist sie schon vor vielen Jahren, teilweise Jahrzehnten, gefallen.
Was heißt das jetzt?
Der RN in Frankreich, den sehen Sie in Ihrer Analyse zu einer zweiten Kategorie, nationalistisch-rechtspopulistisch-parteien, ambivalente Haltung zur Demokratie. Dann gibt es noch eine dritte, autoritär-rechtspopulistische bzw. rechtsextreme Antisystemparteien. Sind diese Parteien in...
Rechtsextreme Antisystemparteien, müssen wir jetzt schon mal merken. Das ist also die dritte, die schlimmste Kategorie.
In den vergangenen Jahren noch mal stärker geworden.
Also sie sind im Vergleich eher nicht so stark. Das sieht man daran, dass es ja drei Fraktionen ganz weit rechts gibt im europäischen Parlament. Und in dem Fall entspricht das im Wesentlichen auch dieser Kategorie der autoritär-rechtspopulistischen und rechtsextremen Parteien. Die sind inzwischen fast ausschließlich versammelt in dieser Fraktion Europa der souveränen Nationen. Und da ist die AfD drin und da sind einige kleinere Parteien, die polnische Konfederatia und so. Also das ist wirklich die Gruppe der sehr extremen Parteien.
Also vielleicht ist das gar kein Studie, sondern einfach ein Deep Research. Und es hat gar nicht die Konrad-Anhaltungs-Stoftung gemacht, sondern so ein Typ, der Gemini bedienen kann. Denn ich habe gerade noch mal drüber nachgedacht. Die haben jetzt diese drei Kriterien.
EU, Rechtsstaat, Russland.
Genau. Das sind ja inhaltliche Fragestellungen, die diese Parteien einfach beantworten. Man guckt einfach ans Programm. Wollen die aus der EU aussteigen oder nicht? Möchten sie finanzielle militärische Unterstützung für die Ukraine? Ja oder nein? Und was weiß ich, haben sie was gegen das höchste Gericht oder sowas? Und dafür muss man ja keine Studie machen. Also das muss man ja nur nachlesen einfach, oder?
Und jetzt nach dieser Kategorisierung, die da vorgenommen wird, ist also die AfD bei den extremsten Rechten. Und ich sehe aber, dass die AfD sagt, wir brauchen fünf Prozent NATO-Ziel. Ich sehe nicht, dass die aus dem Euro gerade austreten oder die EU verlassen.
Also aus dem Euro sowieso nicht mehr.
Und den Rechtsstaat, da haben sie jetzt einen auf den Deckel bekommen, dass sie nicht Bürger zweiter Klasse einführen dürfen bei der Staatsbürgerschaft. Deshalb machen sie das jetzt nicht. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, das ist so eine strategische Selbstverharmlosung. Das ist natürlich immer die Frage, was ist in zehn Jahren? Das kann ich hier auch nicht beantworten. Ich kann nur sehen, dass also der Höckeflügel gerade nicht an Stärke gewonnen hat. Das ist ja ganz offensichtlich, sondern wir sehen, wie sich gerade zwei in Position bringen, quasi so eine Meloni-Kanzlerschaft anzutreten. Die eine ist Weidel und der andere ist Gra. Und da muss man dann schauen, wer sich da eher durchsetzen kann, wer noch über irgendwas stolpert. Da darf man gespannt sein zum Rassemblement National.
Die sind aber im Vergleich nicht die größte Gruppe, sondern in diesen drei Gruppen eher die kleinste Gruppe.
Also, ach nee, Entschuldigung, das war jetzt noch zu den sehr rechten. Da sind sie die kleinste Gruppe. Und nun, wie ist es dann mit der AfD?
Aber dass die AfD da drin ist, ist natürlich für den deutschen Fall eine interessante Schlussfolgerung. Und dann natürlich doch ein Argument, dass die Brandmauer gerade gegenüber dieser Partei sehr, sehr sinnvoll ist.
Also sie ordnen eigentlich die AfD falsch zu, sagen das aber, weil sie da auf der extremsten Seite sind, muss natürlich die Brandmauer bestehen. Bedeutet für mich aber eigentlich, dass man hier nahelegt, sollte die AfD dann doch mal diesen drei Kriterien entsprechen. Also nicht mehr Anti-EU, nicht mehr Anti-Rechtstaat, nicht mehr Pro-Russland, wo ich sagen würde, das ist ja eh schon der Fall. Dann brauchen wir vielleicht die Brandmauer nicht, oder wie ist das?
Aber der Arbeitsauftrag für die Leute ist ja, liebe Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung, hier spricht euer Parteichef. Ich brauche eine Argumentation, warum Brandmauer und diese Argumentation sollte die AfD abfackeln, aber die CDU nicht.
Deswegen dürft ihr nicht über Migration dabei reden.
Genau, da kommt man natürlich schon in Sofa-Wasser als CDU.
Sonst kommt Kollege Dobrindt ins Schwitzen.
Beim Thema, ups, also die Brandmauer macht nicht so richtig Sinn.
Und das ist etwas, was wir jetzt vielfach erleben werden. Man wird den Rechtsruck gar nicht mehr als eine migrationsfeindliche Politik wahrnehmen wollen, sondern wird nur noch sagen, ach, Rechtsruck, das sind die, die gegen Rechtsstaat sind oder die Putin treu sind oder was auch immer. Aber gegen Migration sind wir ja alle, auf glaube ich nur der andere Weise. Das ist jetzt das, woran sich die Mitte wird gewöhnen können. Und die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung legt hier vor, zumal es ja auch die zeitliche Dimension gibt.
Ich glaube, ein ganz wichtiger Faktor, den man in jedem Fall erwähnen muss, ist die Zeitdimension, dass diese Parteien nicht nur per se unterschiedlich sind, sondern dass sie sich auch permanent verändern. Einige werden radikaler, das sieht man bei der AfD in Deutschland, die in den letzten Jahren eher noch ein wenig radikaler geworden ist.
Ich sehe nicht, dass die AfD da radikaler geworden ist, sondern ich würde sagen, diese richtigen Ausfälle, auch verbal von Höcke oder Gauland, das haben wir lange so nicht vernommen.
Also wir wollen sie jagen und so, ist jetzt fast zehn Jahre alt.
Ja, also ich sehe diese Art der Radikalisierung nicht. Und ich würde auch hinzufügen, ja, es gibt da eine Zeitdimension und natürlich verändert sich die AfD, verändern sich andere Parteien. Ja, das ist der Punkt.
Verändern sich andere Parteien.
Eine Gewöhnungsdimension findet gerade statt, weil man sagt, ja, die Migrationsfeindlichkeit an sich ist schon richtig, aber vielleicht nicht ganz so laut, wie die AfD das macht. Bedeutet dann hier für den Herrn der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung?
Es gibt aber auch einige Parteien, die sich tatsächlich mäßigen. Und Giorgia Melonis Fratelli d'Italia sind so ein Beispiel, die sich über die Jahre... Genau, also das ist das Beste und natürlich auch deshalb am meisten debattierte Beispiel, weil Giorgia Meloni eben Regierungschefin ist und sich gerade in dieser Regierungsrolle noch einmal deutlich gemäßigt hat. Es gab ja große Sorgen, als sie an die Macht kamen, gerade im Hinblick auf die europäische Ebene. Und da kann man, glaube ich, heute sagen, sie ist eher ein stabilisierender Faktor in Europa, als ein destabilisierender, und das ist sicher eine gute Nachricht.
Ja, da können wir ja glücklich sein mit Georgia Meloni und ja.
Aber ich hör das immer so. Kann das auch immer jemand argumentieren? Ich höre immer nur so ein These, These, These, These. Sie ist so soft geworden und so.
Ja, sie tritt nicht aus der EU aus. Und sie unterstützt die NATO.
Aber das könnte man doch auch inhaltlich nochmal nachhaben.
Also was die mit Migranten macht, oder wie die die Sozialgesetze beschneidet.
Auch da so viel wie nie übrigens.
Wie dort Proteste beschnitten werden, das spielt doch alles gar keine Rolle. Solange außenpolitisch man an einem Strang zieht. Und das wird die AfD schon leisten. Und ich will deshalb nochmal diesen langen, aber doch sehr wichtigen Clip spielen, den wir mal in einem Salon uns angehört haben, nämlich von Friedrich Merz. Wir sind jetzt nochmal im Dezember, glaube ich, des vergangenen Jahres. Friedrich Merz hat dort einen CDU-Parteitag und spricht über die AfD. Und wir hören uns auch da mal die Kategorien an, die wichtig sind für eine Nichtzusammenarbeit mit der AfD.
Und ich kann den Wählerinnen und Wählern in Deutschland eines sehr klar und sehr deutlich versichern. Wir werden mit der Partei, die sich der Alternative für Deutschland nennt, nicht zusammenarbeiten. Vorher nicht, nachher nicht, niemals. Diese Partei steht für gegen alles. Diese Partei.
Hier auch wieder die Frage, so eine Selbstverständlichkeit, die allzu lange beklatscht wird, macht einen auch misstrauisch. Inzwischen stehen die Leute schon.
Liebe Freunde, diese Partei. Diese Partei steht gegen alles, was unsere Partei und unser Land in den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten in Deutschland aufgebaut hat.
Bin gespannt, kommt jetzt Migration?
Sie steht gegen die Westbindung, sie steht gegen den Euro, sie steht gegen die NATO und deshalb wollen wir gerade in diesem Wahlkampf alles tun, um diese Partei wieder so klein wie möglich zu machen. Es gibt keine Zusammenarbeit, es gibt keine Duldung, es gibt keine Minderheitsregierung. Sie ist der wichtigste Gegner für uns in diesem Wahlkampf. Wir wollen sie wieder klein machen, sie wollen wir zu einer Randerscheinung machen, da wo sie hingehört, liebe Freundinnen und Freunde. Und da gibt es kein Wenn und kein Aber, gar nichts gibt es da, mit uns zusammen zu machen. Gar nichts!
Westbindung, Euro, NATO, für die AfD in der jetzigen Form kaum noch ein Problem. Da sind noch ein paar, die müssen dann bei der AfD noch federn lassen. Aber an sich ist das, was hier aufgemacht wird, eigentlich ein Pappkamerad. Bedeutet also, nicht dass ich Friedrich Merz jetzt unterstelle, der will eigentlich mit der AfD koalieren. Was ich aber sage, ist, dass man hier schon einen Weg geebnet bekommt für eine Zusammenarbeit mit der AfD. Das wird dann vielleicht nicht ein Friedrich Merz sein, der das macht. Aber solange diese drei Kriterien, die er jetzt offenbar die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung nochmal bestätigt hat, erfüllt sind, ist also eine Zusammenarbeit möglich. Bedeutet also für 2029 dann wäre da einiges denkbar.
Also, richtige Nazis weinen ja nicht, wenn sie Syndagogen eröffnen. Deswegen ist Friedrich Merz keiner. Und über andere Massenmord reden wir halt nicht. Ja. Okay, sehr gut. Damit haben wir alles verhandelt. Wir gucken nur einen Clip, nur damit du schon mal angeheitert bist. Denn ich habe gestern nur noch nebensächlich geschrieben, ich hätte auch noch Markus Gabel-Clips. Aber nur wenn wir dazu kommen, dann hast du geschrieben unbedingt.
Ja.
Also liegen sie jetzt hier auf Halde für irgendwann mal, also nicht heute.
Wie spannend.
Aber einen kleinen 20 Sekunden warm machen, wo man so reinkommt ins Gespräch. Gucken wir uns doch an.
Die sagen im Grunde genommen längst vorher, welche Emotionen.
Ja, uns geht um die große Erkenntnis, dass die KI jetzt nicht nur Sprache kann, sondern auch Gefühle.
Die sagen im Grunde genommen längst vorher, welche Emotionen ich als Nächstes haben werde wahrscheinlich. Also wer in der Stimmung ist, so schnell scrollt, so tippt mit der Stimme, spricht in der Audiofunktion. Jemand, der sich so ausdrückt, fühlt sich wahrscheinlich gleich so.
Das ist jetzt schon der Fall?
Längst. Wow.
Mir gefällt auch, dass Markus Gabriel sich jetzt als Berlin-Mitte-Hipster verkleidet hat und nicht mehr im Anzug daherkommt. Und ja, ich bin so verblüfft, was das auch für Emotionen bei mir wieder auslösen wird. Nicht nur die KI, sondern auch Markus Gabriel.
Also wir gucken das auf jeden Fall noch spätestens im Dezember-Salon, dann auf der Bühne einfach, weil wir es vorher nicht unterkriegen, je nachdem, was jetzt im Oktober so passiert.
Wir sehen uns ja Mitte Oktober wieder, ein paar Tage später, als wir sonst veröffentlichen.
Wir warten auf ein Buch.
Ja, Richard-David Precht hat ein Buch geschrieben, es trägt den Titel Angststillstand, warum die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet.
Schwindelt?
Schwindet. Sie schwindet also, sie ist nicht schon weg, aber sie wird weniger oder ist nicht mehr so ganz da.
Ja, wir massieren dann im Salon so ein bisschen deine, aber ich bin sehr, also ich glaube, der Precht macht auch so ein paar Hackenschläge, die...
Ja, Angststillstand ist ja schon ein interessantes Wort. Also es hat offenbar etwas damit zu tun, dass aus Angst heraus die Meinung nicht gesagt wird oder nicht mehr gesagt werden kann. Wer macht da eigentlich wem Angst und wer hat vielleicht auch unbegründete Angst? Also das ist ein Buch, das wir unbedingt diskutieren müssen, denn ich beharre darauf, Meinungsfreiheit, Free Speech, das ist das große Thema, das wird uns noch lange beschäftigen. Und ich hoffe auch, dass es uns lange beschäftigt. Denn nur dann, wenn Free Speech gewährleistet ist, ist überhaupt Partizipation und Diskussion und all das möglich. Insofern werden wir da weiter streiten.
Ja, werden wir.
Sehr gut. Weißt du sonst schon, was du im Salon mitbringen willst?
Ja, es gibt Literatur. Ich habe sie noch nicht gelesen, aber es gibt sowohl zwei Texte, die uns KI noch mal erklären. Also zum einen hat man der KI gesagt, du darfst auch mal den Chat beenden, statt immer nur dir anzubieten, ich kann dir auch noch weiterhelfen und so. Und dann wollte man herausfinden, wann es das macht.
Ja.
Und offenbar gibt es Charme-Gefühle, die GBT dazutreiben. Na, ey, nach dem. Also so in diese Richtung habe ich Texte, da liegen die mich selber noch mal sehr interessieren. Ansonsten müsste ich jetzt noch mal nachgucken. Sag du doch schon mal, ich schaue noch mal nach.
Ich werde es mir noch sehr offen halten. Ich werde auf jeden Fall einen Roman mitbringen. Also immer etwas aus dem Bereich Benetristik und ich werde wieder einen Musiktipp dabei haben, will aber mir noch alles offenhalten bis dahin. Bin erst mal sehr gespannt auf das Buch von Richard David Precht. Wir haben eine neu gestaltete Homepage. Du hast sie neu gestaltet. neuezwanziger.de, es lohnt sich, da mal drauf zu gehen. Vor allem, wenn man den Podcast noch nicht abonniert hat, also beziehungsweise noch nicht die Bezahlschranke überwunden hat, noch nicht bei Steady, Patreon oder Apple ein Abo hat. Wir empfehlen ja immer Steady und es ist jetzt noch leichter zu erkennen, wo man hin muss, was man buchen kann. Also es ist jetzt so gemacht, dass sogar ich es verstehe.
Sehr gut. Also die Seite ist schon neu. Ich hatte mir die Herausforderung gestellt. Ich wollte immer meine Webseite haben, die so gar keinen technischen Fehler hat. Es gibt ja so verschiedene HTML-Validatoren oder Google Page Speed Insights. Gibt dir so Hinweise, wo deine Seite noch Schwächen hat. Diesmal ist alles ausgeräumt. Also ziemlich alles, außer dass der Server halt langsam ist oder langsamer als jetzt die weltbesten Server der Welt. Das heißt, das Grundgerüst steht. Das große Ziel ist natürlich, zu sagen, da gibt es eine Suchfenster drauf, auf denen man einfach die Frage stellt, wann haben Stefan und Wolfgang dieses und jenes Buch besprochen, war das und jenes schon mal Thema und dass dann eine Antwort kommt. Dazu muss allerdings der Datenbestand aller bisherigen Folgen noch mal aufbereitet werden, was einfach bedeutet, die Transkripte, die ja da sind, müssen noch mal neu zusammengefasst werden, weil die Transkripte selbst würden alle KI's überfordern, also auch so einen 5-Stunden-Dialog, mit Clips, 10-mal im Jahr und so, das ist einfach zu viel. Also nur die Transkriptebene ist schon zu viel. Aber ich suche noch den richtigen Prompt, um dann kapitelweise alles so zusammenzufassen, dass man es später als Suchindex gut verwenden kann, weil technisch gesehen ist alles dafür da, dass man das einfach einbaut. Das ist aber das Ziel bis zum Jahresende dann.
Gut, jetzt erst mal.
Und vielleicht auch nur für Salonmitglieder, die sich auf der Seite erst einloggen müssten.
Ach so, das könnte man machen.
Ja, ja, ja. Also solche Sachen haben natürlich Premium.
Wir wollen erst mal sowieso nicht nur mit solchen Anreizen kommen, sondern generell. Der Podcast lohnt sich und der Salon lohnt sich auch. Wir sprechen ausführlich dann über das Buch von Richard David Precht und empfehlen weitere Texte. Und wer den Salon abonniert hat, hat natürlich auch Zugang zu den Live-Salons und zu den vergangenen Salons. Also sehr viel ist zu hören, sehr viele Literatur zu entdecken. Am besten geht man auf neuzwanziger.de und kommt dann zu Steady. Dort kann man für drei Euro im Monat einen Abschluss dann tätigen. Man kann aber auch unseren Podcast auch über Patreon abonnieren, wenn man dort schon ist. Und wer sagt, ich möchte den Apple Cosmos gar nicht verlassen, kann das auch direkt über Apple buchen. Auch das ist ganz einfach zu machen. Und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr den Podcast auf diese Weise unterstützt.
So ist es. Wir sehen uns Ende, Mitte Oktober.